GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
HAVE A DEARTH OF MEMBERS SO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT A
LITTLE BIT BEFORE WE START OUR
HEARING WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE. ON TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO GIVE US A FEW MINUTES
ALL RIGHT LET'S DO A LITTLE BIT
OF THE HOUSEKEEPING FIRST BEFORE
WE ACTUALLY START THE HEARING
THEN. SO AGAIN WELCOME TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND I WILL
KNOW THAT WHILE THERE'S NO MORE
MASK REQUIREMENTS OR- PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENT WE DO ASK
THAT PEOPLE. REMAIN SAFE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO WEAR MASKS IF YOU'RE
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT AND-
LEAVE SOME ROOM BETWEEN FOLKS WE
ARE STILL IN THE PANDEMIC. AND
DO NOT WANT TO BE SPREADING THAT
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN HELP
IT. SO WE ARE GOING TO. BE ABLE
TO HAVE WITNESSES NOW IN THE
HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS ON THE
TELEPHONE WE TRY TO MAKE TEN.
BOTH AVENUES FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND THE ABILITY TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL. SO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THE
BILL YOU CAN BASS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WE DO ASK THAT
NOBODY. TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
THAT THE SERGEANTS MANAGE THAT
PLEASE. AND IF YOU ARE WISHING
TO COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE. THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER WHICH SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN AT THIS POINT IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN
THAT'S. 877-692-8957 THERE IS AN
ACCESS CODE WHICH IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN.
AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND WE HAVE AS
WE PROCEED WITH SORT OF THE
WITNESSES AND GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS THIS IS A FORMAL HEARING
SO WE DO ASK FOR DECORUM FROM
FOLKS THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF HEARINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISRUPTED AS OF LATE INTENSELY
DISRUPTIVE SO WE'RE ASKING. THAT
THERE ARE NO LOUD NOISES FROM
THE AUDIENCE OR DISRUPTION OR
TALKING WHILE SOMEONE ELSE IS
TALKING THERE ANY VIOLATIONS OF
THE RULES THIS CAN BE SUBJECT TO
BEING REMOVED FROM THE HEARING
ROOM. FOR THOSE ON THE TELEPHONE
. PLEASE IF YOU ARE A WITNESS
THAT'S FINE PLEASE STAY WITHIN A
WE GIVE ABOUT THREE MINUTES TO A
WITNESS STAY WITHIN THAT TIME
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE ADDING ON
WE JUST ASK FOR NAME AFFILIATION
AND HIS SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON
THE APPROPRIATE BILL WE HAVE
SOME BILLS SET FOR SPECIAL ORDER
OF BUSINESS AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK
AND THOSE ARE A B. TWO OH NINE
ONE BONTA AND AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WICKS WE ARE
EXPECTING A NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
CALL IN. SO I RESERVE TE RIGHT
TO LIMIT PUBLIC TESTIMONY DURING
THAT TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN GET THROUGH OUR AGENDA TODAY
WE SET THOSE LATER ON TO TRY AND
GET THROUGH TODAY'S AGENDA AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE AND
ALLOW APPROPRIATE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR THOSE SPECIAL
ORDERS OF BUSINESS I WILL. ALSO
NOTE. THAT THEIR VAN A COUPLE OF
ITEMS REMOVED FROM. THE CONSENT
AGENDA AND THAT IS ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN
DAVIES. AT ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN LOW WE ARE
EXPECTING TO HEAR THOSE TODAY.
AND ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY NINE BLANCA RUBIO IS
NOW ON THE CONSENT AGENDA I WILL
MAKE THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS AS WE-
HAVE A QUORUM AND ARE ABLE TO.
HERE THE CONSENT AGENDA WE ALSO
WILL BE HAVING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MATHIS AND THREE OF US JOINING
US TODAY TO FILL A COUPLE OF
WELL ONCE A- VACANCY THAT IS
FILLING IN. AND ONE IS FOR A
ANOTHER MEMBER WHO WILL NOT BE
WITH US TODAY. SO WE WILL BE I
THINK THIS DOWN ONE BUT- VISIBLY
COMMITTEE WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL WORK
AS A SUB COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW AND
MISTER BLUE OUR ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER. I HAVE A PLACE 2% AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE WHICH
REQUIRES LEVYING OFFICERS SUCH
AS SHERIFFS AND MARSHALS WHO
SERVE PROCESS IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE DOCUMENTS FOR SERVICE BY
FAX OR OTHER ELECTRONIC MEANS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
REQUEST CONTAINS AN ORIGINAL WET
SIGNATURE. AND WITHOUT
SUBSTANTIVE REVIEW. OF A VALID
COURT ORDER. I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND YOU THANK YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL MISTER CHAIR-
CURRENTLY THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IS TASKED WITH
SERVING COURT DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING RESTRAINING ORDERS AND
THE FILE LITIGANT ELECTS TO HAVE
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. SERVE
THOSE COURT DOCUMENTS THE
LITIGANT MUST COMPLETE A REQUEST
FOR SERVICE FORM AND DELIVER THE
FORM AND THE COURT DOCUMENTS TO
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN
ORDER TO HAVE THEM SERVED. AT
PRESENT THESE REQUEST FOR
SERVICE FORMS ARE CREATED BY
EACH SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
THE FORMS ARE UNIQUE TO EACH
COUNTY. IN MOST CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES THE REQUEST FOR SERVICE
FORM MUST BE PHYSICALLY SIGNED
BY THE APPLICANT USING A WET
SIGNATURE. AND DELIVERED IN
PERSON TO THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WITH THE DOCUMENTS TO
BE SERVED AND IT SHOULD BE
OBVIOUS SAID THAT THESE
REQUIREMENTS PRESENTS SOME
OBSTACLES TO LOW INCOME AND
RURAL THAT AGAINST. WHO DO NOT
HAVE A MEANS OF OBTAINING A
PRINTED COPY OF COURT DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE FILED AND RECEIVED
ELECTRONICALLY FROM THE COURT.
NORWAY TO TRANSPORT PAPER
DOCUMENTS TO A DISTANT SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. ANOTHER CHALLENGE
THAT LITIGANTS ARE FACING IN
SOME COUNTIES IS THAT SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS HAVE ENGAGED IN A
SUBSTANTIVE REVIEW OF COURT
ORDERS ALREADY REVIEWED AND
SIGNED BY A JUDGE. IN THESE
SITUATIONS THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT MAKES ITS OWN
INDEPENDENT DETERMINATION AS TO
WHETHER THEY THINK THE ORDER IS
VALID. BEFORE THEY AGREE TO
SERVE THE ORDER. THIS PUTS
LITIGANTS IN THE AND REASONABLE
POSITION OF HAVING TO GO BACK TO
COURT AND ASK A JUDICIAL OFFICER
TO RECONSIDER ORDERS THAT THEY
ALREADY RULED ON. AND SENATE
APPROVED TO SATISFY THE
UNNECESSARY SCRUTINY OF A
PROCESS SERVER. OF THESE
CHALLENGES DELAY THE PROCESS AND
INCREASE THE RISK OF HARM TO
LITIGANTS. SO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE MODERNIZES AND
STREAMLINES THE- CURRENT SYSTEM
TO ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES BY
REQUIRING. THE CREATION OF A
UNIFORM STATEWIDE SHARE
CONSTRUCTION FORM THAT WILL BE
UGH ARE PREPARED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. IT ALSO REQUIRES
LEVYING OFFICERS TO ACCEPT
ELECTRONICALLY SIGNED SHARE
CONSTRUCTION FORMS AND TO ACCEPT
DELIVERY OF DOCUMENTS FOR
SERVICE BY FAX OR ELECTRONIC
MAIL AND TO ACCEPT ANY ORDER FOR
SERVICE. AS LONG AS THE ORDER IS
SIGNED BY A JUDGE INCLUDING BY
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE WITH A
COURT ENDORSEMENT OR SEAL. THIS
BILL IS PARTICULARLY CRUCIAL FOR
ABUSE SURVIVORS WHO RELY HEAVILY
ON THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT FOR
SERVICE OF COURT DOCUMENTS
BECAUSE IN MANY CASES ESPECIALLY
WHERE FIREARMS MAY BE INVOLVED
SHARE SERVICE IS FAR SAFER FOR
THE VICTIM. I AM PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY AMANDA CHANG Q. WITH
THE LOS ANGELES CENTER FOR LAW
AND JUSTICE AND STEPHANIE PENROD
WITH THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
VIOLENCE LAWCENTER WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING REMOTELY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU MR WILL
AND I DO HAVE A MANDATE CHEN Q.
AND STEPHANIE PENROD. HAS LISTED
BOTH WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE.
AMANDA JANE Q. ARE YOU WITH US.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE. AT
THE- IN GEORGETOWN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLAN I AM THE
GENTLEMAN YOUR FAMILY LAW
ATTORNEY AT THE LOS ANGELES
CENTER FOR LAW AND JUSTICE AND
WE SERVE LOW INCOME SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND I
CURRENTLY RUN OUR STATE LIKE
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER
PROJECT. THE PRACTICE OF THIS
YEAR DEPARTMENT ENGAGING IN THIS
GRATUITOUS. SUBSTANTIVE OF COURT
ORDERS HAVE BEEN HOW FOR WELL
OVER TEN YEARS TO AN UNKNOWN
NUMBER OF LITIGANTS. BUT THE
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES ARE
EVIDENT FROM THE STORIES OF THE
SURVIVORS THAT WE CAN REACH. MY
COLLEAGUE PAULA CALLING FROM LA
FLAT ASSISTED A PREGNANT
SURVIVOR IN SEEKING A
RESTRAINING ORDER FOR HERSELF
AND HER UNBORN CHILD. AFTER
HISTORY OF ABUSE FROM A PARTNER
AND THE SUSPICIOUS DEATH OF THE
PARTY'S FIRST CHILD. HOWEVER THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT REFUSED TO
SERVE A RESTRAINING ORDER A
ROHINGYA FLEE INSISTING THAT AN
UNBORN CHILD WAS NOT A VALID
PROTECTED PARTY. AND THAT THEY
NEEDED A NAME AND DATE OF BIRTH.
EVEN WITH. MY COLLEAGUES POLICY
ADVOCATES SAY THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WINNING ADAMANT AND
THE ISSUE WOULD ONLY RESULT
AFTER THE JUDGE HERSELF CALLED
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO
INSIST THAT HER ORDER WAS VALID. AND SHOULD BE FACT. THE
REQUIRE OF PENSION SIX. THAT
HANDLE AFTER. AFTER EFFECTS ON
JULY. MICHAEL STEPHANIE PENROD
WILL TEST ABOUT THE NORTH CARE.
BUT WE HAVE THE STORIES AND SO
CAL. YEAH THAT'S SEVENTIES YEAR
OLD DISABLED SURVIVOR WHO WAS
TOLD SHE MUST HANDLE WEBER HER
RESTRAINING ORDER DOCUMENT. HE
NEARBY SHARE DEPARTMENT OR IN A
NEARBY COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIVE MILES AWAY WHICH IS ABOUT
THREE HOURS EACH WAY. WE HAVE
ANOTHER TV SURVIVOR WHO DROPPED
HER RESTRAINING ORDER AFTER SHE
WAS UNABLE TO TRAVEL IN PERSON.
TO THE SHERIFF'S. DEPARTMENT TO
REFLECT THEIR- THE LOADING
SURVIVORS THE ONES SUFFER. FROM
THESE PRACTICE BECAUSE BACK WHEN
SUMS AND WE- THEY OFTEN HAVE NO
OTHER ON. FOR OF. THE LAST LEVEL
TRANSFER. OR CHILDCARE AND
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THEY MAY
HAVE LANGUAGE BARRIERS- CYCLE
EMOTIONAL BARRIERS RELATED TO
TRAUMA OR DISABILITY. AND THE
EXAMPLE THAT WE SHARED TODAY ARE
OF THE LITIGANTS ARE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE LEGAL ASSISTANCE
IN NAVIGATING THESE BARRIERS.
BUT MOSTLY AGAINST DO NOT HAVE
AN ATTORNEY OR AN ADVOCATE AND
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
LITIGANTS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM. WITHOUT
HELP AND SUPPORT. AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE HELP SECURE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT. AND OTHERS BY ENSURING
THAT THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
COULD NOT IMPOSE UNREASONABLE
BARRIERS ON LITIGANTS ARE ASKING
THEM TO SERVE RESTRAINING ORDERS
AND OTHER DOCUMENTS. AND IT ALSO
BRINGS THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
IN LINE WITH THE PROGRESS OF THE
COURTS AND COUNTLESS OTHER
SYSTEM TO ARE NOW USING REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY TO ACCESS SERVICE
THAT. EXHAUSTED ALL OF OPTIONS
LOCAL TO TRY RESOLVE ISSUES WITH
ARTS DEPARTMENT BUT YOU KNOW
WITH. WHICH IS WHY WE SUPPORT
THE BUDGET. TO ADDRESS THESE AND
JEFF FIFTH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDER OF THE. TWENTY SEVEN
NINE ONE. THANK YOU. AND WE ALSO
HAVE STEPHANIE PENROD. YES GOOD
MORNING- GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE PENROD I'M THE
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT THE FAMILY
VIOLENCE LAWCENTER I'M A FAMILY
BIBLE TO RESTORE SERVICES
PROVIDER IN THE BAY AREA SERVING
PRIMARILY ALAMEDA COUNTY I'VE
BEEN WORKING IN THIS FIELD. FOR
OVER THIRTEEN YEARS AND I HAVE
WATCHED- I WOULD SAY HUNDREDS OF
WOULD AGAIN STRUGGLE WITH THE
OUTDATED INFLEXIBLE AND
UNREASONABLE REQUIREMENT OF THE
LOCAL SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS WHEN
ACCEPTING DOCUMENTS FOR SERVICE-
I HAVE. EXAMPLES FROM. KAY IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY- WE HAD ENTERED
REPRESENTING A TV DV. WHO NEED
TO SHARE OF SERVER ORDER HEARING
. THIS YEAR OF REVIEW TO X. AND
YOU THEN. OUT VERSION OF THE
ATTORNEY SAID. DEMANDING ABOUT
SIGNATURE ONLY IN REQUIRES HER
TO TAKE OUR OUT OF HER. STRIVE
TO ENSURE OFFICE. ALSO IN ON THE
- A. B. SURVIVE SUFFERING
BECAUSE THEY ENCOUNTER THE
STATEMENT. TO FOR WHAT. THE
LEGAL. THE HAD YOU OBTAIN. DRIVE
TO AND A WEST. FROM A COUPLE
POSITIVE. AND THEN THIS YEAR
ALSO HER IF THE CLIENT COULD
PERSONAL AND TO GET THE DOCKET.
ONLY ALLOWANCES AFTER IT. AT ON
BEHALF OF THE. AND ANOTHER LOCAL
COUNTY. WE HAVE NOT WITNESSED
CLIENTS. FOR UP TO TWO HOURS
WITH CHILDREN IN TOW PUBLIC. ALL
IN ORDER BRING SIGNTURES. TO
THE SHERIFF'S. OR WERE LYING ON
A- OUT. POLICIES INTO- THAT
REALLY MADE NO AND WHAT THAT
WERE LIVE IN TODAY. I WISH ORDER
WITH SERVICE LIKE A DOOR WITHOUT
HAND IT WON'T KEEP ANYONE IT.
AND REFUSAL TO SERVICE ORDERS
EFFECTIVE DENY THE RESTAURANT-ORDER IN THE ENTIRE. EVEN ANTI
ON A- BY POLICE. AND LEAVE THE
SURVIVORS AND THEIR SIX. WE ARE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND
PRINT ALL CAL. SURVIVE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE IN THE- OF FOR A BI TWENTY
SO NINETY. NOT GONNA TAKE IT
MORE TESTS BUT WE WILL TAKE
NAME. OF AND SUPPORT FOR BI
SEVEN ONE. MY GOD IS A GOD BRING
TRAURIG REPRESENTING.
PARTNERSHIP TANDEM BY IN SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU THE NEW ELSE.
RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU- OPEN
THE LINES ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. SUPPORT FOR A TWENTY NINE
ONE. GIVE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
IS ONE AND THEN 0% SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
NANCY GOLDBERG THE JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT OF
ALIGNMENT FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THERE WHAT MEN FROM
RAINBOWS SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES
AND STRONG SUPPORTER AB. TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO HAVE A SOME MUTE.
RIGHT EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT I'M I'M I'M WAITING
FOR EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA KNIGHT
BUYING THE LEGISLATIVE COALITION
TO PREVENT CHILD ABUSE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU HAVE TO GO TO
LINE UP FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PUBLISHED LATER COREY AS
THE COMMUNITY LEGAL AID SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ORDERED A PIZZA
USED. TWO SEVEN NINE ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ALISON MESSENGER WITH GENESIS
CENTER LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO
LINE AT THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MINTY STILL COULD NOT
COPY THE PEOPLE CONCERN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I DO NOT
HAVE ANY LISTED OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE. ALL RIGHT SAYING
NONE. OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE.
GIVEN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THEY'RE OFF IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE. MISTER TERRY HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IF YOU AT THIS TIME.
I THINK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE
THE LINES AND I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE MISTER
WILLOUGHBY MAKE CLUBS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THAT WITNESS
TESTIMONY REALLY I THINK
DRAMATICALLY DEMONSTRATES. WHY
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT AND-
ASPECT LAST FOREVER. THANK YOU
WE WILL TAKE IT UP ONCE WE HAVE
CORPS. RIGHT MR ARAMBULA US TO
BILLS WITH US. A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY N. TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE
START WITH AB NINETEEN NINETY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
THE FIRST WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS WHICH I
ACCEPT THANK YOU AB EIGHT
NINETEEN NINETY WILL STRENGTHEN
THE POLICIES AND LAWS WHICH WAS
ENACTED THROUGH EIGHTY A OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO UNDER GEORGE H.
W. BUSH. IN NINETEEN NINETY.
ALTHOUGH THE LANDMARK POLICIES
OF THE PAST HAVE MADE MAJOR
STRIDES FOR THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY MANY ASPECTS OF THE
STATE LAWS NEED TO BE UPDATED TO
ADJUST TO MODERN TIMES.
ESPECIALLY REGARDING MODERN
TECHNOLOGY. CALIFORNIA IS AND
HAS BEEN A NATIONWIDE LEADER AND
ENABLING LANDMARK LEGISLATION
FOCUSING ON THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. AB NINETEEN
NINETY WILL CONTINUE THIS
LEADERSHIP BY CREATING A WORK
GROUP TO ADDRESS THE UPDATED UP.
EXCUSE ME TO ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR UPDATING LAWS AND SERVICES
TO AIM TO SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES.
THIS LEGISLATION AIMS TO BRING
PEOPLE REPRESENTING THE MANY
FACES OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
VARIOUS DISABILITIES TO THE
TABLE FOR MUCH NEEDED
CONVERSATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
I AM JOINED TODAY WITH TWO
WITNESSES WHO ARE SUPPORTING AB
NINETEEN NINETY IN PERSON WE
HAVE ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND ON THE
PHONE WE HAVE CLAUDIA CENTER
REPRESENTING THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS EDUCATION AND DEFENSE
FUND. THANK YOU WE'LL START WITH
MISTER HARRIS IN THE ROOM GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ERIC HARRIS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA A
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT PROTECTION
AND ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF. OF ALL
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IN THE
STATE. WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF
AB NINETEEN NINETY. THE
DISABILITY MOVEMENT HAS GONE ON
FOR NEARLY A CENTURY WITH
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE EQUALITY
AND EQUALITY FOR ALL PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. DISABLED PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF ADVOCATE KNOWING
THAT WE CARRY ON THE INCREDIBLE
LEGACY OF DISABLED ADVOCATES AND
LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY'S
HISTORY BUT SPECIFICALLY
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. MANY OF
THE LEADING DISABILITY ADVOCATES
ARE FROM CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOUGHT AND WON BATTLES TO GET
SECTION FIVE OH FOUR OF THE
REHABILITATION ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES EDUCATION ACT
AND ULTIMATELY THE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT IN
NINETEEN NINETY. HOWEVER WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE ADA IS THE
FLOOR AND NOT THE CEILING THERE
ARE STILL SO MANY AREAS WERE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CAN IMPROVE
FOR PEOPLE WITH MOBILITY
DISABILITIES MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SENSORY DISABILITIES CHRONIC
PAIN AND TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES AND MORE. AB NINETEEN
NINETY WOULD FORM A WORK GROUP
FOR STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY BUSINESS
COMMUNITY LABOR EDUCATION AND
HEALTH CARE COMMUNITIES TO COME
TOGETHER TO PUT FORWARD IDEAS ON
WAYS THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DEVELOP
A CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AND
SHOULD BE THE LEADER ON
DISABILITY RIGHTS ACCESS AND
ENFORCEMENT AND AB NINETEEN
NINETY WOULD HELP OUR STATE
ACCOMPLISHED THAT. THANK YOU AND
WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU N. LOOKING ALSO FOR
CLAUDIA CENTER WHO'S WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE COMPANY AS PART OF
CENTER PLEASE GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME IS CLAUDIA CENTER AND I AM
THE LEGAL DIRECTOR OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS EDUCATION AND DEFENSE
FUND TRY TO FIT THE NATIONAL
NONPROFIT LAN POLICY CENTER THAT
IS DEDICATED TO PROTECTING AND
ADVANCING THE CIVIL RIGHTS.
CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WE ARE PART OF
THE LEGAL SERVICES SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SERVICE THE
SUPPORT CENTER TO FRONTLINE
LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER HARRIS SAID HAS
A LONG AND PROUD HISTORY OF
INDEPENDENT DISABILITY CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS THAT EITHER MEET OR
EXCEED FEDERAL LAW SANDERS. SO
FOR EXAMPLE. WHEN THE ADA WAS
ENACTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO PASSED AB TEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WHICH STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA LA
WHERE IT WAS WEAKER THAN THE
FEDERAL ADA. AND RETAINED
CALIFORNIA LAW WHERE IT WAS
STRONGER THAN THE AVIARY.
SOMETHING SIMILAR IN TWO
THOUSAND AFTER THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT WEAKEN THE ADA IN
A SERIES OF CASES. TWO TWENTY
TWO OR THE CURRENT K. POP THINK
ACT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE HARMFUL
FEDERAL COURT DECISION COULD NOT
GOVERN CALIFORNIA JURISPRUDENCE
. SIMILARLY AFTER CONGRESS
ENACTED SECTION FIVE OH EIGHT
AND NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA PASSED SB ONE OH FIVE
IN TWO THOUSAND CHU TO CREATE A
SIMILAR REQUIREMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. TODAY UNDER THE
GARDEN CONCORD CALIFORNIA TREES
BUT THE REVISED DISABILITY RIGHT
STANDARD TO BETTER MEET THE
CHALLENGES THAT DISABLED PEOPLE
FACE DAILY IN NAVIGATING OUR
MODERN AND OFTEN DIGITAL WORLD.
THIS WORLD IS DESIGNED BUILT AND
ORGANIZED BY AN ARRAY OF
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS THAT WERE
UNKNOWN JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
THERE IS A GREAT AND URGENT NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP. I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETY AND AS AN
EDITORIAL COMMENT I WOULD SAY
THAT- WELL AGREE WITH THE NEW
DEADLINE FOR THEIR REPORT- FROM
THE WORKING GROUP. IT MAY BE
THAT THERE ARE IDEAS COULD
EMERGE FROM THE WORKING GROUP
THAT THE- BODY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE ON BEFORE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TO
THAT. I THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
TO OTHER SINCE THE IS THERE ANY
IN HERE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN NINE. SEE NON OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN NINETY. YOUR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN NINETY
MAY PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN
NINETY. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE AT SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DAN OPEN POTS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN NINETY.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BROWN'S BLACK A
LONG TIME DISABILITY ADVOCATE
AND SUPPORTER OF BABY NINETEEN
NINETY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE
I THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
LISTED OPPOSITION BUT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
ARE PRETTY WOULD YOU OF THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN NINETY. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'SONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. NINETEEN NINETY. AND MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU I THANK YOU ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE THE LINES AND I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE RESEARCH DR ABDULAHI MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON AB
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE
CERTAINLY TAKE IT UP ONCE WE
HAVE A POOR. ALL RIGHT SO THEN
YOUR NEXT BILL AB TWO TWO S<c.cyan></c>
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
I FIRST WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE ARE GOING TO
MISS YOU AND- ROLE BUT ALSO
YOU'RE A COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN STRENGTHEN THIS BILL. FOR
THE RECORD I ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
FIVE WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS SAFEGUARD OPIOID
MEDICATIONS. AND REDUCE THE ACT
OF PILL. A POWERFUL ON RAMP TO
THE NATION'S CURRENT OPIOID
ADDICTION CRISIS. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE A PHARMACIST TO
PROVIDE SCHEDULED TO END TO END.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND A
LOCKABLE CONTAINER.
PRESCRIPTIONS SUCH AS MORPHINE
OXYCODONE AND REDOLENT.
HILFERDING WHICH IS THE ACT OF
SNEAKING A SMALL NUMBER OF PILLS
HOPING THAT IT WILL GO
UNDETECTED IS THE LEADING SOURCE
OF USED OPIOID ABUSE. THE
OUTDATED CHILD RESISTANT
PRESCRIPTION VIALS CURRENTLY IN
USE HAVE NOT BEEN MODIFIED IN
OVER FIFTY YEARS. WHEN THE
FEDERAL POISON PREVENTION
PACKAGING ACT WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THE GOAL THEN
WAS TO PREVENT CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF FIVE FROM GAINING
ACCESS TO ASPIRIN. TODAY THOSE
SAME CHILD LOCKS ARE USED TO
PROTECT MEDICATIONS THAT RANGE
FROM COUGH MEDICINE TO
PRESCRIPTION PAIN MANAGEMENT
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE EIGHTY
TIMES STRONGER THAN MORPHINE.
REQUIRING LOCKING PRESCRIPTION
VIALS FOR POWERFUL NARCOTICS IS
A LOW COST WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MODERNIZE THE ANTIQUATED FEDERAL
LAWS THAT ARE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR CAUSING THIS
NATIONWIDE EPIDEMIC. THERE ARE
TWO WITNESSES WHO WE HAVE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE PADDY VARGAS
REPRESENTING THE RECOVERY
ADVOCACY PROJECT AND SHERRY DALY
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS. GECKER ARAMBULA
TO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
SHERRY DALY PETTY VARGAS BOTH.
ON THE TELEPHONE JERRY DALY OR
PETTY VARGAS ARE YOU WITH US.
YOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA SHERRY WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND ADDICTION
COUNSELORS MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
TREATMENT PROGRAM THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY RECOVERY RESIDENCES. AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE RECOVERY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M HERE
TODAY TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR YOU
TWENTY TO SIXTY FIVE BUT THAT'S
AN EXPERT IN THE SUBJECT
TREATING FIELD AND PER AT A
PARENT. FOR MICHAEL STANDPOINT
WORKING WHILE TURNING IN
EXCELLENT AND VERY PREVENTION
MEASURE CONCERNING YOUNG ADULT
AND ADOLESCENT THIS AGE GROUP IS
MATURE ENOUGH TO CALCULATE RISK
REWARD POSSIBILITY FOR THE
ACTION. DELETE YOUR THREE CALLS
FROM OVER A PERIOD OF TIME THE
PARLOUS BE DETECTED THAT AN
ENTIRE OF MEDICATION SUDDENLY
GOING MISSING THERE
EXPERIMENTING WITH
PHARMACEUTICAL FROM HOME BUT WE
HAVEN'T HAD LITTLE TO. FROM THE
CURRENT GOAL TO PER. BUT FROM A
LIFE AND DEATH TEN POINT
CONSEQUENCES FROM BEHAVIOR
LITERALLY BE TO. AND IN OUR
LETTERS WHEN THE MUSIC ABOUT A
FAMILY IN INDIANA WHO
EXPERIENCED THE TRAGEDY THAT CAN
OCCUR WHEN THESE POWERFUL
MEDICATIONS ARE SHARED CATHOLIC
PARTIES AND MIXED WITH ALCOHOL
BECKY SAVAGE SAVAGE HAD TWO
AMAZING SONS NICK AND JACK LET
TALKY TALK ABOUT AND LATE NIGHT
HANGOUTS. WHEN IT CAME HOME FROM
COLLEGE CELEBRATE YOUNGER
BROTHER JACK HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION THE TO ATTEND A SMALL
PARTY WITH FRIENDS OR OPIOIDS
AND ALCOHOL WERE SHARED IN THE
MORNING WENT BACK HE WENT TO
PICK UP LAUNDRY IN JACK'S ROOM
AS WELL THE ONE THAT HOME FROM
COLLEGE SHE GOT HIM.
UNBELIEVABLY WELL SHE WAS
ADMINISTERING. PARAMEDICS
ARRIVED BUT WENT TOWARD THE BASE
NOT ONE ANOTHER CALL FOR
ASSISTANCE HAD BEEN RECEIVED
THAT NIGHT BECKY LOST TWO OF HER
FOUR SONS APPEARED OVERDOSE FROM
A PRETTY PRETTY. I THINK THIRTY
ABOUT HOME ALTHOUGH I WAS SCARED
THE HORRIFIC TRAGEDY BABBAGE
WILL HOLD IT TODAY. I AN ADMIN
OF ADDICTION TREATMENT FOR DE. I
BELIEVE MY CHILDREN HAD SOME
BECOME A- ORDER AFTER ALL I DID
ALL THE RIGHT THINGS I HAVE THE
TOP I DO ALL THE PERTINENT IN.
AND I TOLD THEM ENVIRONMENT PARK
SECOND COUSIN UNCLE WOULD BE OF
A.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL A FEW MONTHS
INTO MY CHILD RECOVERY THAT I
I'M SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS WHEN
MY CHILD TOLD ME THAT HER USE
BEGAN IN MY HOME THE LEFTOVER
NORCO FROM THE SURGERY I HAD I
WAS SHOCKED AND IN DISBELIEF MY
HEART THANK OF I THOUGHT. IF I
ONLY KNEW HOW MUCH PAIN AND
SUFFERING BECAUSE I AM SAVED MY
CHILD'S LIFE AND IN MY OWN
FAMILY HOW MUCH TIME DO WE LOSE
HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD BLOCK
PAYING PER MONTH THE RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT ALL BECAUSE HE DID NOT
HAVE AN EARLY WARNING SYSTEM IN
OUR HOME. IT TOO LATE FOR BECKY
AND THOUSANDS OF PARENTS WHO
JUST DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY
DIDN'T NOW WE CAN CHANGE THAT
WITH AB. TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR EYES OUT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. SO THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK AYE GOOD
MORNING HONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM COUNTY VARGAS I'M
HERE TODAY AT THE STATE
ORGANIZED THERE BUT THE RECOVERY
ADVOCACY PROJECT AS WELL AS THE
PARENT COACH WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP IN DETECTION I'M
ALSO A MOTHER WHO LOST MY SON
THE OPIOID ADDICTION AND HAVE A
DAUGHTER IN RECOVERY. FROM THE
THANK DEBATE. A. B. HONOR THANK
SELDOM WERE ABOUT MY TO POKER
MEDICATION FROM MY MEDICINES.
MAINLY THEY'RE WEREN'T ANY THERE
. BACK THERE I HAD IN THE TO
ARCOT AND NEVER TOOK ANY STAR
THAN. OR I. MY KIDS WANT TO SIX.
IT WAS GOING TO HAVE TO FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND GET. WHEN MY
SON WAS ABOUT SEVENTEEN I
LEARNED THAT HE AND SEVERAL OF
HIS FRIENDS HAD BEEN DEALING
HILLS FROM THEIR PARENTS A
LITTLE HERE A LITTLE THERE. AND
TRADING THEM BACK AND FORTH WITH
OTHER KIDS BATTLING THEM. TELL
CONTRIBUTION WITH WITHOUT OUT
AROUND I HAD NO IDEA THAT THE
MEDICATION I FOUGHT SO HARD FOR
MY SON TO BE PRESCRIBED. WHAT
THE HOT TICKET ON THE ILLICIT
MARKET. I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH ALL MY KIDS IN THE AGE OF
TEN AND ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
ALCOHOL AND MARIJUANA. I NEVER
EVEN CONSIDERED TALKING ABOUT
THE DAMAGE. PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COULD GET A- I THEY DO THE DRUGS
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN TO GET TO
CLAIM. SIMPLE DR EXPERIMENTATION
DOESN'T START WITH A NEEDLE IN
THE- IT STARTS WITH DRUGS THAT
EVERYTHING HE GETS HE LEADS
OPENING YOUR MOM MEDICINE
CABINET. RESEARCHERS THAT EIGHTY
PER OF THOSE PREDICT TO HEROIN
BEGAN BY USING PRESCRIPTION
OPIOIDS WHAT IT THERE WERE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO MAKE THEM
HARDER TO ACCESS. WHAT IS THAT
YOUNG PERSON HAD TO DO A QUICK
WITH SQUARE WARD IN FACT MUCH
MAKING A PILLAR TO HERE AND
THERE VERSUS THE ENTIRE BOTTLE
DISAPPEARING ALTOGETHER. LOCKING
HELD BY ALL. MEANS THE
CONVENTION MAKE IT NOT NOT THE
PATIENT. A LOT EASIER. TO MY
KIDS THE VENTURE GRADUALLY THE
OTHER GUYS THANK. HEROIN AND- WE
LOST INTO SEVEN. HE WAS A POET
I'M- HE WAS FINDING AND HE WAS
LOVED. ALL TO SENSITIVE AND BY
AN UNCLE. BUT THE NUMBER WITH
THE HE COULDN'T BE. I WISH I
HADN'T DONE COMPLY. ASSUMING
THAT MY IN LIGHT CONGRESO ABOUT
ALCOHOL AND THEY'RE A-
ACCURATELY. WHAT WOULD YOU GOING
ON AND THERE'S- IF I COULD
POSSIBLY THEM MANY. THAT TO A-
ULTIMATELY CAUGHT LIKE. BY IT
WOULD HAVE HEARTFELT HYUNDAI OF
THE- EACH. LEGAL FEES. AND OTHER
WITH THE COST NOT MENTION THAT
OF LOCKED AND TALK WITH YOU
TONIGHT. AB TWO SIX FIVE WILL
ENSURE THAT. TWO DRUG ARE
ACCEPTABLE ONLY BY THOSE WHO
NEED THEM I RESPECTFULLY URGE.
YOUR IPHONE. I THANK WE WILL TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANY IN THE HEARING WHO
WITH TO INDICATES A- FOR A
TWENTY TWO SIXTY. MISTER MEMBER
CHAIRS MARKET OUT ON BEHALF OF
SHATTERPROOF FOR ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS THE BILL. SHARE
NATIONAL. NATIONWIDE NON PROFIT-
COMMITTED TO ADDICTION AND
TREATMENT ISSUES THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
. RIGHT SEEING NONE ARE PRETTY
WOULD YOU OF THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO.
ONE TWENTY TWO YOU TOOK YOURSELF
OUT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR OPEN ONE TWENTY SEVEN. OKAY
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AM- FOR
EIGHT DAYS THE BILL THAT WOMAN
WAS TALKING ABOUT. REGARDING THE
DRUG. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT YES I'M WITH HABITS
OF WASTE AND I SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT TO ABOUT TO LIGHT ONE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YEAH HI ONE
BAKER. HI MY NAME IS LISA I LIVE
IN LA HABRA AND I OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. OKAY SO WE ARE ON
AB TWO TWO SIX FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. MSJ WE
HAVE NO MORE SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION I HAVE A LISTED
OPPOSITION LYNSEY COHORT IN.
HERE IN THE ROOM. FOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS ONE OF THE GOING ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN
DRUG STORES AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE. AT WOULD YOU
SHARE THE AUTHORS GOAL TO THIS
ISSUE WITH THIS ISSUE TO ADDRESS
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC- AND WE ARE
NOT AT ALL OPPOSED TO PATIENTS
BEING ABLE TO VOLUNTARILY USE
LOCKABLE PRESCRIPTION VIALS. ARE
CONCERNS INSTEAD CENTER ON THE
UNDUE BURDEN WE THINK THIS WILL
PLACE ON PHARMACIES. AND I'M
PATIENTS BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
THEIR MEDICATION. A PATIENT
MIGHT HAVE ANY NUMBER OF
CONDITIONS AND THEN TO A
PHARMACIST THAT MIGHT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO ACCESS
THEIR MEDICATION IN A WALKABLE
VILE- OR THEY MIGHT FORGET THEIR
PASSCODE MISPLACE IT BE UNABLE
TO RETRIEVE IT. AND NOT LEAVE
THEM WITHOUT ACCESS TO THEIR
MEDICATION. IN ADDITION TO THE
ACCESS ISSUES- THIS BILL WILL
PUT A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON PHARMACIES BY
REQUIRING PHARMACIES DIFFERENTLY
THE COST OF THE LOCKABLE VIALS
AND SEEK REIMBURSEMENT FROM
MANUFACTURERS. I AM CURRENT COST
OF CURRENT CHILD SAFE M. VILES
ARE PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR
WHERE'S THE LOCKABLE VIALS CAN
COST MORE THAN THE MEDICATION
THEY CONTAIN. IN ADDITION TO
THAT- PHARMACIES DON'T INTERACT
DIRECTLY WITH MANUFACTURES WE
CURRENTLY- INTERACT WITH
WHOLESALERS FOR THE ACT
ACQUISITION OF DRUGS SO TO M.
EMPLOYMENT THIS WILL HAVE TO
CREATE AN ENTIRE NEW ACCOUNTING
PROCESS JUST TO RECEIVE. AM
REIMBURSEMENT AND THIS WILL
HINDER PHARMACY WORKFLOW AND
DISTRACT FROM PATIENT CARE. AND
LAST THING I WANT TO RAISE THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY ENACTED A
BILL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE. WHICH
REQUIRES CHAIN PHARMACIES TO
PROMINENTLY DISPLAY SAFE STORAGE
PRODUCTS THAT THE PATIENTS IF
THEY WISH TO USE THESE. THEY ARE
ABLE TO DO SO- THIS WAS ONLY
BEEN EFFECT FOR THREE YEARS I
THINK IT IS PREMATURE TO
IMPLEMENT A MANDATE AND WITHOUT
FIRST EXAMINING THE FINANCING IF
IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE. IN
ADDRESSING PRESCRIPTION DRUG
THEFT AND ABUSE. I DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE WOULD
REMOVE OPPOSITION. IF THE BILL
WAS MADE VOLUNTARY THE LOCKABLE
VIALS AND IF THE BURDENSOME
ADMINISTRATIVE AND FINANCIAL
REQUIREMENTS ON PHARMACIES ARE
REMOVED AND JUST WANT TO
REITERATE. OUR COMMITMENT TO
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WHAT THE
AUTHOR WITH THE LEGISLATURE BUT
TODAY UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE A- TO AB.
TWO S<c.cyan> FIVE. SIGNUP ALL RIGHT</c>
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE. AND WE HAVE A TWENTY
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET THEIR
LINE NUMBER. AND AS A REMINDER
WE ARE ON A. B. TWO TWO SIX FIVE
IN OPPOSITION. W'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE RESPECTFULLY
HERE AND- AND OPPOSED AND MUST
AMENDED PETITION. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SO I HAD. SHAKHTAR
CAT ABOUT PLANNED I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE BASED ON THE WAY THE BILL
IS FOR. THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- I WAS CALLING
IN TO OPPOSE THE BILL. GIVE
AMATEUR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE THE LINES WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. CIGNA DOCTOR
ABILITY MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS DIFFICULT
TOPIC. I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS AS QUOTED FROM THE LETTER
OF SUPPORT BY THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
THE RATE OF CHILD POISONINGS
FROM ACCIDENTAL INGESTION OF
HOUSEHOLD MEDICATIONS PROMPTED.
THE INVENTION AND REQUIREMENT OF
CHILD PROOF PRESCRIPTION
BOTTLES. TODAY IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WE CONTINUE TO RELY ON THOSE
SAME CHILD PROOF BOTTLES. BUT
THE PROBLEM IS NO LONGER
ACCIDENTAL POISONING. THE
PROBLEM IS PILFERED. AND OUR
OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND TO DEAL WITH
THIS PROBLEM WE NEED A DIFFERENT
SOLUTION. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
FIVE WILL PREVENT PILFERING AND
EARLY OPIATE OPIOID USE IN
CHILDREN AND TEENS. BY REQUIRING
LOCKABLE VIALS AT THE TIME OF
DISPENSING. I RESPECTFULLY WILL
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
AND WE CERTAINLY WILL ONCE WE
GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU. RIGHT
WILL MOVE TO OUR ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. THIS
CALDERON.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE FOR
REQUIRED VEHICLE HISTORY REPORT
PROVIDERS TO INCLUDE THE NAME
MAILING ADDRESS PHONE NUMBER AND
EMAIL OF THE SOURCE FOR EACH
ITEM CONTAINED ON THEIR VEHICLE
HISTORY REPORT. VEHICLE HISTORY
REPORT PROVIDERS AGGREGATE DATA
FROM VARIOUS SOURCES TO COMPILE
REPORTS THAT PROVIDE HELPFUL
INFORMATION ABOUT A VEHICLE SUCH
AS PREVIOUS OWNERSHIP SERVICE
HISTORY AND PRIOR COLLISION.
SOMETIMES THESE REPORTS CONTAIN
INCORRECT INFORMATION WHICH CAN
QUICKLY DEVALUE OF VEHICLE AND
MAKE IT HARDER FOR CAR OWNER TO
SELL. REQUIRING THE INCLUSION OF
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR EACH
ITEM ON A VEHICLE HISTORY REPORT
WILL MAKE ERRORS EASIER TO FIX
FOR CONSUMERS AND WILL INCREASE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. WE'VE
RECEIVED OUT REACH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CARTER CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION EXPERIAN AND
CARFAX REGARDING THEIR CONCERNS
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OPPOSITION ON ADDRESSING
THEIR CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
LISTED IN SUPPORT BUT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE O SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. GIVE
YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVES OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE. MISTER TERRIFY ME
AND WE DO HAVE ONE- AND
REGISTERED OPPOSITION- GEORGE
MILLER FROM CARFAX IS ON THE
LINE OKAY I WAS GONNA GO TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. RIGHT
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. YEAH. IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GEORGE MILLER
ON BEHALF OF CAR TAX- WE
APPRECIATE THE OPERAS AND DALTON
SAYS AFTERNOON AS WE- WERE LATE
GETTING A LETTER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER AND
YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THE- THE
FRUSTRATIONS THAT THAT SOME
CONSUMERS FEEL PLAN- PERHAPS THE
VEHICLE HAS NOT BEEN IN AN
ACCIDENT PERHAPS A BETTER NUMBER
HAD A DIGIT OPTED MISSILE TODAY
IN IN THIS FRUSTRATION. THAT
THEY FEEL AND- YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE BILL DOES
WOULD MANDATE THAT ALL SOURCES
OF ANYTHING ON YOUR VEHICLE THIS
REPORT GIVE YOU. THE INFORMATION
TO TRACK IT DOWN UNFORTUNATELY
ENTITIES LIKE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THEY DON'T HOUSE THAT STAFFING
OR MANPOWER TO DEAL WITH-
NUMEROUS. CONSUMER ENQUIRIES OR
TO SET UP DEDICATED- ENTITIES
FOR THAT IN PART OF THE DEAL
WITH CAR FAXES AT THAT IS THAT
THEY WILL DEAL DIRECTLY WITH
EACH OF THOSE INDIVIDUAL
ENTITIES AND MAKE SURE TO TRY TO
RESOLVE THE CONSUMERS ISSUES. IN
FACT THE AVERAGE TIME FOR
CONSUMERS TO HAVE THEIR ISSUE
RESOLVED IS ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY
FOUR TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS HELLO
FRUSTRATING FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMER I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE PREPONDERANCE OF THE
WHOLE THE BENEFITS THAT THAT
CALIFORNIANS. AT LARGE GET
MEDDLING THAT A CAR HAS NOT BEEN
SALAS DOES NOT HAVE OPEN RECALLS
EXCITER IT IS OUTWEIGHED BY THE-
UNFORTUNATE. FRUSTRATION IF YOU
. WE LOOK FORWARD OR WITH THE
AUTHOR SHE'S BEEN VERY GRACIOUS
IN OUR TIME AND- LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS HIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY
SPEAK YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
MOVE ON TO ONE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES IF YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW.
YELLOWHEAD YEAH- I'M CALLING TO
PROTEST THE- YOU HAVE THREE
BILLS THAT ARE BEING- LISTEN TO
RIGHT NOW WE ARE ON AB AND THE
SEVENTY ONE. A. B. TWO TWO TWO
THREE I'M SORRY THAT IS NOT IN
FORCE RIGHT NOW. WE ARE NAY BE
ABLE YOU KNOW ANYONE. EIGHT AB
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE OKAY I'M NOT
CALLING ABOUT THAT ONE ALL RIGHT
HEY REMEMBER ONE. ACTIVATED I AM
AT SIX. I'M CALLING ABOUT IT
SEVEN ONE ALSO. ARE YOU STILL
THERE- EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. I KNOW
YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT. OPERATOR
MOVE UP PLEASE AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. SO WITH
THAT ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE
LINES WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEEING NONE. CALDERON YOU
MAY CLOSE. I JUST LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL AND I
AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
EXPECT LESS RELIABLE THANK YOU
AND AGAIN WE WILL TAKE IT UP
ONCE WE HAVE CORPS. THANK YOU
OPERATOR OUR ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX MISREAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING I FELT LIKE
IT'S MORNING. THE MORNING OR.
OKAY HI HI. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBER I TO THANK OF
ALL THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL- I AM
SAID ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THE DEFINITIONS USED IN THE BILL
THESE MOMENTS APPEAR IN MOCK UP
FORM ON PAGES TEN AND ELEVEN OF
THE ANALYSIS I THINK ALL OF US
WOULD HAVE HAD THE EXPERIENCE IF
YOU BUY ANYTHING ONLINE OF
GETTING YOUR WHICH IT IN THE
MAIL AND THEN BEING ASTOUNDED BY
THE AMOUNT OF NON RECYCLABLE
PLASTIC THAT HAS COME UP WITH
THAT WHICH IT. WITH THIS BILL
TRIES TO DO IS TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BY GOING AFTER WHAT'S
REALLY THE LOW HANGING FRUIT OF
NON RECYCLABLE PLASTIC MATERIAL
WHICH IS THIS ADDED PACKAGING
WHICH WE KNOW IS NOT NECESSARY-
THERE ARE. ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET TODAY
THAT WILL BE EITHER COMPOSTABLE
OR RECYCLABLE AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO REQUIRE WITHIN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME R. E.
RETAILERS TO START USING WE HAVE
PUT REASONABLE EXEMPTIONS AND
LONGER TIME FRAMES IN THE BILL
FOR MATERIALS THAT ARE MORE
DIFFICULT TO PACKAGE AND I CAN
TELL YOU FROM EXPERIENCE AS
SOMEONE WHO HAD AN ART GLASS
COMPANY WHERE I WAS LITERALLY
SHIPPING FRAGILE GLASS AROUND
THE WORLD THAT THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE THAT WORK
EVEN FOR FRAGILE ITEMS. BUT IT
TAKES A CALIFORNIA TO PUSH THE
MARKET TO SET TO THAT THAT
STANDARD SO THAT THE DEVELOPERS
OF THIS TYPE OF MATERIAL SCALE
IT UP GET IT OUT GET IT TO
STAPLES GET INTO TARGET SO THAT
EVEN THE SMALL GUY AT HOME CAN
BY IT AS THEY VERY MUCH WANT TO
AND LASTLY I'LL JUST SAY THAT
THE- BRUNT OF ALL OF THIS NON
RECYCLABLE PLASTIC IS BEING PAID
FOR BY RATE PAYERS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IF YOU LIVE IN A
MUNICIPALITY YOUR TRASH FEES ARE
GOING UP BECAUSE THE LANDFILLS
ARE FILLING UP WITH THIS
MATERIAL IT'S GUMMING UP THE
RECYCLE MACHINES BECAUSE IT GETS
STUCK IN THOSE MACHINES. IT'S
REALLY A PROBLEM THAT WE'RE ALL
HAVING TO PAY FOR AND SO FAR
AFFECTS SOME RETAILERS HAVE BEEN
GOOD ACTORS BUT NOT ALL OF THEM
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY TAKES THIS SERIOUSLY-
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR MARINE
LIFE OF OUR ENVIRONMENT WE ARE I
DON'T I ALSO WANT TO SAY TO.
THIS BILL WAS NOT MEANT TO BE A
STATEMENT THIS IS MEANT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT IS WORKABLE. BY
ALL SHIPPERS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY HARD WITH INDUSTRY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE MISSUS
MOVE FOR THE PROCESS. TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THEIR CONCERNS WE HAVE
BEEN LIMITING THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL. TRYING TO FOCUS THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL BY TALKING WITH
INDUSTRY AMERICAN COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THAT WORK. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX OUR TERROR BROKE WITH
OCEANIA. AND LAURA D. HIM WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO YOU HAVE
THOSE TWO WITNESSES LISTED TERRA
BROCK AND LAURA D. HAN. TERROR
BROKER YOU ON THE LINE WITH US.
AND THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TERRA BROCK
AND I AM PACIFIC COUNCIL FOR THE
OCEAN CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION
OCEANICA. ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA MEMBERS.
OCEAN IT PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY TWENTY THANKS. TO
REDUCE THE HARMFUL IMPACTS OF
UNNECESSARY SINGLE USE PLASTIC
USED TO SHIP PRODUCT TO
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS FROM ONLINE
RETAIL PARTS OF THAT. ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION
IS NOW BUYING ONLINE. AND
PLASTIC PACKAGING FROM
E-COMMERCE IS ESTIMATED TO MORE
THAN DOUBLE BY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
PRACTICAL ALTERNATIVES TO SINGLE
USE PLASTIC SHIPPING ENVELOPES
BUBBLE WRAP AND POLYSTYRENE
PACKAGING ARE AVAILABLE. AND ARE
MANUFACTURED IN THE US AND EVEN
IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
ALTERNATIVES CAN AND SHOULD BE
USED MORE WIDELY. UNSURPRISINGLY
ABOUT PUBLIC SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
LIKE AB TWENTY TWENTY THANK. AS
YOU HEARD FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- WE ARE ALL BEING THIS
PLASTIC IN OUR HOME. AND NEW
POLLING RELEASED LAST MONTH
FINDS THAT 73% OF VOTERS SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT REDUCE THE USE OF
PLASTIC PACKAGING FROM ONLINE
SHOPPING. CALIFORNIA MY- AB
TWENTY TWENTY THANK COMES THAT
THEY COMES AT A TIME WHEN FAILED
IN E-COMMERCE MARKET PLACE HAVE
GUY ROCKET WITH CALIFORNIA
LEADING THE COUNTRY IN ONLINE
SHOPPING. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE ESTABLISH REQUIREMENTS THAT
INSURANCE PACKAGES SENT IN AND
INTO THE STATE OUR PACKAGE AT
THE FAMOUSLY AND RESPONSIBLY IF
POSSIBLE. WE THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR REFINING THE DEFINITIONS OF
SEVERAL TERMS IN THE BILL TO
BETTER CLARIFY THE SCOPE AND
INTENT. AND WE THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND THANK
YOU AYE TEARS DOWN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA BURKE CO AUTHORING
THIS EFFORT. WE URGE AND I
ABOUT. THANK YOU AND THEN LOW
DHEA. YES THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LAURA D. HAN AND I'M THAT STATE
DIRECTOR FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA WHERE A STATE WIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION
WORKING FOR CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER AND A LIVABLE PLANET AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX ALONG WITH
OSHANA AND CALPERS. IT'S
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE GLOBAL PLASTICS
CRISIS BY STATING THAT THE
UNNECESSARY AND UNACCEPTABLE
AMOUNT OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC.
USED TO SHIP ONLINE PURCHASES.
AND THE CALIFORNIA. IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT TWO DUMP TRUCKS
WORTH OF PLASTIC END UP IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT EVERY MINUTE. AND WE
KNOW NOW THAT THIS PLASTIC
DOESN'T JUST GO AWAY AND INSTEAD
IT BREAKS UP INTO SMALLER AND
SMALLER PIECES THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN DISCOVERED IN EVERY CORNER
OF THE GLOBE. LITTERING OUR
STREETS POLLUTING THE OCEAN AND
HARMING WILDLIFE. MICROPLASTICS
HAVE NOT EVEN BEEN INVITED AND
STATE FOOD AND BEVERAGES
EXPOSING HAS HAPPENED A CONTENT
AND ADVOCATE. AND THE PLASTIC
PACKAGING ADDED ONLINE PURCHASES
DURING SHIPMENT INCLUDING THE
PLASTIC MAILING ENVELOPE- HELLO
IT'S BUBBLE WRAP EXPANDED
POLYSTYRENE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTOR GET THIS CRISIS.
ALMOST ALL OF THE PLASTIC
PACKAGING IS DISCARDED
IMMEDIATELY AFTER A PACKAGES
OKAY AND IT'S NOT BE USED OR
RECYCLED THE PLASTIC INSTEAD END
UP IN LANDFILL FOR IT GETS
BURNED OR LOWERED INTO WATER
RATES WHERE IT CAN PROCESS THAT
THE COALITION OR GENERATION. AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE RECENT
DRAMATIC. GROWTH OF ONLINE
SHOPPING. ONE OF PACKAGING THAT
DOESN'T COVER OUR ENVIRONMENT
OUR HARM PUBLIC HEALTH. OR COST
OUR COMMUNITY RESOURCE SAYS
CLEANING UP. AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX IS AN IMPORTANT AND URGENT
BILL AIMED AT ADDRESSING.
AUTOMATICALLY WHAT SPARE A BIRDS
THE THING MARINE MY ANOTHER
WILDLIFE FROM THE HARM CAUSED BY
UNNECESSARY PLASTIC POLLUTION WE
DON'T REMEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THAT AS WELL AS MR
CHARACTER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
SUPPORT AND WE URGE I YOUR I
BOUGHT. I THANK YOU WILL NOW GO
TO OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM. OCEAN
CONSERVANCY CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION
AND DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HELLO GONZALEZ POTTER
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. WILL NOT TAKE ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT JUST NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. GIVE
YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE OUT THERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE IS SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DANIEL BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GO TO LINE A ONE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JENNIFER TANNER INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BEANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU SEVEN ONE
TREATMENT FOR THE L. THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY SIXTY LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI NICOLE
CURRY IN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FIND ONE OF
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE NUMBERS REFLECTED OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING BEHIND
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND STOP PLACED IN
SUPPORT YEAH. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE YOU
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONENTAL VOTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL
JARRETT REPRESENTING THAT
CALIFORNIANS TO PROVIDE
DIVERSITY IN THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE A SEVENTY SIX YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JIM WOOD
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN THE. THANK YOU
NEXT CAROLINA SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
NUMBERS GENEVIEVE AVEDON CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
CLEANS HE'S LOBBYING COALITION
MEMBERS SAVE OUR SHORES THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION. THE FIVE
GYRES INSTITUTE HEAL THE BAY
PLASTIC OCEANS INTERNATIONAL
WHICH CHOI CHU MUCH FOUNDATION
ZERO WASTE USA IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NOT TO GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JENNINGS JOHN MUHAMMAD
CALPERS CALLING THE TRUMP REPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHERYL KUNIO IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CHAPTER OF THE
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE AT SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AMBER BUT
THERE ARE PER OF THE MARINE
MAMMAL CARE CENTER LOS ANGELES
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXUS ONE
IS SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. KATRINA CANTRELL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WOMEN'S HEALTH
SPECIALISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT IS OUR LINE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BEACON DANIEL GRAHAM WITH
INTRICATE STOLEN VERITY NETWORK
IN LOS ANGELES IN UNEQUIVOCALLY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR IT WOULD BE
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO AT LEAST CALLED
BY AND WITH THE GLENDALE
ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GO TO LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY LET ME.
YES REYES- MY NAME IS RAJ AND
I'M GOING ABOUT THE CARING AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
HEARING ON MAYBE TWENTY TWENTY.
FIVE BETTER TALK JUST LIKE THEM
ACROSS THE MRNA SO WE SHOULD
THEM THANK YOU. THANK A VIRTUAL
OF SIR TWO LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
. I THIS IS JUDY SO. I'M OF ALL
WITH THREE FIVE OH BAY AREA
ACTION AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SUPPORTERS WE
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN KILL
THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. WE TALK ABOUT
. EITHER YEAH.
MORNING CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE AT
REGULAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ONE OF THE BEGIN AND WE HAVE A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
SKEWS ME WE WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
STAFF THE AUTHOR NGO COMMUNITY-
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS WHO WORKED
ON THE AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THE
SCOPE WE APPRECIATE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THIS BILL IS
BANNING AND WHAT IS NOT BANNING
IT DOESN'T REMOVE OUR OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AT THIS
TIME BUT- WHAT WHAT WE DO HAVE
REMAINING CONCERNS ABOUT- IS
REALLY AROUND THE PACKAGING
THAT. IS BANNED THAT WE DO WE
DISAGREE IS NOT CRITICAL TO
SHIPPING- THEY REALLY HUNDRED OF
CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S
TELEVISIONS LCD MONITORS-
PRINTERS APPLIANCES X. THAT ARE
USING EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE- WE
DO. I DISAGREE THAT SHIPPING
GLASS VERSUS SHIPPING. HI THE
BREAKABLE OF TRONICS IN WHICH
THE B. S. THE SHOCK- IMPACTS
FROM SHIPPING FROM EAST ASIA
INTO THE UNITED STATES- HAS VERY
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
PACKAGING REQUIREMENTS AND SO
THERE IS NO- EPS BAND ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD ON THESE DURABLE
GOODS REPRESENTS ZERO POINT 5%
OF OUR WASTE STREAM WE WHOLLY
AGREE WITH IMPROVING THAT THE
RECYCLING CALIFORNIA- THE SOURCE
REDUCTION OF SUPERFLUOUS
PACKAGING. THAT MANUFACTURES
NEED TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND
ACTUALLY PAY FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- TO RECYCLE THIS
AND IF WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS IN A VACUUM AB ONE THING WE
ARE CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING A
CIRCULAR FIRST IN THE NATION-
BROADER THAT- RECYCLING BILL
THAT COVERS ALL THE SAME
PACKAGING THAT IS CURRENTLY
BANNED UNDER THIS BILL. AND SO
WE THINK IT'S PREMATURE AND
INCONGRUENT WITH THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND IN FACT. WE
THINK IT'S- COULD LEAD TO
PERVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES
IF YOU HAVE TO SHIP- LITERALLY
MILLIONS OF TV'S OR OTHER BREAK
BILLS BACK TO THEIR- ORIGIN
WHETHER IT'S GREENHOUSE GAS
SHIPPING IT BACK OR LANDFILLING
MUCH MORE. UP LARGER BREAKABLE
AND WORSE- IN MARBLE OUTCOMES
THROUGH LANDFILLING THESE
PRODUCTS THAT BREAK AND SO WE
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TO TRY TO FIND A- COMPROMISE
THAT. I THINK FALLS INTO THE
BROADER CIRCULAR ECONOMY
DISCUSSIONS WHICH CALCHAMBER ITS
MEMBERS ARE WHOLLY ENGAGED AT
THIS TIME AND SO WITH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR OPPORTUNITY COMMENTS
THANKS. THANK YOU. THAT'S WITH
WITH A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TIM CHESTED WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- I'VE
GOT TO WANT TO. ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- TO HELP CLARIFY THE
AT THE SCOPE OF THE BILL. AND
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO OUR- THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE I WANT TO
REITERATE TOO MUCH WITH. THAT MR
WRIGLEY SAID BUT WELL WE
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT- MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO REDUCE THEAMOUNT
OF PLASTIC WASTE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT. THAT'S WHY WE ARE INVOLVED
WITH CENTER ALLEN IN THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT HE'S
PULLING TOGETHER TO CREATE THAT
FRAMEWORK TO CREATE A POLICY
WHERE YOU HAVE. A 75% RECYCLING
REQUIREMENT BY TWENTY THIRTY
TWO. SOURCE REDUCTION
REQUIREMENTS ON PRODUCERS
PRODUCER PAY FEES TO HELP
INCREASE- THE COLLECTION AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE SO
WE CAN PROCESS IT. THIS MATERIAL
. AS WELL AS REQUIRING PACKAGING
TO CONTAIN A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
RECYCLED MATERIAL SO WE CAN
CLOSE THAT LOOP- AND MAKE SURE
THAT NO MUCH MORE MATERIAL. IN
UP IN A LANDFILL OR OR IN THE
OCEAN SO WE DO ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
LOOK FOR WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
IS A BILL MOST OF THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN ALLIANCE
TO ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. GIVEN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THERE OF THE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. WE WILL GO TO LINE AT ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEFFREY LEE TALKS ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN CLEANING INSTITUTE
. PRESENTING THE LEADING
MANUFACTURERS OF CLEANING
PRODUCTS. THAT WE ARE OPPOSE
MUST AMENDED THE REASON STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE AT SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS OR INTENT THEN ON BEHALF
OF THE JACK IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS BOB SPIEGEL
JUNIOR POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSED COMMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBER LAURA
AGUILAR HERE WITH THE FLEXIBLE
PACKAGING ASSOCIATION AND THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR PACKAGING
AND THE ENVIRONMENT ALL-
MATHEMATICIAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DONNED CAP KEY WEST MCCUE
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE AIR CONDITIONING HEATING AND
REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE ALSO AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. IF YOU DO NEXT TO GO
TO ONE. NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WALTER RIDER EXPANDED
POLYSTYRENE INDUSTRY ALLIANCE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE AT ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TAKE A
CATCH THE ON BEHALF OF THE HOME
APPLIANCE- MANUFACTURES
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
BILL BAND EPS. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO LINE A ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARGARET CLUTCHING A PATH
THAT CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION EUROPE HOUSING
LESSEN THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NXT WE WILL VOTE TO ALIGN
TO ALL ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
TWO OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ABOUT THAT I WAS ON MUTE THIS IS
TRUE TO HIS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HOPING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORED THE STAFF
ON ON SOME CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
I KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN LIKE
THAT SINCE LIKE THE BILL. THANK
YOU NOTES ABOUT THE LINE TO.
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME'S
JIM BOND THE I'D LIKE TO OPPOSE
AB TWO TWO TWO THREE PLEASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
TWO TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. YES MY NAME IS GERRY BOWLER
AND I WANT TO OPPOSE A. B. TWO
TWO TWO THREE SITE MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WE ARE AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX WE ARE NOT ON TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX OPERATOR MOVE ON PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING KELLY
HIT ON BEHALF OF THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
OF THEM AND IT THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BORN IN THE
FISHERMAN DELAY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
OF NOTHING AND- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN KILL. THANK YOU
I'M GOING TO BRING IT THEN BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE BUT FIRST LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM STONE HERE.
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. HOLDEN KALRA
HERE MATHIS MAIENSCHEIN REYES
THERE ROBERT RIVAS THREE OF US.
THANK YOU BILL WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECONDS. SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
INTERESTINGLY I JUST PURCHASED A
LARGE LCD MONITOR THAT CAME IN.
CARDBOARD AND COMPRESSED PAPER
IT WAS PERFECTLY FINE. OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW- THIS IS
BEEN I'M QUITE TO. A LABOR OF
LOVE AND POLICY HI I KNOW HOW
MUCH OF TIME ENERGY THAT A
NUMBER OF US ARE PUTTING INTO
THIS BUT- REALLY APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING- YOU KNOW.
TRYING OUR BEST TO WORKING TO
IMPROVE GET GET. GET IN THERE
BURKE OF ALL AMENDMENTS THAT
DON'T UNDERMINE. THE OVERALL
GOAL DOES NOT THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE CLARIFICATIONS ON
LANGUAGE CLARIFICATIONS.
CERTAINLY- HELP IMPROVE OF THE
BILL BECAUSE- MAYBE TALK ABOUT
PACKAGING IS VERY GENERAL TERMS
BUT WHEN YOU ACTUALLY APPLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE HAVE THE
SPECIFICITY NECESSARY FOR A BILL
OF THIS NATURE VERY PROUD TO BE
A PRINCIPAL AUTHOR AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO SEE A MOVIE FLORIDA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT
SIGNALED THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE YES THANK YOU- BUT WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OF US SOME SECTIONS OF-
SHIPPERS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON AMENDMENTS AND I
DO THINK THAT SOME OF THE CALLS
THAT YOU HAD A FIFTY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO ACTUALLY GOING
TO TURN TO NEUTRAL BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE CLIP THE
NARROW OF THE NARROWING OF THE
BILL THAT WE HAVE DONE- AND- I
AGREE MR STONE THAT THERE
CERTAINLY ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE
OUT THERE THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
USE THAT COMPANIES LIKE SAMSUNG
ARE NOW SHIPPING IN. A MOLDED
TYPE OF MOLDED PLASTIC THAT'S
MADE FOR EACH OF THE- PIECE OF
MACHINERY AMAZON HAS BEEN DOING
QUITE A LOT WITH INNOVATIVE
PACKING MATERIAL I WILL JUST SAY
THAT YOU KNOW AS MUCH AS
INDUSTRY HAS SAID IT YOU KNOW
WAIT FOR WORKING ON SOMETHING
WAIT THERE'S BEEN A LOT MANY
MANY YEARS OF WAIT WAIT WE'RE
GOING TO ONE DAY DO SOMETHING
BUT IT'S TIME FOR US TO TAKE
ACTION HERE THERE ARE REASONABLE
TIMETABLES IN THIS BILL. AND WE
CANNOT WAIT THE LANDFILL IN MY
CITY CANNOT WAIT IT'S LITERALLY
FILLING UP WITH THIS PACKAGING
WITH NO END IN SIGHT AND IT IS
UNNECESSARY WE KNOW IT'S
UNNECESSARY- THIS WILL SEND THAT
STRONG- SIGNAL OUT TO THOSE
COMPANIES OUT THERE THAT ARE
WORKING ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOME GROWN COMPANIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY PRODUCING-
BIODEGRADABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
PACKAGING MATERIAL SO WITHOUT I
WOULD REQUEST AND I VOTING WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK TO ALL PARTIES.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE. AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM ABOUT. DAVIES
DAVIES NO HLDEN KALRA RIGHT
KALRA AYE MATHIS MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES HI RES I ROBERT RIVAS
PRIVATE RIVERSIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I. THINK YOU NEED
ONE MORE SO WE'LL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL. MISTER JONES SAWYER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT A. B. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE. THAT. GOOD GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS THAT TODAY AMBER
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE THE BAND A BOX
HOUSING ACT CALIFORNIANS WITH A
CRIMINAL RECORD- HISTRIA
INSTANTLY MARKED WITH A SCARLET
LETTER THAT BLOCKED HIM FROM
GETTING THEIR LIVES BACK ON
TRACK AND REUNITING THEM WITH
THEIR LOVED ONES THIS BILL WILL
BAN THE BOX PREVENTING RENTERS
FROM INCLUDING QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE APPLICANT'S
CRIMINAL HISTORY ON THE INITIAL
BY REPEAT THE INITIAL ROUND UP
APPLICATIONS WHILE SEEKING
HOUSING. AT THE STANCE TODAY WE
PUNISH THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED INCARCERATION FOR
BEING HONEST ABOUT THE PAST WHEN
TRYING TO SECURE HOUSING AT A
TIME WHEN OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SPECIFIC TO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS OF
COLOR 61% REPORT DIFFICULTY
FINDING HOUSING MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE RATE OF OTHERS MOST HOUSING
APPLICATIONS HAVE FEES AND
OFTEN- FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ARE ARE PAYING TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS FIFTY DOLLARS EVEN
A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
APPLICATION ONLY TO HAVE THEIR
APPLICATION THROWN IN THE TRASH.
BECAUSE OF THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORD. IT WORSE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS FACE
CRIME FREE HOUSING POLICIES THAT
EMPOWER RENTERS TO EXCLUDE THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVED
POPULATION FROM NEIGHBORHOODS
WITH ACCESS TO BETTER SCHOOLS
AND OPPORTUNITIES. ACCORDING TO
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES ARTICLE
SOME LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROSECUTORS OFFER TRAINING TO
RENTERS ON HOW TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST A FORMERLY INCARCERATED
WITHOUT SUFFERING LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES. I'M AUTHORED AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE TO
GIVE THE FORMERLY INCARCERATED A
PATH TO LIFE SUSTAINING HOUSING.
THANKS TO THE WORK OF CAN OF
THIS COMMITTEE THIS BILL BUILT
ON THE ALREADY EXISTING
REGULATIONS ADOPTED LAST YEAR BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. THE BILL
PROVIDES NECESSARY CLARITY FOR
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS OF THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THESE
REGULATIONS THIS BILL WOULD NOT
PREVENT OWNERS FROM REQUESTING A
BACKGROUND CHECK. BUT REQUIRED
THAT IT ONLY PRESENT IN DETAIL
BUT BY MEANS OF A BACKGROUND
CHECK. THAT DEEMS SUFFICIENT FOR
DENIAL WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF
RECEIPT. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
GRANTS APPLICANTS THREE DAYS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
INCLUDING EVIDENCE OF
REHABILITATION. REFERENCES AND
OTHER PERTINENT INFORMATION MY
BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE'S PAST IS NOT UNDULY
IMPEDE HIS OR HER FUTURE. AS
ALWAYS I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ISSUE
IF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE A
STATE OF SECOND CHANCES BUT A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED. WE HAVE
TO BE WILLING TO GIVE THEM A
FAIR CHECK ANY ALREADY UPHILL
BATTLE OF SECURING HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. S. BY NOON YES
EMMANUEL GOMEZ OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ARE JOINING
ME TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTAMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND I HAVE S.
ABOUT NEW IDEAS HERE WITH US
TODAY GO AHEAD PLEASE. A GOOD
MORNING TERRY MEMBERS OF THE- MY
NAME IS AS BY NEW AS A NUMBER
THE ENTIRE. COALITION I HAVE
WORKED IN ADVOCACY AND DIRECT
SERVICES FOR FALLING CARS RIGHT
PEOPLE SINCE I WAS RELEASED FROM
INCARCERATION MYSELF IN APRIL
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. HOUSING IS
A FOUNDATIONAL NEED FOR
EVERYONE. AND CONSIDERING
FALLING BECAUSE VERY PEOPLE ARE
TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
HOMELESS WE ARE NO DIFFERENT. A.
R. C. IS ACUTELY AWARE OF WHAT
PEOPLE RETURNING HOME NEED TO
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE BACK
INTO SOCIETY. AND CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND MEANINGFUL AND POSITIVE WAY
. STILL IT BECOMES NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO SO WITHOUT
ACCESS TO STABILIZE HOUSING.
SOMEONE CAN'T BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT EDUCATION WORK AND FAMILY
REUNIFICATION IF THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO REST HER
HEAD AT NIGHT. AARC MEMBERS WHO
TAKE PART IN OUR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM. ARE PROVIDED
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO FIND
THEIR FOOTING. DEFINED QUALITY
EMPLOYMENT AND PATHWAYS TO
CAREERS. SOME ARE IN SCHOOL
THEY'RE ABLE TO RECONNECT WITH
THEIR FAMILIES YET WHEN THE TIME
COMES FOR THEM TO FIND THEIR OWN
HOUSING. THEY ARE UNABLE TO DO
SO WHAT THEN DO THEY TURN TO THE
STREETS THEY RETURNED TO A
COMMUNITY THAT'S UNSAFE AND
UNHEALTHY. ALL OF THEIR UPWARD
REMIT MOBILITY IS STIFLED. AND
THEY ARE AT RISK OF REVERTING
BACK TO SURVIVAL MODE. THIS BILL
GIVES PEOPLE A CHANCE FIRST TO
BE SEEN FOR WHO THEY ARE. TODAY
AND NOT FOR WHO THEY WERE WHEN
THEY COMMITTED THEIR OFFENSE AND
IT ALLOWS THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GROW AND FIND STABILITY. THIS
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS THE
RESULT OF YEARS OF NEGOTIATIONS
AND CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS BILL ALLOWS
LANDLORDS TO KEEP THEIR ECONOMY
THEY STILL GET TO SEE APPLICANTS
FINANCIAL INFORMATION CREDIT
HISTORY AND LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION EVERYTHING ONE
WOULD NEED TO MAKE THE
DETERMINATION OF SOMEONE IS A
GOOD AND RELIABLE TENANTS. IF
AFTER CONSIDERING THOSE FACTORS
THEY STILL WANT TO RUN A
BACKGROUND CHECK THEY MAY DO SO.
BUT THEY MUST ADHERE TO
REGULATIONS ENACTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. BY DISALLOWING
LANDLORDS TO ASK ABOUT SOMEONE'S
CREEK CRIMINAL HISTORY ON THEIR
APPLICATION THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT APPLICANTS WHO ARE UNLIKELY
TO KNOW ABOUT THE REGULATIONS
ARE COMPELLED TO GIVE LANDLORDS
INFORMATION. THEY OTHERWISE
WOULDN'THAVE INSIGHT INTO THAT
ALLOWS THEM THE DIGNITY AND
ABILITY TO APPLY FAIRLY WITHOUT
PRECONCEIVED JUDGMENT OR SHAME.
WE ARE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IF WE BELIEVE IN
SECOND CHANCES AND BELIEVE IN
FORGIVENESS THAT WE MUST CREATE
POLICIES THAT REFLECT SUCH.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE HEALTHY AND
STABLE LIVES AS RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THEN WE ALSO HAVE
MANUEL GOMEZ THE END OF
RECIDIVISM COALITION WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE ARE YOU WITH US. I
AM. GO AHEAD PLEASE GOOD MORNING
THE MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME
ABOUT WHAT ALMOST AND THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL
A DISABLED MILITARY VETERANS AND
OF LONG BEACH STATE GRADUATE
STUDENT. I'M A FATHER TO THREE
PEOPLE CHILDREN AND A HOT SPOT
AND A MEMBER OF THE- COALITION.
FIVE STAR TO MAKE AMENDS MY
PREVIOUS POINT. IN EACH SERVE MY
COMMUNITY TO REMEDY THE HONDA
THAT BECAUSE A FEW YEARS IN
PRISON. I FEEL MY PAIN TRAUMA
WAS REALLY INTO THE NINETEEN.
UPON AROUND ALLOWED ME MY FAMILY
WOULD BY IN A SMALL GARAGE.
THERE'S A LOT MY FAMILY TO BE
TOGETHER BUT IF WAS AN UNFAIR TO
THE AND OTHER SUPPORT TO BE FROM
. I BEGAN TO FOR NEW HOLBROOKE.
WEEKLY ACQUIRE APPOINTMENT AS A
MANAGER. AND HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SUPPLEMENTAL AND AT THE BUT- MY
SPOUSE WITH EDUCATOR FOR THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT EDUCATE
. I ALL THE CORNERS TO. EVIDENCE
TO CRITICAL. OR INCOME STABLE
AND FROM. SURPASS FOUR TIMES
RENTAL CAR. YEAH EVERY TIME
SOMEONE THAT I HAD BEEN
CONVICTED OF A. IT WAS. I THINK
POVERTY WE HAVE A MYSELF. IN THE
LONG TERM OF THE ELECTED SHOULD
HAVE ALLOWED ME TO. THE HOW THAT
WOULD BEST. AND HOW TO FOR MY TO
CHILDREN. BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
MOST SUPPORT THING FOR ME.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO
GO ON THIS WAY BUT THE- WILL BE
. STILL IT'S- AFTER BEING THE-
FOR MULTIPLE. WITHOUT THE HOME
BY PRIVATE PARTY. BUT BACK
LOOKING TO. AND I DIDN'T IT. I
THOUGHT THAT HONESTY THERE TO ME
WHAT THE- BILLION OPTION. OUR
FAMILY NEEDED A WHOLE.
THE OLD SCHOOL A THIRTEEN YEAR
OLD BOY AND A NEW BABY. SOMEONE
WHO GIVES BACK TO COMMUNITY BY
SERBIAN MARC MARGINALIZED
INDIVIDUALS. IN HIGHER EDUCATION
HEY LET'S FINANCIAL STABILITY.
THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN FIRST MY
WIFE AS AN INCREDIBLE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER. ORANGE COUNTY
AND NOT ONLY THE FAMILY. MEMBER
OF SOMEONE WHO WASN'T PRESENT.
IN OTHER HAS HAS BEEN KEVIN
HERE'S MY CONVICTION. THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE OTHERS LIKE ME TO
BE SEEN THE PARKING. OF THE
PEOPLE WE ARE NOW. AND ALLOW US
TO LOOK FOR INTO THE- AND BEST
FOR FALLS. IN A FAMILY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME ASSEMBLY
ASPECTS. OF BILL. THANK YOU. I
IS THERE ANYONE IN HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ENTER SUPPORT
FOR A BI TO THREE EIGHTY. SEEING
NONE OF WOULD YOU OPEN A LOT FOR
WHO WOULD LIKE INDICATES. FOR AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE WE
WILL NOT TAKE ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY. TO TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORTS. THANK
YOU HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE. WE WILL ALIGN TO
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS CAROL
HANSON AND I WOULD LIKE TO VOTE
AGAINST. AB TWO TWO NUMBER THAT
IS NOT THE BILL THAT IS BEFORE
US WE'RE ON A B. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE. THEM TO THE PUBLIC
IF YOU WANT T CALL IN ON AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE THAT
IS WHAT IS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JOHN DIDN'T GO WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY MY NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHICH CHANGED. WILL MOVE
ON TO THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S COMMUNITY
BALLOT ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE THREE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MONEY WAS TAKEN OVER COSTS
AND I WOULD DO OPPOSE BILL AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE SORRY THAT IS
NOT THE BILL THAT IS NOT FOR US
WE ARE IN AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE. REALLY THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP FOR FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FINE FOR FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EXTRA GO TO LINE UP FOR FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS GARCIA ANTI RETURN
NICHOLS POINTED TO PUT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISTER WE HAVE NO
FOR THE IMPORTANT AT THIS TIME.
I THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO LISTED
CURTIS HOWARD AND ZECHARIAH
KENDA CURTIS HOWARD ARE YOU WITH
US ON THETELEPHONE. WELL YES I
AM GO AHEAD PLEASE. YES MY NAME
IS CURTIS OUR FIND THE LEAD
ORGANIZER AND I'M REPRESENTING
ALL ALL OF US ARE DONE- ADVOCACY
GROUP OF FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES AND I
AM. CALLING AND JUST FIND IT TO
OPPOSE. SB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE AS MUCH AS I WOULD TO UP
SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO
WITH FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE THERE ARE SOME- INSTANCES
AND IN IN THIS BILL THAT CREATE
DEAL BREAKERS FOR US AND ONE IS
TO. EXPLAIN THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO BOTH LANDLORDS AND
ABOUT THE HISTORY AND TO APPEAL
TO THE LANDLORDS- WHEN THEY SEE
MY BACKGROUND AND TO RE LIVE THE
TRAUMA ASSOCIATED WITH BEING A
PART OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ABOUT HAVE TRANSITION
MIND LIFE- DAL. TO BE A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY-
SOMEONE IS ACTUALLY ME TO RELIVE
AND APPEAL TO THEM- MARC
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND IT IS NOT
BEING DONE IN A SETTING THAT
UNDERSTANDS HOW THE HOW THE
COURTS WORK SO I WOULD HAVE TO
EXPLAIN TO THEM CIRCUMSTANCES-
IN EXPLAINED. THOROUGHLY OF ALL
CRIMES ARE MARKED A PASS TO THEM
IN A WAY WHICH WILL NOT REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEM AS MUCH AS
FOR HOW MEANS TO ME. I SEE THAT
THE ARE. OF THE- BREAKERS AND IN
THIS BILL THAT WILL NOT PREVENT
ME TO SUCCEED IN THAT WILL ALLOW
MARK PASS IS STILL BREEZY BIG ME. AND FOR THAT REASON ALL OF US
ARE NOT OPPOSE THIS. AB TWENTY
THREE ID 4% ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ZACHARIAH OKAY. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS
ZACHARY OKAY END I'M THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY ATTORNEY AT
ROUTE REBOUND WHICH IS THE
NONPROFIT REENTRY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT PURPORTS
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
NAVIGATING BARRIERS TO RE ENTRY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO TOOK
AN IMPACTED PERSON ADDING A
FATHER AND BROTHERS WHO HAVE
BEEN OR ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN STATE PRISONS I
RESPECTFULLY SPEAKING OPPOSITION
LAW REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR CHANCE HOUSING COALITION
WHICH SUBMITTED A LETTER IN
OPPOSITION WITH RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TO TWENTY AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE. OUR
COALITION BELIEVES RENTAL
APPLICANTS SHOULD BE JUDGED ON
WHO THEY ARE TODAY AND NOT THEIR
WORST MOMENTS MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT THE SUPPORT WITNESSES SPOKE. ON WE ACTUALLY AGREE WITH. BUT
AB TWO THREE EIGHT THREE WITH
ALLOW THE- CHECKS BE USED SCREEN
RENTAL. AND CLAIMS WERE BY QUOTE
FAIR AND THOROUGH THAT CLOSE
QUOTE. FOR TWO REASONS ARE COLD
DISAGREES BUT THIS BILL. ANY
MEANINGFUL FAIR TREATMENT PER
APPLICANT THE CONVICTION HISTORY
. FIRST AB THREE EIGHT THREE
CLAIMS TO PROTECT PERSPECTIVE
TENANT DURING THE INITIAL
APPLICATION PAGE WHICH INCLUDES
THE WRITTEN APPLICATION. RENTAL
AND CREDIT HISTORY CHECKS AND IN
PERSON INTERVIEWS. BUT AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE DOES NOT
REQUIRE LANDLORDS TO MAKE IT
CONDITIONAL OFFER APPLICANTS TO
PASS THAT THE VISUAL BUT-
WITHOUT A CONDITIONAL OFFER FOR
APPLICANTS WHO PASS THE INITIAL
PHASE NOTHING THIS BILL PREVENTS
LANDLORDS FROM SIMPLY GOING
THROUGH THE MOTIONS. WHILE
OFFERING UNIT TO ANOTHER
APPLICANT THIS PROMOTES A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY UNDERMINES THE
PRACTICAL EFFECT THE BILL. ANY
ANTI DISCRIMINATION ENFORCEMENT. BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. SECOND
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE
ALSO A TO ALLOW APPLICANTS A
CONVICTION HISTORY TO PROVIDE.
EVIDENCE IN SUPPORT OF READ THE
- BUT- AGAIN IT PROVIDE DON'T
HAPPEN THREE CALENDAR COULD DO
SO WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH TIME TO
ACQUIRE ANY SUCH EVIDENCE. AS A
LEGAL ADVOCATE I KNOW IT TAKES
WEEKS TO GET ROUND THE COURT
DOCUMENTS AND COPIES OF
RAPSHEETS FROM THE DOJ THE
CHALLENGE INACCURACIES ON
BACKGROUND CHECKS. CONCLUSION
EXCEPT CANADIAN CONSIDERING
SUPPORTING BILL WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT IT NOT DO SO WITHOUT
BOTH REQUIRING A CONDITIONAL
OFFER APPLICANTS YOU PACKED
INITIAL SCREENING CRITERIA. AND
AN EXTENSION FOR THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE CAN GET TO PROVIDE
MITIGATING REHABILITATIVE
EVIDENT. AS WRITTEN WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYONE IN HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE.
AND WE'RE NOT TAKING FURTHER
TESTIMONY BUT WE'LL JUST TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION
. RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OF THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU
HAVE HERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS OPPOSITION FOR A.
B. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE. WE
WILL GO TO LINE FOR FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY RESPONSE TIME
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL I'M A
LANDLORD AND- I DON'T I WOULD
NOT WANT TO THANK YOU HAVE TO
DISCLOSE READ. THANK YOU LINE
AND NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO A THREE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TAMPERING WITH THEIR AND
READ IT SO SEATS REPRESENTING
THE SEVEN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREAM THREE C. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION WITHIN
OPPOSE MUCH AMENDED POSITION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NOTEBOOK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HI MY NAME IS MORGAN
KNOWING FROM. TERM FOR WHICH-
CALLING TO. A. B. FORTY THREE
FOR NOW THANK. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE FOR HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DIANA RAMOS AN OPPOSING OUR.
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU NEXT GO
TO LAW OF FIVE OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO I'M CALLING FOR
THE BIG. THANK YOU NEXT THE LINE
EIGHTY NINE AIRLINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. HELLO MY NAME IS
TRACKING ON LEWIS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND I AM CALLING AN
APPLICATION AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE FOR FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FOUR FORTY NINE. HI JESSICA AND
I'M CALLING TO THE POLLS AB.
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO LINE AT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEXT OVER TO LINE FIVE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI THIS IS JOSEPH AND I'M
OPPOSING AB TWO TWO TWO THREE
I'M SORRY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WE
ARE NOT ON THAT BILL WE ARE ON
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ANY OTHER
BILL IT IS IRRELEVANT TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND WILL NOT BE.
RECORDED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN
Q. THANK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTION. COMMA ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE DECISION SORRY
MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU NATURE
YOU CAN CO. OF THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY IS LOOKING AT BOTH
SITES AND WE'RE RIGHT DOWN THE
MIDDLE BECAUSE- PEOPLE HAVE
ISSUES ON EITHER SIDE AND I JUST
OF WHAT THE ENEMY IS THE
PERFECT. HERE DO TO IMPLEMENT
THIS THIS IS A WAY WE CAN MOVE
THIS FORWARD OF COURSE I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BOTH
SIDES. TO MAKE SURE WE GET THE
BEST CRAFTED BILL OF THIS IS
ABOUT OUR RIGHTS SAID EARLY IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP. MY MOTHER ALWAYS
TOLD ME AND MY GRANDMOTHER SAID
JOB YOU NEVER HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO GET A SECOND
CHANCE TO MAKE A GOOD
IMPRESSION. WELL THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THIS ONCE PEOPLE
SEE OF A CRIMINAL RECORD- TO
JUST THROW YOUR APPLICATION.
THIS GIVES THIS BILL GIVES
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO GET A
SECOND CHANCE- THEY ACTUALLY
LOOK AT YOUR YOUR BEHAVIOR SINCE
YOU'VE LEFT. BANCORPORATION AND-
SEEN THAT IT'S BEEN GOOD
WEATHER'S CREDIT BY YOUR CHURCH
MEMBER WOULD GOOD WORKING
HABITS. SO THEY CAN MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON WHETHER OR
NOT TO READ TO YOU- AND SO I
THINK THIS IS A WAY TO OPEN UP
THAT. TOO TO GIVE PEOPLE AN
OPORTUNITY. TO SHOW THEIR BEST
SIDE AND FOR LANDLORDS TO BE
ABLE TO SHOW THEIR BEDSIDE AND
TO RENT TO PEOPLE WHO JUST NEED
A SECOND CHANCE. THANK YOU
MESSAGES FOR I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. SECOND THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOW
DAVIES DAVIES NO HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I KALRA. MATHIS MAIENSCHEIN
REYES ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
I'D THREE OF US WHOSE RIVERSIDE
. THE BILL CYCLE IT NEEDS TO
MORE THANK YOU THANK YOU
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MISTER LOW
IT LOOKS LIKE SO WE NOW MOVE
DOWN THE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN. AND IF.
MORNING COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THE PLEASURE TO BE
HERE I UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE
THING WITH YOUR MOTION IS THERE
SECONDS. ASSEMBLY ASKED FOR A
VOTE. WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THIS IS AN ITEM THAT
WAS PULLED OFF OF CONSENT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF HE CAN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN
. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN WE ARE
ON AB TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN. ABOUT
TO LINE FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. BROKE. NINE FIVE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE OKAY- HELLO- I ACTUALLY WAS
. I THINK I WAS A TRADING Q. FOR
THE LAST BILL BUT IT. HM MOVE A
LOT HONORABLY. THANK YOU LINES
THIRD SEVEN YOU MAKE AHEAD. NINE
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. NINE THREE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THREE SIXTY FOUR DO YOU
HAVE A SON YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN QUEUE ATTHIS TIME I
THANK YOU WAS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WHICH YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN FEAR
OF YOU IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN. AND WE DO
HAVE SOME QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
FOR THE FIRST NINE NUMBERS. THE
LINE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CURRENT MEMBERS A JURY DESMOND
ON BEHALF OF THE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA. FOLLOWING A REVIEW
OF THE MARCH THIRTY AMENDMENT WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE AUTHOR
COMMITTE YESTERDAY WITH OUR
CONCERNS WITH ONE SPECIFIC
SECTION OF AB TWO SIX ONE SIX.
THE PROPOSED NEW SUBDIVISION T.
OF PROBATE CODE SECTION TWO FOUR
OH ONE ON PAGE TWENTY ONE LINES
TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH THIRTY FIVE
OF THE MEASURE. OUR CONCERN IS
THAT HAS NOW WRITTEN THIS
PROVISION PLACES
RESPONSIBILITIES ON A
CONSTRUCTOR OR GUARDIANS WITH
TERMINOLOGY THAT IS BIG OVERLY
BROAD. UNDEFINED AND SUBJECTIVE
. FIRST IS THE RQUIREMENT THAT
A CONSERVATOR OR GUARDIAN SHALL
AVOID EVEN THE APPEARANCE OF ANY
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. AS WORDED
THIS WOULD ENABLE ANY INDIVIDUAL
TO ALLEGE THAT AN ACT SOUND
VISION OR SOME OTHER SENSORY
PERCEPTION HAS CREATED AN
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THERE IS IN FACT A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. SECOND IS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT A CONSERVATOR
OR GUARDIAN SHALL AVOID ANY
INTERACTION WITH AN ENTITY THAT
BENEFITS THE GUARDIAN OR
CONSERVATOR AND THAT IS NOT
DIRECTLY IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE WORKS. WITHOUT FURTHER
CLARIFICATION THIS PROHIBITION
COULD BE INTERPRETED TO APPLY TO
A WIDE VARIETY OF ACTIONS
BETWEEN THE CONSERVATOR GUARDIAN
WITH AN ENTITY REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE GUARDIAN OR
CONSERVATOR KNOWINGLY
PARTICIPATED IN INTERACTION.
WHICH IS LATER DETERMINED TO BE
IN CONFLICT WITH THE WAR
DIFFERENT SERVICE BEST INTEREST.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO WAY TO KNOW
WHEN EACH CITY. IN THE- THAT
PERHAPS EVEN AT THAT OCCUR.
EVERY IN. WITH INTENDED ISN'T
BEST OF THE CONSERVATIVE OR WORK
ADDITIONALLY THAT THE
PROFESSIONAL PRODUCERS ARE
ACTING ON BEHALF OF NUMEROUS
WORK TO CONSERVATIVE. THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL THAT A PRODUCER
YOU HAVE AN INTERACTION WITH AN
ENTITY THAT IS IN THE BASKET
INTEREST BEST INTEREST OF ONE
BUT NOT NECESSARILY IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OTHERS. WE BELIEVE
THESE ISSUES COULD BE RESOLVED
AND WE PROVIDED THE AUTHOR WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY CLARITY TO ENSURE
THAT THE SUBDIVISION D. WILL BE
WORKABLE AND ENFORCEABLE. THE
FOR THE SUBDIVISION WOULD READ.
THE IN THE COURSE OF PERFORMING
THEIR DUTIES TO ORDER
CONSERVANCY A GUARDIAN OR
CONSERVATOR. SHALL AVOID ALL
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. SHOP ACT
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE WORD
CONSERVATIVE. AND SHALL NOT
ENGAGE IN ANY PERSONAL BUSINESS
OR PROFESSIONAL INTEREST A
RELATIONSHIP THAT IS REASONABLY
THAT IS A REALLY COULD BE
PERCEIVED AS SELF SERVING. OR
ADVERSE TO THE BEST INTERESTS OF
THE CONSERVATIVE AWARD. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR CONCERNS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER WITH
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO LINE FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT. YOUR LINE OF THE.
I'VE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
OKAY HE TOOK HIMSELF OUT AT FIVE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE EIGHT FIVE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT THE FIVE
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE I WILL MOVE ON TO FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
DEBORAH GRAVERT LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE. AB TWO
TWO. WE ARE ON A B. TWENTY SIX
ONE SIX WE WILL ONLY TAKE
TESTIMONY ON AB. TWENTY SIX ONE
SIX. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SAYING NONE MISTER
WILLIAM IT CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RICHER CHAIR WE RECEIVE THE
OPPOSITION AS STATED AT THREE
FIFTY FOUR YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
I'VE WORKED A LOT WITH A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT WITH THE
FISHER THROW AN ASSOCIATION OF
THE QUARTET DRESSING SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS FOR THIS BILL
MOVE FORTY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. DAVIES DAVIES I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA MATHIS
MAIENSCHEIN REYES ROBERT RIVAS
THREE OF US- SERVICE I. THAT
NEEDS ONE MORE WHO WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL IF YOU THINK YOU.
MS RIVAS WOULD YOU LIKE PRESENT
YOUR. OKAY.
MORNING THANK YOU GOOD MORNING-
CHAIR MEMBERS. I WANT TO START
BY THANKING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS ANALYSIS. AB
TWENTY TWO OH THREE WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS BY PROHIBITING HOUSING
PROVIDERS FROM REQUIRING CREDIT
CHECKS FOR APPLICANTS WITH
PUBLICLY FUNDED HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. THE BILL WILL ALSO
ELIMINATE THE APPLICANT FEES
SUBSIDY HOLDERS. ARE FOR SUBSIDY
HOLDERS WHICH IS TYPICALLY USED
FOR CREDIT CHECKS CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE GREAT EFFORTS TO REDUCING
RENTAL ASSISTANCE BARRIERS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SB THREE TWENTY NINE
AUTHORED BY FORMER SENATOR
MITCHELL PROHIBITED HOUSING
PROVIDERS FROM REFUSING TO RENT
TO SOMEONE BECAUSE THEY USE A
HOUSING SUBSIDY TO AFFORD THEIR
RENT. UNFORTUNATELY RENTAL
APPLICANTS WITH HOUSING
SUBSIDIES ARE BEING REJECTED
BASED ON POOR CREDIT HISTORY
EVEN THOUGH THE GOVERNMENT
DIRECTLY PAYS FOR ALL OR MOST OF
THE RENT. THE STATE DOES NOT
PROHIBIT A HOUSING PROVIDER FROM
CONDUCTING A CREDIT CHECK OR AN
APPLICANT USING A HOUSING
SUBSIDY NOR DOES THE STATE
PROHIBIT REJECTING AN APPLICANT
BASED ON THE RESULTS OF THEIR
CREDIT CHECK. A RECENT SACBEE
ARTICLE CHRONICLED THAMEL BROWN
WHO WAS UNDER HOUSE FOR TEN
YEARS BEFORE RECEIVING A HOUSING
CHOICE VOUCHER. OVER THE COURSE
OF FIVE MONTHS BROWN APPLIED TO
OVER THIRTY APARTMENTS. THAT
REQUIRED A FORTY DOLLAR
APPLICANT FEET EACH TIME. SHE
STILL HOMELESS HOUSING PROVIDERS
CONTINUE TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
PEOPLE WITH HOUSING SUBSIDIES BY
REJECTING THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SHAKY CREDIT. TYPICALLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO QUALIFY FOR
HOUSING SUBSIDIES ARE LOW INCOME
OR HAVE LOW OR NO CREDIT.
THEREFORE ASSESSING A RENTAL
APPLICANTS ELIGIBILITY THROUGH
CREDIT CHECKS CAN EASILY RESULT
IN AN APPLICATION DENIAL AS
PEOPLE WITH HOUSING SUBSIDIES
OFTEN HAVE LOW CREDIT SCORES FOR
CREDIT OR NO CREDIT HISTORY.
MOREOVER HOUSING PROVIDERS
TYPICALLY REQUIRE APPLICANTS TO
PAY A FEE TO COVER THE COST OF A
CREDIT CHECK. THE FEE WHICH CAN
BE AS HIGH AS FIFTY DOLLARS CAN
PRESENT A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER
FOR APPLICANTS USING HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. TODAY I HAVE FOUND IN
MEMBERS OF STRONGER WOMEN UNITED
CALLIE WRITER AND DEBORAH CRAFT
PROVIDING TESTIMONY STRONGER
WOMEN UNITED ARE A COLLECTIVE OF
WOMEN WITH LIVED EXPERTISE IN
HOUSING DISPLACEMENT. THANK YOU
KELLY WRITER AND WE'RE DEBORAH
CRAFT ON THE TELEPHONE OR OTHER
THE WITH US YES WHO HAD PLEASE
YEAH. I KNOW HOW WE RUN OUR
NUMBER OF STRONGER WOMEN UNITED
THE SPONSOR FOR EIGHTY TWO TWO
OH THREE. STRONGER WOMEN UNITED
AS A COLLECTIVE I'M HOUSE
INFORMALLY AND HOUSE WOMEN
ALLIES FIGHTING FOR. HER HOUSING
JUSTICE OF THE FORMA GENDER
JUSTICE WE USE OUR VOICES AND
OUR HARD EARNED EXPERTISE TO
CREATE POSITIVE CHANGE FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE AND HOUSE. SH I WAS ON HOLD
FOR NEARLY TWO AND A HALF YEARS
WHILE ON A WAITING LIST. FOR
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
DURING THIS TIME I WORKED. AND I
WAS DIE WITH CANCER. I SURVIVED
CANCER TREATMENTS WHILE LIVING
IN A CROWDED SHELTER. MY CREDIT
SCORE DROP TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE POINTS WHILE I WAS.
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF MY LACK OF
INCOME. AFTER TWO AND A HALF
YEARS I RECEIVED A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER. I THOUGHT HOUSING WAS
WITHIN MY REACH HOWEVER I
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN MORE WRONG.
HOUSING POVIDERS REJECTED MY
OBLIGATIONS EIGHTEEN TIMES IN A
ROW. EVEN THOUGH I HAD A VOUCHER
INHERENT. MOST OF THE TIME
HOUSING PROVIDERS REJECTED MY
APPLICATION BECAUSE OF MY LOW
CREDIT SCORE. SH EACH TIME I
APPLIED FOR AN APARTMENT MY
HOLDS SOARED ONLY TO BE DEFLATED
AGAIN. I KNEW THAT I HAD TO USE
MY VOUCHER WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS OR LOSE THAT. I
WOULD BE OBVIOUS NOT MY CREDIT
HISTORY WAS PREVENTING ME FROM
USING MY VOUCHER I BECAME
INCREASINGLY DISCOURAGED CARNAGE
ANGELS DEPRESSED AND SCARED I
FEARED THAT MY VOUCHER WAS JUST
ANOTHER BROKEN PROMISE AND THAT
I WOULD REMAIN HOSTILE. WHILE
SEARCHING FOR AN APARTMENT AND
SPENDS AROUND FIVE HUNDRED AND-
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS ON
APPLICATIONS. I HAD TO CUT DOWN
ON THE FOOD AND JOBS IN ORDER TO
PAY THOSE FEES BUT I WAS THE
LUCKY ONE NOT EVERYONE CAN
AFFORD THOSE THOSE THINGS. AB
TWO TWO OH THREE WOULD REDUCE
THE BARRIERS FOR OUR IN HOUSE
AND HELPING IN SECURE PEOPLE TO
CHANGE PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WITHOUT UNDER SCREENING
CRITERIA FOR THESE REASONS
STRONG WILLED WOMEN UNITED URGES
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS CRUCIAL
THEY'LL- THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
IS. DEMOCRATS ON THE LINE AS
WELL. GOOD MORNING I. MANY CAN
MEMBERS I GAP CRAFT OSTERSUND
MEMBER OF STRONG WOMEN UNITED
SPONSOR FOR A. B. T. ZERO. AND I
AM A BY SURVIVOR AND GATOR CHAU
THANK. TWO SIX FIVE. I AM
BELIEVE TIRE. OF WOMEN AND
BECOME I KNOW HOW DO. TO GET
DOMESTIC BY- I WAS WANTED BE THE
WAY I KNOW CHOI BUT TO FULLY MY
ADVICE PARTNER- BASICALLY GOT
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING. SO I HAD
MINUTES TO LEAVE MY HOME.
QUICKLY WITH ONLY A THOUSAND
DOLLAR TO I HAD HIT NO SAFELY
AWAY I HAD ZERO CREDIT- AND IS A
FIFTY YEAR OLD CURRENTLY JUST
WOMAN. I HAD TO RISK MY ENTIRE
LIFE TO SAVE MY LIFE. MY PARTNER
WHO IS FINANCIALLY ABUSED LEFT
ME WITH NOTHING NOTHING- BUT THE
CLOSER THAT WAS ON MY BACK
LITERALLY HE HAD RUINED MY
CREDIT AND STOLEN MY SAVINGS I'D
SPENT OVER THIRTY YEARS BEING AN
EXCELLENT TENANT. I PAY MY BILLS
ON TIME AND I HAD LEFT EVERY
HOME THAT I EVER LIVED IN BETTER
MUCH BETTER THAN I EVER FOUND IT
THIS IS REALLY WHO I AM BUT MY
CREDIT SCORE JEFF. IS NOT
REFLECTED IN. I AFTER LEAVING MY
ABUSIVE PARTNER. I IN MY CAR IN
A SHELTER FOR ALL. SEVEN YEAR. I
WHILE I WAS WE FOR EXAMPLE.
HOUSING SUBSIDY I DIDN'T KNOW
AFTER AND WE MY VOUCHER THAT
MAILER. IT'S ENOUGH TO FIND
APARTMENT BUT I THAT A LANDLORD
THEN- JUST USE THE FACT THAT MY
CREDIT BEEN BY SOME ELSE- NINETY
A HOME. AT SHOPPING FOR.
SHOPPING FOR WITH OVER MY-
PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
ON THE- WHO HAVE. YOU KNOW ABOUT
CHURCH DEBT TO THE GOVERNMENT
YOU HAVE MADE PLEASE WONDERFUL.
PROGRAM AND PEOPLE USE THEM JUST
BASED ON THE NUMBER. SO.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE SPEED
THAT HAVE GIVEN THE ABOUT I'M
BETTER THANK RISKS TO LANDLORDS
MY FUTURE NEIGHBOR SHE'S WENT ME
NOT BE. BY THE FEDERAL- R. OCKS
WORSE- STANLEY INTER OF. A M. IF
YOU WELL AND- EVEN IF THEY HAD
TO EVACUATE AND SQUARE SCORE
NEXT MONTH FOR THE HAPPEN WE ARE
KNOW THE COULD HAVE WE ALL KNOW
HOW IS. AT YOU KNOW ON ANY SIDE. EIGHTEEN PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE SOLVED. THANK YOU FOR HELPING
TO ADDRESS THESE CITY. YEAH THEY
WERE OKAY AB TWO TWO THREE ZERO
THREE WITH A LIVE THIS. IT WOULD
ALLOW A FOLLOW THROUGH FOR THE
PROMISE. TO FINALLY- YOU CAN
HOME. AB TWO TO THREE WITHOUT
THE WEALTHY BACK SO PLEASE THE
RIGHT THING PLEASE VOTE I ON THE
PORTENT KEEPING ABOUT HOME THANK
YOU THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHOSE TO IN
SOME FOR A. TWO OH THREE. ERIC
HARRIS WITH THIS BY RIGHTS. AND
WILL PROBABLY GET A LETTER IN A
LITTLE BIT LATER WE ARE ABLE TO
GET ONE AND BEFORE THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU AND WHEN I IN HERE.
SING OPERATOR WOULD YOU THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO.
OF FOR A TO- WILL ONLY TAKE OF.
IN SOME. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO OR THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO OH THREE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DANNY CANDLE KISER
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND PRODUCT
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO YOU
HAVE A SOME YOU. NO I'M HERE FOR
A POSITION. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE AT SIX FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M ENOUGH I'M AND IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWO TWO OKAY THAT
IS NOT THE BILL IF YOU SPEAKING
ON A BILL THAT IS OTHER THAN TO-
THREE YOUR COMMENTS ARE WASTED.
THANK YOU NOT TO GO LINE SIX SIX
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SIX SIXTY FOUR.
THANK TO GO TO LINE IS SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE TODAY YOU'RE AT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DAVIS AND
FORMER INTERN AT THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND I PROBABLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
FIVE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. THE PAIN UPON APPARENTLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE SIX SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE SIX SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
RIXOS THE NORTH AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION CALIFORNIA
ACTION YOU'RE PLEASED WITH THE
PARTICULAR. THREE THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT TO LINE EIGHTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JONATHAN GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO OH
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE IS SIX
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. I WAS CALLING REGARDING AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IS NOT
UP RIGHT NOW WE ARE ON AB TWO
TWO OH THREE OPERATOR MOVE ON
PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO
LINE FOUR HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN FOUR HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER JERRY HAVE NO
FOR THE SUPPORT QUEUE THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION TO
AB TWO TWO OH THREE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THE MORNING WHEN A SEARCH TERM
MEMBERS NEVER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION I WILL
TELL YOU THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND AND HEAR THE CONCERNS
THAT ARE PRESENTED BY THE A
SUPPORT HERE UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T THINK THIS BILL WILL MAKE
HOUSING ACCESS EVEN EASIER IT'S
GOING TO MAKE IT HARDER. IN FACT
WE THINK THE APPLICATION PROCESS
NOW WILL PRESENT A BARRIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS. WITH A VOUCHER. IT
PUTS THEM IN THE SAME CATEGORY
AS SOMEBODY NOW WITH BAD CREDIT
BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT HAVE
ACCESS OR LEASE THE LAND THERE
WILL NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
CREDIT REPORT. OWNERS WON'T READ
HOUSING BLINDLY THEY WILL ASK
FOR EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND
INFORMATION WHAT A CREDIT REPORT
DOES THIS AGGREGATE THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR PAST BUT
WHAT IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT. IS
WHO YOU ARE TODAY AND GOING
FORWARD DO YOU HAVE A JOB DO YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY DO YOU
HAVE A GUARANTOR. DO YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO WILL VOUCH FOR YOU-
THE OTHER FEES ARE ALSO PAID OR
NOT JUST ABOUT THE CREDIT CHECK
BUT- CHALLENGING A FOREIGN OWNER
TODAY AND PROBABLY EVEN. AN
APPLICANT IS YOU HAVE TO PAY A
FEE IF YOU WORK FOR A LARGE
COMPANY TO EVEN ACCESS THE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER THAT
APPLICANT WORKS FOR YOU- THAT IS
A FEW THAT'S OFTEN COMPLETELY
SEPARATE AND GIVEN. THE LANGUAGE
HERE WE DON'T THINK WE WILL BE
ABLE TO COLLECT A FEE FOR THAT.
TODAY IF YOU HAVE POOR CREDIT OR
NO CREDIT- BE HONEST WITH THE
OWNER JUST BE STRAIGHT UP WITH
THE OWNER I KNOW THAT DOESN'T
GUARANTEE ANYTHING BUT HAVE A
CONVERSATION. SOMEWHAT LIKE WHAT
WE SAW IT EARLIER WITH- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER HAVE THE
CONVERSATION- DON'T KEEP GIVING
MONEY FOR A CREDIT REPORT. ASK
THE LANDLORD WHAT IS IT THAT YOU
ARE LOOKING FOR. ASK A LANDLORD
HOW MANY APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED OFTEN THERE ARE SO
MANY APPLICATIONS ALREADY
SUBMITTED IT IS A WASTE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL EVEN SOMEBODY NOT
WITH- AND ACTUAL VOUCHER TO PAY
A FEE- LANDLORDS CAN NOT A
COLLECTIVE FEET OR RUN A REPORT
IF THEY'VE ALREADY OFFERED THE
UNIT TO SOMEBODY ELSE WE HAVE
LAW ON THAT ALREADY. TODAY THERE
ALSO SERVICES THAT AN APPLICANT
CAN USE TO HOUSE THEIR CREDIT
REPORT SO PUT IT THERE ASK THE
LANDLORD IF THE LANDLORD WOULD
ACCESS THAT. THE TENANT OR
APPLICANT PAYS ONCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARDS WORKING ON A
PROCESS LIKE THAT. I'M AND ONE
FINAL POINT- I THINK WHAT WE
HEARD IN THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IS THAT- APPLICANTS HAVE GONE
THROUGH STRINGENT PROCESS.
THROUGH THE HOUSING AUTHORITY TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE VETTED
THAT'S TRUE BUT THEY ARE VETTED
NOT FOR THEIR- ABILITY TO PAY
BUT BECAUSE OF THEIR INABILITY
TO A PAY. SO REALLY WHAT IT IS
FOR THIS APPLICANT IS WHAT IS
YOUR OBLIGATION GOING FORWARD
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION- AND I THINK THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT I'M WITH THE AUTHOR
WHAT DOES THIS REALLY MEAN THE
BARRIERS YOU ARE PRESENTING.
BOTTOM LINE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA THAT'S OUR
BIGGER PROBLEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ZERO
THREE. ALL RIGHT SAYING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO- THREE
AND ONLY. TWO TWO OH THREE.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO TWO OR THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
OPPOSITION. AB TWO TWO OR THREE.
ABOUT THE LINE IS SIX FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS
ADAMANTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IT'S OPPOSITION ALAINA COMMENTS
WITH THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS
WHAT SAKE WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING COMMUNITIES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE OF FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU KNOW
BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO
LINE AT THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE PICTURE
MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH THERE AND
READ IT SO SEATS REPRESENTING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OPPOSED. TO
AB TWO TWO OR THREE GREAT
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE TWO TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTER GOOD MORNING A THIRD
TERM MEMBERS OF THE STRANDZHA
ARE COUNTING. I WOULD HAVE TO
AGREE WITH THE PREIOUS- A
CALLER IS THAT I WOULD OPPOSE-
TWO ZERO. TO TRAIN ON THE BASIS
OF ANYTHING BEING VERY VISIBLE.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
FIVE OH TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
TWO TO SEVENTEEN ON THE APPLE TV
NEXT AYE OPPOSED AB TWO TWO OR
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN Q. MR THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE-
RING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE THREE OF US YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
I'M LOOKING FOR MOTION. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. DAVIES NO
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA COLOR
AYE MATHIS MAIENSCHEIN REYES
ROBERT RIVAS THREE OF US HI THIS
RIVERSIDE. THAT NEEDS TO MORE SO
WE WILL PUT IT ON CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU I HAD ACTUALLY HOPED
WOULD BE A LITTLE FURTHER ALONG
IN OUR AGENDA AT THIS POINT
WHICH IS WHY WE SET AN ELEVEN
O'CLOCK. SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS BUT I WOULD LIKE T
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SINCE
MISS ALEXIS HERE AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING CAN
MORE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND YOUR WONDERFUL STAFF AND MY
FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON THE DIETS I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK IN CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MICHAEL YOU
WHAT WE HAVE WITNESSES. COMING
ON THE PHONE ON THE PHONE FULL
OF WITNESSES ON THE PHONE OKAY.
SO THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THIS BILL
THAT'S BEEN SPREAD BY THE
OPPOSITION THEREFORE I WANT TO
BE VERY VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES DO. THIS BILL IS
SPECIFIC TO PREGNANCY AND
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT NO
ONE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE PROSECUTED FOR ENDING A
PREGNANCY ARE EXPERIENCING
PREGNANCY LOSS. AND THE PAST TWO
DECADES AT LEAST THIRTEEN
UNDRED PREGNANT PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED FOR
HAVING MISCARRIAGES ARE STILL
STILLBIRTHS OR SELF MANAGING AN
ABORTION. CALIFORNIA IS NOT
EXEMPT FROM THIS DESPITE CLEAR
LAW THE ENDING OR LOSING A
PREGNANCY IS NOT A CRIME
PROSECUTORS IN THIS STATE HAVE
CHARGED PEOPLE WITH. HOMICIDE
OFFENSES FOR PREGNANCY LOSS TWO
EXAMPLES ARE THE CASES OF THE
CHELSEA BECKER AND A DOOR PRESS
TWO CALIFORNIA WOMEN WHO WERE
RECENTLY PROSECUTED AND
IMPRISONED FOR THEIR
STILLBIRTHS. THESE CHARGES WERE
ONLY RECENTLY DISMISSED
INNERVATED VACATED AND ONLY
AFTER THESE WOMEN WERE BEHIND
BARS FOR MONTHS. IN THE CASE OF
CHELSEA BECKER AND YEARS IN THE
CASE OF A DOOR PRESS WHO IS
STILL CURRENTLY IN JAIL PENDING
CHARGES. AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IS INTENDED TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE CRIMINALIZATION OF
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES. AND PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE AND PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT BE SUBJECT TO PROSECUTION
FOR ANY A TRAGIC SITUATION THAT
MAY HAPPEN DURING THE PREGNANCY.
THIS IS THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
HOWEVER THE OPPOSITION HAS
CREATED A NARRATIVE THAT THIS
BILL LEGALIZES INFANTICIDE OR
QUOTE UNQUOTE THE KILLING OF
BABIES. THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT LEGALIZE
INFANTICIDE. SPECIFICALLY AS IT
RELATES TO PERINATAL DEATHS THIS
BILL PART PROTECTS PARENTS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING EXTREMELY
TRAGIC PREGNANCY OUTCOMES. AS
PARENTS EXPERIENCE TRAGIC
SITUATIONS THEY SHOULD NOT BE.
SORRY THEY SHOULD BE SUPPORTED
AS THEY MOURN THEIR LOSS AND NOT
CRIMINALIZED. NO PERSON SHOULD
HAVE TO UNDER PROSECUTION AS
THEY GRIEVE THE TRAGIC LOSS THAT
HAPPENS DURING THE PREGNANCY AND
THIS BILL PROVIDES THOSE
PROTECTIONS. REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDES
CLARIFYING THAT NOBODY WILL BE
PROSECUTED FOR ANY PREGNANCY
LOSS OR PREGNANCY OUTCOME.
THEREFORE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE WILL REMOVE OUTDATED
PROVISIONS REQUIRING CORNERS TO
INVESTIGATE CERTAIN PREGNANCY
LOSSES. CLARIFY THAT THE
REPRODUCTIVE PRIVACY ACT
PROHIBITS CRIMINALIZATION OF
PREGNANCY LOSS AND PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES. AND CREATE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION FOR PEOPLE WHOSE
RIGHTS HAVE BEEN VIOLATED. I
WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT. CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IF ONE HOW
LAWYERING FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. WITNESSES TESTIFYING
WITH ME TODAY ON THE PHONE ARE
SO MENTALLY WITH THE NATIONAL
ADVOCATES FOR PREGNANT WOMEN.
AND FARADAY'S D. DÍAS TALE OF IF
WHEN HOW LOWERING FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIFE. AYE
VOTE. THANK OU I DO HAVE THOSE
TWO WITNESSES LISTED FERRET DÍAS
KO ARE YOU WITH US. AND
SACRAMENTO LEAD FROM NATIONAL
ADVOCATES FOR PREGNANT WOMEN
I'LL ACTUALLY BE GOING FIRST
OKAY GO AHEAD THEN AND PAYMENT.
THANK YOU I'M I'M A ATTORNEY
WITH NATIONAL ADVOCATES FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN AND WE WERE SOME
OF THE ATTORNEY TO REPRESENT A
CHOPPY BACKER AGAINST THE MURDER
CHARGES BAKER PREGNANCY LOSS. I
WOULD LIKE TO READ FOR THE
COMMITTEE A STATEMENT FROM
INSPECTOR ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE.
MY NAME IS CHELSEA BECKER I WAS
INCARCERATED IN KING COUNTY JAIL
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR. FROM
NOVEMBER SIXTH TWENTY NINETEEN
UNTIL MARCH TENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WHILE I WAS AWAITING TRIAL
FOR FIRST DEGREE MURDER AFTER
EXPERIENCING A STILLBIRTH
POLITICS IT'S NOT COMPATIBLE. I
HAVE READ THE PROPOSED AMENDED
BELL AND BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE
I BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE PASSED.
EXPERIENCING THE LOSS OF MY BABY
ALONE BECAUSE A LOT OF TRAUMA
FOR ME AND WHILE I WAS IN
CUSTODY I WAS UNABLE TO SPEAK
WITH PROPER COUNSELING TO HELP
ME WITH THE GRIEF PROCESS. EVEN
WITH THE COMPANIES AT THE JAIL I
WAS AFRAID ANYTHING I MIGHT HAVE
SAID THEM WOULD BE. AGAINST ME
IN COURT. SO I SAW ALONE. WHILE
I WAS IN JAIL MY YOUNGEST LIVING
ON MY CUT THE- OF THE TIME. HAD
TAKEN INTO THE- AND THE GREATER
DOCTOR. IF THE HOSPITAL HAD
INVOLVE ONE FOR DUE TO THE OVER
HAPPENING. I STILL HAVE CUTS OF
MY SON. THE CHARGE WHAT THE
CHRISTMAS TO MAKE TWENTY TWENTY
AND BY THEN THE- OF A FINAL
MONTHS PRIOR. THANKS FOR WITH
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND CAN WITH
. TO MY MENTAL HEALTH. AND IF
YOU THAT I WOULD FAIL BY. AT THE
BILL IF PASSED THE WOULD PREVENT
OTHER P. FROM. WHAT I'D SB
PACKAGE I PUNISHED FOR SOMETHING
THAT COULD HAVE TO ANY. I THAT
IN THE FUTURE NO WOMAN WILL EVER
PERFECT PREVENTING PREGNANCY.
NATIONAL OF WOMEN. I WOULD LIKE
TO I'M THAT THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD LIKE TO ENTER THE CAN THAT
ABOUT 15% OF ALL KNOWN PREGNANCY
AND THE PRACTICAL. THE FACT OF
BIOLOGY TO KEEP. METHAMPHETAMINE
COULD NOT CUT BACKERS LOSS NOR
IT HAVE. PREGNANCY WHAT IT SAYS
DRAMATIC ALREADY AND I KEEP LIKE
MR MULTIPLIED BY TRAUMA
EXPONENTIAL. EVEN I SHOULD
ULTIMATELY WANT CASE AGAINST HER
FOR. SHIPMENT MONTHS IN JAIL
KOBE SHE BY THE CHARGES FOR
NINETY MONTHS AND SHE LOST HER
CHILD. CARESS REMAINS THE FACING
MURDER CHARGE FOR LOSS. AND
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND TWO FIFTY
PEOPLE IN THE HAVE FACED CHARGES
BECAUSE OF THAT PICKED AND TOP
FIFTEEN. IN ORDER TO PREVENT
THAT FROM TO ANY ELSE CALIFORNIA
BE STRONG URGE THE TO GIVE TALK
ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
THEN FERRET THE TAPE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHARITY ENTAIL AN ANCIENT
COUNSEL AND LEGAL DIRECTOR BUT
HOW WILL YOUR HISTORY JUSTICE
STE THERE MIGHT WORK
CONTEMPTIBLE THAT MAKING. AND
CAN UNITED IN WHICH YOU WHO WISH
TO MAKE ABORTION CLEAN OF THE
FACTION. THANK YOU FOR OUT OF
POCKET FOR THEIR OWN OF WHAT YOU
CAN STOP BY. AB TWO TWO TWENTY
THREE WHICH ISSUE THROUGH
ENSURING THAT AT THE NOBODY CAL
IS INVESTING. PROSECUTED FOR
COUNTRY FOR ANY PROVINCE VERSUS
A PREGNANCY. SH CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LEADER ENSURING PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO ABORTION. STRONG
COULD AGAIN I THINK FOR THE
CARRIAGE OF THE FORCE. THE
RECENT CHOPPY ACKERMAN DRIVE HAS
BOTH CHARGING HIGH BUT LEAVING A
PART. SURE THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO PROTECT. REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM. PROSECUTIONS WERE PART
OF A NATIONAL THE WE- TO
ESCALATE. IN COURT WHICH OR
FURTHER UNDER DRUG WAY.
BUT A REPRODUCTIVE OUTCOMES FIND
ANY PROTECT. WE'VE ALSO LEARNED
ABOUT. THE FACT IT HARD TO
BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE ACTIONS
ARE BORN MOST HEAVILY BY BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR- YOU'RE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE ADVERSE PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES HERE TO INVESTIGATE
MARGINALIZATION ARE HEALTH CARE
AND SOCIAL SUPPORT WITH THEM.
AND I'M MORE LIKELY TO ALREADY
BE UNDER THE SURVEILLANCE IF
UNITED STATES HAS DONE AND
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO BE. A
SUFFICIENT QUANTITY HEALTHCARE.
IT TWENTY TWO THREE AM CHANGE OF
INSECURITY MAKING IT ABUNDANTLY
THAT PEOPLE'S WE LAW SHOULD FREE
PRINCIPLE OF AN OPEN. SO-
INCLUDES A PART RIGHT ABOUT TO
PEOPLE THE OF A OF THEIR RIGHT
TO BE A COUNCIL. MARKET SEVERAL
SYSTEM. YOUR SUPPORT A FELLOW
AND HE CAN PUT THAT TOWARD AND
THAT CALIFORNIA PLUMBING THE
STATE WILL PEOPLE KEEPPROTECT
THE HEALTH CARE FOR ANYTHING.
OUTCOME WITHOUT FEAR COME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL
NOW MOVE TO A IN SOME. AND GIVEN
THE POPULAR OF THIS BILL I'M
GOING TO. LIMIT THIS TIME WILL
START IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THEN MOVED TO THE PHONES BUT I'M
GOING TO LIMIT THIS TIME TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES. SO NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY TO SUPPORT. NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORTS NATASHA
MINSKER ON BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MOLLY ROBSON WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSORED PROUD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI AT TWO
MEDICAL MD I'M FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M IN A STRONG
INDEED NOT IN SUPPORT SORRY.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION. THIS IS FOR SUPPORT
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WE WILL TAKE
ONLY NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN
THERE APPEARED SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FOUR FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY I'M
IN OPPOSITION NOT SUPPORT THIS
IS NOT THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION.
NEXAVAR TO LIGHT A SIX NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARKET AMERICA YEAH
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES A RETURN
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK AND
CHILD SUPPORT IF YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF FIVE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT TO GO TO LINE IS SIX SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DOES NOT THE INTERVIEW
CALIFORNIA ACCENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU SUCH LOOK AT
THE ELLA BURKE CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
ABORTION FUND ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB CUTE CUTE
YOU THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER THE LINE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO
. GO AHEAD. YES I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSING A. B. THIS IS NOT
OPPOSITION THIS IS THOSE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT TO
LINE FIVE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIVE EIGHTEEN. MEXICO
TO LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MEXICO TWO SIX EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'LL GO ON TO WIN WHY
NOT ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I ALREADY HAVE PROVIDED
SUPPORT. THANK. NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. MY NAME IS SUSAN
ARNOLD I'M A CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF LEGAL
pLEAGUE AMERICA'S FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING FIFTY
TWO MEMBER PREGNANCY HELP
CLINICS CENTERS AND MATERNITY
HOMES IN EVERY ONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PRO LIFE VOTERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS THE BILL
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THERE IS SO
MUCH WRONG WITH AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FIRST CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE SECTION ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN ALREADY PROHIBITS
PROSECUTION OF ABORTION EVEN A
BOTCHED LATE TERM ABORTION WOULD
NOT BE ACTIONABLE SECOND THIS
BILL PREVENTS INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF ANYONE NOT JUST
THE PREGNANT PERSON WHO
INTENTIONALLY MURDERS AN INFANT
EVEN WEEKS AFTER BIRTH HERE'S
HOW. THE BILL BLOCKS THE USE OF
THE CORONER'S INVESTIGATION AND
FINDINGS INTO A BABY'S DEATH IN
ANY CRIMINAL OR CIVIL ACTION AND
AGAINST ANY PERSON NOT JUST THE
MOTHER BUT ANYONE WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN ANY WAY WITH THE
FETUSES DEATH THEN THE BILL GOES
FARTHER IT RESTRICTS THE USE OF
THE CORONER'S FINDINGS RELATED
TO A BABY'S DEATH NOT ONLY FOR
MISCARRIAGE STILLBIRTH OR
ABORTION BUT ALSO FOR QUOTE PERI
NATAL DEATH DUE TO A PREGNANCY
RELATED BECAUSE- EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW. DEFINES
PERINATAL AS UP TO ONE MONTH
FOLLOWING DELIVERY THE BILL
ANALYSIS ADMITS THIS ON PAGE
TEN. THE AUTHORS RECENT
AMENDMENTS DO NOT CURE THE
PROBLEM AS IT STILL REMAINS
VAGUE AND OVER BROAD AND ILL
DEFINED AND WITH NO MEANINGFUL
LIMITS. FINALLY THESE PROVISIONS
DIRECTLY CONFLICT WITH THE
EXISTING CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR THREE FIVE WHICH
PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF AN INFANT
PREMATURELY BORN ALIVE IN THE
COURSE OF AN ABORTION. AN INFANT
BORN ALIVE HOLDS THE SAME RIGHTS
AS AN INFANT BORN SPONTANEOUSLY
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WILL
MAKE THIS SECTION KNOWLAND VOID
BY PROHIBITING THE INVESTIGATION
OF THAT INFANT'S DEATH. THE BILL
ANALYSIS DOES NOT ADDRESS THIS
CONFLICT OF LAW THAT'S VERY
TROUBLING FINALLY IT IS
PARTICULARLY TROUBLING THAT THIS
BILL TRAMPLES ON FEDERAL
IMMUNITY AND CONFLICTS WITH PRE
EXISTING CALIFORNIA
PROSECUTORIAL IMMUNITY AS WELL.
FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. GO AHEAD PLEASE MY NAME
IS KATIE KLEIN AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY FOR AMERICANS UNITED
FOR LIFE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AGAINST
THIS BILL. EVEN WITH THE
ANALYSIS WE STILL DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE BILL COVERS THE BILL
SAYS THE STATE SHALL NOT DENY OR
INTERFERE WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO ATTAIN OBTAINING
ABORTION BUT WHAT DOES
INTERFERENCE MEAN. NOTORIOUS
PHILADELPHIA ABORTION DOCTOR
KERMIT GOSNELL SPENT DECADES
PERFORMING UNSAFE UNSANITARY AND
DEADLY ABORTIONS BEFORE FINALLY
BEING CHARGED AND CONVICTED WITH
FIRST DEGREE MURDER STAFF OF THE
PENNSYLVANIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH TESTIFIED THAT THEY
BELIEVED ANY INSPECTION OR
REGULATION OF HIS CLINIC WOULD
INTERFERE WITH ACCESS EVEN AS
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON. I
BET HE WISHES HE LIVED IN
CALIFORNIA EARLIER THIS YEAR A
BILL IN MARYLAND ALSO USING THE
WORD PERI NATAL WAS PULLED AFTER
THE SPONSOR WAS UNABLE TO ANSWER
BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT ITS INTENT
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT NO
DEFINITION OF PERI NATAL STOPS
AT BIRTH. IT'S STATE SANCTIONED
INFANTICIDE IS NOT THE GOAL THEN
THIS BILL NEEDS AMENDING
NUMEROUS CALIFORNIA LAWS COULD
BE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
INCLUDING PARENTAL RIGHTS A
STATE CRIMINAL LAW AND BORN
ALIVE PROTECTIONS BUT THERE IS
NO DISCUSSION IN THE RUSH TO GET
A GOLD STAR FROM THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY. LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
BE BARRED OR DISCOURAGED FROM
INVESTIGATING NEWBORN DEATHS
UNDER THE BILL. HEARING THIS
TESTIMONY I READ NUMEROUS
STORIES ABOUT BABIES THROWN IN
DUMPSTERS BUT RATHER THAN
EXPANDING CALIFORNIA SAFE HAVEN
LOT THIS ASSEMBLY WOULD PREVENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
INVESTIGATING HORRIFIC CRIMES.
THE ANALYSIS SAYS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN INVESTIGATE. BUT
ONLY UNTIL THEY FIND EVIDENCE OF
A MOTHER OR ANYONE WHO'S HELPING
HER IS WRONG DOING. AT WHICH
POINT THEY OPEN THEMSELVES UP TO
LEGAL LIABILITY IF THEY PURSUE
THE CASE. IF ABUSERS AND
TRAFFICKERS KNOW THAT CRIMES
RELATED TO ABORTION OR
CHILDBIRTH WILL GO
UNINVESTIGATED AND UNPUNISHED.
IT WILL LEAD TO MORE CASES OF
CHILD ABANDONMENT. AND DEATH AND
MORE HARM TO PREGNANT WOMEN
INFANTICIDE IS AN ACT OR
OMISSION THAT KILLS A HELPLESS
BABY. IS ALSO THE LOGICAL NEXT
STEP TO BE AN ABORTION
SANCTUARY. IF A BABY HAS NO
RIGHT TO LIFE AT THIRTY NINE
WEEKS AND OF CALIFORNIA SEARCH
NO INTEREST IN DEFENDING OR
PROTECTING THAT CHILD. THEN WHY
WOULD THE RIGHT ATTACH JUST
BECAUSE THE CHILD DRAWS BREATH.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BOTH NEED
NOURISHMENT PROTECTION TO
SURVIVE. NEITHER CAN CARE FOR
THEMSELVES FOR YEARS. VOTE NO ON
THIS CONFUSING OVER BROUGHT INTO
HUMANIZING FELL. THANK YOU.
RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL NOT TAKE
FURTHER TESTIMONY. BUT ONLY NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WILL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM I'M GOING TO AND
THEN MOVED TO THE PHONES. I'M
GOING TO ALLOW A MAXIMUM OF
THIRTY MINUTES FOR THIS. SECTION
GO AHEAD PLEASE HI MY NAME IS
GOING TO BE UPON AYE OPPOSED.
THE BILL BECAUSE IT WHILE
RAISING A HUMAN WRECKING FURTHER
TESTIMONY JUST NAME A FEW IF
FILIATION AND OPPOSITION. OKAY
MY NAME IS JEFF YEP I'M FROM-
BAY AREA OF CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE. AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. I'M MARY CRAWL
FROM SACRAMENTO FORTY DAYS FOR
LIFE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
A. B. TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK
YOU. I'M CATHY FARRINGTON FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA DESTINY
CHRISTIAN CENTER AND I AND OUR
CONGREGATION FULLY OPPOSE A. B.
TWO TWO TWO THREE. MY NAME IS
TERRY BORCHERS I'M A RESIDENT OF
ROSEVILLE- FOUNDER OF A LOUD
VOICE. AND I ADAMANTLY OPPOSED
TO AB TWO TWO TWO THREE. THANK
YOU CAN I LEAVE A STATEMENT
WRITTEN STATEMENT YES YOU MAY
LEAVE A WRITTEN SQUARE. I THANK
WITH I HANDED OUT TO EACH ONE OF
THE NO LEAVE IT WITH THE
SERGEANTS PLACE AND WE WILL GET
IS A COPY OF. THE TRUTH OF THE
DEMOCRATIC OR- I'M SORRY SIR.
HANDED OVER NEXT PLEASE. I'M
DEBORAH THOMAS AND I REPRESENTS
THE RESPECT LIFE GROUP AT ST
MARY'S CHURCH IN VACAVILLE AND
WE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS
DECEPTIVELY WRITTEN AND HEINOUS
ACT BILL. I'M JEFF SIMPSON A
PRIVATE CITIZEN FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE OUT FOR
AFFIRMATION MENTIONED REASONS
AND TESTIMONY I STRONGLY
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS TORT
TERRIBLE BILL YOU AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. HI TO ARTICLE ON
THE RIGHT LINE NOW I OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. JEAN A CAT
CALIFORNIA TAX PAYER AND
ADVOCATE FOR THE UNBORN AND I
TOTALLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS ROSARIO PRESSURES I'VE
SENT TO EACH AN EMAIL ALREADY I
AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER MILBORNE I WORK FOR
ABORTION SURVIVORS NETWORK AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO. TO THREE.
MY NAME IS SARA GELSER JOSH I'M
A PART OF DESTINY CHRISTIAN
CHURCH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BRENDA MILOSEVIC FROM
FROM FOLSOM CALIFORNIA. I STAND
FOR ALL HUMAN LIFE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS HERE SINCE I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S MICHAEL CARRINGTON I'M
PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL I ASK YOUR OPPOSITION
pBEFORE YOU VOTE THANK YOU. GREG
BIRD WITH A CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS INFANTICIDE BILL THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MAX
GRAVES I'M PASTOR LIBERTY
BAPTIST CHURCH OF NORWALK
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR THE LIBERTY
LIFE CENTER A CHRISTIAN
PREGNANCY CARE CLINIC OF WHAT
YOU'RE CALIFORNIA IN A MEMBER OF
DISTRICT- FIFTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE VOTE NO THE BIBLE
SAYS GODCHAUX HATE HATES THE
HANDS OF SENTENCE OF BLOOD. MAX
GRAVES LIBERTY BAPTIST CHURCH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. IT'S
INFANTICIDE THANK VIRUSES ALL
THAT HE'D GONE THANK YOU. PASTOR
JERRY COOK DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE
REPRESENTING THE FREEDOMS WAY
BAPTIST CHURCH IN SANTA CLARA
CALIFORNIA. WE ALL OPPOSE THIS
BILL AB. TWO TWO TWO THREE. MY
NAME IS ZACH REID **** I
REPRESENT BONTA POINT CHRISTIAN
ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. MY NAME IS
LARRY **** AND THE PASTOR AT
FIRST BAPTIST CHURCH IN TRONA IN
SAN MARINO COUNTY OUR CHURCH
STRONGLY OPPOSES AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. BRANDON
CAMPBELL PASTOR THE FAITH
BAPTIST CHURCH IN WHEATLAND AND
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR
FOR THE BAPTIST INDEPENDENT
BAPTIST PASTORS CALIFORNIA
CAPITAL CONNECTION. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL- LLOYD
CAMPBELL FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND
I'M RETIRED AND I STRONGLY AND
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS ERIN JASPER FROM THE
LIBERTY LIVE CENTER AND I OPPOSE
THIS ABOMINATION TO GOD'S LOVE.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER SNYDER I'M
AN ATTORNEY WITH THE LIFE LEGAL
DEFENSE FOUNDATION AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL WHICH
CLEARLY DOES INCREMENT AND
INFANTICIDE. JAMES COOK PASTOR
LIGHTHOUSE BAPTIST CHURCH IN
CONCORD I ALSO REPRESENT PROJECT
TRUTH I ALSO REPRESENT THE
VOICELESS OF THE WOMB BABIES
THAT ARE BEING MURDERED. ALL THE
TIME. I HAVEN'T TOLD YOU WHERE I
AM ON THIS YOU CAN. TELL US
WHERE YOU ARE OKAY. YOU SAID I
HAVE I'M I'M ABLE TO SPEAK ABOUT
WHERE I'M FROM AND WHAT I
REPRESENT. GO AHEAD OKAY MOVIL I
ALSO REPRESENT I REPRESENT THE
ELECT OF THE SOVEREIGN GRACE OF
GOD. THAT THIS IS WHY ALL THIS
IS HAPPENING TO A TO CALIFORNIA
. AND IF YOU LEGISLATION YOU
PASS THIS YOU WILL AND YOU CAN
HAVE ALL THE LAUGHS OF GOD I AM
IN OPPOSITION. NEXT PLACE. CAN
OCCUR PART OF PROJECT TRUTH AND
I OPPOSE STRONGLY. I'M TOBY
PEKINGESE JUNIOR PART OF BLACK
SIX- CALIFORNIA BLACK SICK
AMERICA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AND BUT SIX STRONGLY OPPOSES AND
FATS EVENTS THE SIZE BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS BRIDGET BLAIR
I'M THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR FOR THE SILENT NO MORE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS KATHERINE MCBRIDE WITH
DESTINY CHRISTIAN CHURCH AND I
STRONGLY. OPPOSE THIS SATANIC
INFANTICIDE BILL PLEASE VOTE NO. MY NAME IS VERONICA FROM
MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO TWO TWO THREE AND I URGE
EVERYONE OF YOU TO SAY NO ON
THIS EVENT IS THAT BILL. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THIS BILL I THINK IT HAS A DATA
CAP ON ANOTHER DEATH. HELLO MY
NAME IS TO MICAH AND I REPRESENT
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO STAND FOR
LIFE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
MURDEROUS EVIL SATANIC
INFANTICIDE BE OFF PLEASE A
STATE OF WHAT NO ON THIS THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS LILY
SAFTEY ON FROM ROSEVILLE I'M
PART OF DESTINY CHURCH. THE
THIEF COMES ONLY TO STEAL AND
KILL AND DESTROY THANK YOU THERE
WERE NOT TAKING FOR THE
TESTIMONY NEXT PLEASE. A. B. TWO
TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS TRUDIE MENDOZA AND I STAND
FOR LIFE IN ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA
I'M ALSO PART OF DESTINY CHURCH
AND I URGE YOU STRONGLY. TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND SO DO MANY IN MY
COMMUNITY. HI MY NAME IS
NOTICEABLE AS A AND I OPPOSE AB
TWO TO THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS
THE VETS OF ALTA AND I OPPOSE A.
B. TWO TWO TWO. TWO THREE. MY
NAME IS STELLA DENTON NUMBER
PRESENTING THE PEOPLE FROM GALT
AND I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU I
REALLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AB TWO
TO THREE. I CONSIDERED
INFANTICIDE. HELLO MY NAME IS
JUDY BIRDS THEY SEE A PRIVATE
CITIZEN OF SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE A. B. TWO TWO TWO THREE.
I AM RON BIRDS AC SAID THE
SENTENCE SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE IN THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS AND I OPPOSE AB. TWO
TWO TWO THREE. SO I'M JUST
WONDERING HOW MUCH- IS EVERYONE
GIVING FOR THESE BODY PARTS OF
OLDER INFANTS IF YOU'D JUST GIVE
ORGAN HARVESTING ASIAN I'M SORRY
NEXT PLEASE NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
PLEASE. SERGEANT NORTH FULTON
SERGEANTS YEAH. IF YOU. I WILL
END THE TIME EARLY IF YOU ABUSE
OUR PROCESS. PLEASE HELLO MY
NAME IS LISA GWENDOLYN KENNEDY
AND I OPPOSE THIS EVIL MURDEROUS
. ALL THANK YOU. DALE KENNEDY
CONCERNED CITIZEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
JONATHAN KELLER PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL I DO
WANNA THANK ASSEMBLYWOMAN WORKS
AND- THESE HEARINGS ARE
CONTENTIOUS BUT I WANTED TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS TESS VAN
DUSEN AND I'M A FOUNDER OF OUR
CHILDREN ARE CHOICE AND I
STRONGLY. OPPOSE THIS EVIL BILL. HI I WAS BORN SIX WEEKS
PREMIUM. UNDER THE NAME RICHARD
B. ROPE YAK DISABLED AMERICAN
VETERAN OPPOSING THIS MURDEROUS
ACT. HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA
LARMER I'M A MEMBER OF JUST ANY
CHRISTIAN CHURCH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. I'M
SHOWING FREIGHTERS FROM ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF DESTINY
CHURCH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS. AB TWO TWO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. I'M WITH
CITY BIBLE CHURCH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL WHICH IS
CLEARLY CLEARLY OF THE KILLING
OF INNOCENT BABIES. HI AN LA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
WOULD CVCC BIBLE CHURCH. HI MY
NAME IS ONLY C FROM CITY BIBLE
CHURCH AND I STAND WITH
ALTERNATIVES PREGNANCY CENTER
AND OUR PRE ENTER PEOPLE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS NICHOLA DONNIE I AM A MEMBER
OF DESTINY CHRISTIAN CHURCH AS
WELL AS- A MEMBER OF THE
SANCTITY OF HUMAN LIFE DOT NET.
HI ALONG WITH MY SON RIGHT HERE
ARE THE DIRECT. OF FACTS OF THIS
BILL THIS BILL WOULD SAY THAT HE
AND I BECAUSE OF OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES CAN BE KILLED.
THANK I STRONGLY OPPOSE. HELLO
MY NAME IS DANA MICHAEL FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA SOON TO BE
GRANDMA MICHAEL I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AB TWO TWO. TWO
THREE GOD STANDS FOR LIFE AND I
STAND FOR LIFE AND I HOPE YOU
STAND FOR LIFE THANK YOU. ROBERT
GRIFFITH PLASTER COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE PLEASE VOTE NO
THANK YOU. MELISSA MCLEAN
PLASTER COUNTY PLEASE OPPOSE
THIS BILL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. HI DONNA ALAN I REPRESENT
MY HUSBAND DUNCAN ALLEN MYSELF
AND DESTINY CHRISTIAN CHURCH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS MARISSA ARNOLD I'M
RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF DESTINY CHRISTIAN
CHURCH AND I OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS NO
ERICSSON OF RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO
AND I WAS BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS
LISA BACH AND I REPRESENT GO TO
PROVIDE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS ANITA
KRAVITZ AND WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE
CHURCH AND I STAND FOR LIFE GOD
GIVEN LIFE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS PENNY MARC I'M
FROM ROOSEVELT AND I OPPOSE THIS
INFANTICIDE BILL. MY NAME'S
DAVID JENKINS I'M FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE AND I ASKED
YOU GUYS PLEASE VOTE NOW. MY
NAME IS THEIR CONRAD I'M FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS MURDEROUS BILL. MY
NAME IS HANNAH QUICKER AS THE
PERSON WHO MADE THIS DECISION AT
A VERY YOUNG AGE I STRONGLY. ALL
THE BILL THREE RED THANK YOU.
THE REGRET UNLIVABLE DON'T LET
BELIEVE THANK YOU NEXT WAS. HI
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH SHERMAN I
AM FROM LINKING CALIFORNIA A
FORMER BABY AND A PART OF
DESTINY CHURCH I ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSE THIS DEMONIC HORRIBLE
SICKENING BILL THANK YOU THANK.
MY NAME IS OLGA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS EVIL AND MURDEROUS
AB TWO TWO TWO THREE BILL PLEASE
VOTE NO. MY NAME IS OF YOUR AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS TANYA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
BRIAN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS CLARK AND RESTORE
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS ROGER ONG FROM
AUBURN AND- I REPRESENT- A
DISCIPLE OF JESUS CHRIST OUR
LORD AND SAVIOR AND I PLEAD THE
BLOOD OF JESUS OVER THIS MEETING
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. AND I JUST SAY IN
THE END GODWIN'S. MY NAME IS
AZIZ- I REPRESENT THE LARGE
SLAVIC CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY. THAT
IS IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND
ALL OF US AS WE THE PEOPLE- WE
OPPOSE THE BILL AB TWO TO THREE
AND WE ASK YOU TO VOTE NO THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS MARTHA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
NATASHA BRIGITTE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AB TWO TWO TWO THREE.
MY NAME IS ESTHER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
ROMINA ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSED
THIS MURDERS ACT. MY NAME IS ELI
AND I ALSO STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS MURDEROUS ACT. MY
NAME IS ARGHA DOMINIC ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
STAND FOR JESUS CHRIST AND HIM
ALONE EVERY KNEE WILL BOW. MY
NAME IS SERGE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MERGER SHOULD NEVER
THANK YOU LEGALIZE IN THE
COUNTRY. NATALIE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE- MY NAME IS
PHILLIP ACELA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AB TWO TWO
THREE TWO TWO TWO THREE. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS TERRIBLE WITH
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL AND I WOULD
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. MY NAME IS AMANDA
NOW THEN I'M PHILLIP AFFILIATED
WITH DESTINY CHRISTIAN CHURCH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWO TWO TWO
THREE. MY NAME IS ALEXANDER
FLORIDA MY DESTINY CHRISTIAN
CHURCH AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU.
RACHEL STARMAN DESTINY CHRISTIAN
CHURCH AND I WOULD IMPLORE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. HI MY NAME IS NATALIE
STOCKPILE COMES FROM SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTING FRIENDS AND FAMILY
WHO HAVE STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME'S
KAREN WE HEAR FROM ORANGE FAIL
AND WE CANNOT HAVE THE BLOOD OF
THESE INNOCENT BABIES ON OUR
HANDS I. URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW.
MY NAME IS WRITTEN HERE AND I
ASK YOU TO DILIGENTLY SEARCH
YOUR HEART. AND VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL. MY NAME'S LUIS ORTEGA AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
ANTHONY CIMINO FOR GOVERNOR
CAMPAIGN AND WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS JESSE FROM ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
OPPOSE THIS EQUAL BILL. MY NAME
IS SAMANTHA CALL BUTTON I AM
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
HOPE YOU LOVE PLAYING THOSE
GAMES ON YOUR PHONE SIR AND
MA'AM AND I PRAY THAT YOU OPPOSE
THIS EVIL SADISTIC BEALE THANK
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS ALLAH AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
ALEXEY JASPER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS CAROL PHELPS
AND I SPEAK FOR THE BABIES
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS PETER PHELPS AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
HORRIBLE HORRIBLE BILL. HELLO MY
NAME'S MELINDA SCHROEDER AND I'M
WITH FORTY DAYS FOR LIFE
PREGNANCY COUNSELING SERVICES IN
PLACERVILLE. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND PRAY THAT
YOU WILL ALSO. MY NAME IS TESSA
SCHROEDER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. ROBERT SCHROEDER FROM
PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT A BABY IS IT'S
HUMAN THANK YOU EXPLAINS. HI MY
NAME IS KATHERINE LEVIT AND
EVERY CHILD KNIT TOGETHER IN THE
WOMAN'S WOMB BY GOD DESERVES
LIFE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
. MY NAME IS FOR THEIR CHI I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I MET
THANK YOU PLEASE DON'T DO IT.
I'M EILEEN MARTIN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NAMES NOT THE
FRONT CHECK I'M FROM GOD WILL
PROVIDE. CHURCH ORGANIZATION
WHERE BODY OF CHRIST ALL OF US
HERE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HI MINUTE OUT
THERE WITH LIBERTY LIFE CENTER
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IT IS INHUMANE
THANK YOU DOES NOT NEED TO
HAPPEN. UNBORN LIVES MATTER
THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE. MY NAME
IS A LARGE ORTEGA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
SANDRA STEVENSON FROM NORWALK
CALIFORNIA WITH A LIFE LIBERTY
LIFE CENTER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. LIFE MATTERS THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS RITA CROUCH CO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
I'M PRAYING THAT YOU GUYS OPEN
YOUR EYES AND SEE WHAT KIND OF.
EVIL THIS ACTUALLY IS. MY NAME
IS SAM PRESSURE ON THEM WITH A
GUN TO PROVIDE MISSION SCHOOL
AND I. OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU.
AND I OKAY TO SPEAK NOW YES OKAY
MY NAME CALLING. IN OPPOSITION
OKAY MY NAME'S COLLEEN MISSY
AND- I'M FROM LINCOLN AND I
OPPOSE. THIS INFANTICIDE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
MATTHEW PATTERSON FROM GARDEN
VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
AB TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL BLOM I'M FROM
GILROY CALIFORNIA I'M OPPOSED TO
A. B. TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SAID EVERYONE IN
THE ROOM. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER CHAIR MMHM A
JUST QUESTION IS THAT EVERYBODY
THAT'S IN LINE. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU. YES THANK YOU A PRETTY MAY
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GIVE US
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION.
AND THAT THEY ARE OPPOSED TO A.
B. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
IS ONE SPEND THEIR OFF IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO. TWO
THREE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. ONE FIFTY ONE YOU HAVE TO PUSH
ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS BERNARD
BAROLO REPRESENTING THE BLESSING
CHURCH IN WALNUT CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
AND GOT THE BILL AB TWENTY.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE AT SIX
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SIX SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH MICHELLE CONNOR
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA WE
REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT- THIS BILL AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I GAVE. THE I
EXPLAINED FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER YOU KNOW I WANTED
TO UP. TO GO TO I NINETY YELLOW
IS OPEN PLEASE GO. BY NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DENNIS FELTON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MEXICO SO LINE IS SIX THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ELIZABETH COUNTY REPRESENTING
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA'S BAN
HAMMERLOCK WE STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I
HAVE TWO PEOPLE ON THE LINE
HERE- MY NAME IS ALEXANDER CREEK
ACEH AND I IMMIGRATION AREN'T
YOU JEANS CATHEDRAL IN THE
CENTER OF THE CALIFORNIA- I AM
REPRESENTING A GROUP OF TWENTY
PLUS WOMEN WHO GATHER FOR PRAYER
EVERY- EVERY WEEK AND WE ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. YOU'RE THE
SECOND PERSON ON THE LINE. HI MY
NAME IS KATHERINE JERRY MCDONALD
. AND I LIVE IN WINDSOR
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. GOD CANNOT BLESS A
NATION THAT KILLED THE UNBORN
YOU AND NOW YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
FILLING. YOUR NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE IS SIX TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE SIX ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DESIREE
RADIO AND THAT THE DEFENDANT
STRONG OPPOSITION AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. THANK YOU NEXT TO BOTTOM
LINE TWO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD-
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER GETS
SENATE NINE MISUNDERSTAND
OPPOSED TO YOU AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO GO TO LINE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LORRAINE AND NICOLE I COME FROM
RIVERSIDE AND ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND THE THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS FROM CALIFORNIA PARENTS
UNITED WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. THANK YOU MEXICO
TO LINE IS SIX EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SIX EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF FOUR EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I NAME IS MEREDITH
AM I NEED MY FAMILY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT FELL. THANK YOU
ABOUT TWO FIVE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
DIANA BOWMAN AND IN THE NAME OF
GOD I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICTOR RUIZ
MENDOZA AND I'M OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU EXTROVERTS
ALIGNED TO TWENTY SIXTY LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN YES GREAT HI MANY MISTER
LATCH I WITH MOMS FOR LIBERTY
AND FOSTER KIANI AND SPEAKING
FOR PARENTS THAT WANT TO SAVE
BABY WIPES AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSING. AB TWO TWO TWO THREE
THE END OF BAD FELT IT AGREED
THAT. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WINDS FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. MY NAME IS
MARIA COULD SHOOT THE
REPRESENTING MYSELF AND MY
HUSBAND JOHN PHILLIPS WHERE
MEMBERS MEMBERS OF GAFFNEY
CHRISTIAN CHURCH GRANDPARENTS OF
EIGHT IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
DECRIMINALIZING INFANTICIDE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FIVE
ALL TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. ONE OF THE THIRTEEN I AM A
PRESIDENT AND THE FOUNDER OF
TRADITIONAL BIBLICAL VALUES FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION AND
REPRESENTS KOREAN AND ASIAN
AMERICANS THOUSANDS OF FANS AND
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO CAROLINA
SIX SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO
HELLO HI YES. I HAD OKAY HI MY
NAME IS DR MICHAEL THE FROM UP
ON THE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED OF. EIGHTY TWO
TWO TWO THREE. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS. ARE YOU HAVE TO START
ARE YOU HAVE TO ONE ZERO AGAIN
NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS ERICA
LAWYER REYES FROM EAST COUNTY
STANDING ON A STRONGLY OPPOSED
EIGHTY TWO TWO TWO THREE. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS GLEN THAT
RANGER I ATTEND CATHOLIC CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS IN CHINO CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS
THE LINE THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
DEANNA HILL LARSON I'M CALLING
FROM WILL THE MARTIN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF ME AND MY
FAMILY WE ARE POSTING. TWO TWO
TWO THREE AND DISCUSSING. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER VITALI AND
I AM REPRESENTING PROVIDENCE
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH AND TRY
MENIFEE CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AS WELL- AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TO
THREE SAVE THE BABY. MEXICO TO
LINE IS SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. HELLO OKAY HI FRANK THE
LORD FOR THE CHURCH- I THINK MY
NAME'S DIANA STILL CAN'T I'M A
MEMBER OF ROMANIANS CHRISTIAN
FELLOWSHIP AND A RESIDENT OF
PLASTER COUNTY AND A BUSINESS
EITHER SACRAMENTO COUNTY IT'S
ONLY PUT AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND I THINK YOU HOPE YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS. YOU FOR. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF FIVE
IS SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS THOMAS GABRIEL
GONZALEZ I TEND TO AGREE CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS AND I SRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF FIVE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD
GOOD A GOOD GOOD MORNING FOLKS
MY NAME IS OSCAR ARAMBULA I WAS
ELECTED. BY BEING OPEN UP WITH
THEM FROM SHE LOOKED. AND
STRONGLY. A. B. COME TO THREE
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT TO GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY FOR YOUR IS A- HI
THERE MY NAME IS LEAH FOSTER AND
I PASTORED AWAKEN CHURCH SAN
DIEGO AND THE WIFE OF A RETIRED
VETERAN AND IF SOMEONE HAS
EXPERIENCED PREGNANCY LOSS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWO TWO TWO
THREE. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN GO
AHEAD. THANK YES GO AHEAD CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES I'M HERE
WORKING THERE ON BEHALF OF THIS
IS BRITNEY MAYOR ON BEHALF OF
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CITIZENS OUT WE ARE
REALLY GOING DOT COM AN ABSOLUTE
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWO TWO TWO
THREE AND BUFFY WICKS WHO
AUTHORED IT. THANK YOU. NEXT.
THANKS OVER TO LINE SIX SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS TWENTIETH IT'S GERALD
AND I'M REPRESENTING FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WHO COULDN'T MAKE IT
THROUGH- BELIEVE THAT SURELY A
WIDE THEIR BILL CAN BE WRITTEN
TO PROTECT CAN HELP BOTH BABIES
AND YOUNG LADIES. LIKE HEALTHY
BACKER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR WINNER
WE ARE PAST OUR TIME YOU CAN
CLOSE THE LINES FOR OPPOSITION.
I'M NOT GOING TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
OF THIS KALRA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND EVERYONE THAT THAT
SPOKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION-
OBVIOUSLY A AN ISSUE THAT-
BRINGS A LOT OF MOTION BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE AUTHOR BRINGS SUPPORT
MEASURE FOR AS WELL AS A
COMMITTEE OF WITH THE SUGGEST
AMENDMENTS I THINK THAT- AGAIN
FIND TO SOME OF THE LANGUAGE AND
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR WITH
INTENTIONALLY. IS AND IS NOT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AS WE DISCUSSED
THE IMPACTS OF CRIMINALIZING
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES IMPERATIVE HE
RECOGNIZED THE DESPAIR DISPARATE
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIESOF COLOR
AND THE ADVERSE HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS THAT COME WITH IT-
THE THESE INVESTIGATIONS OR
PROSECUTIONS RUN THE RISK OF
HARMING A PERSON'S HEALTH
LIVELIHOOD AND ABILITY TO CARE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND- WE
POLICE PREGNANCY OUTCOMES WE
ISOLATE PEOPLE FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR LOVED ONES
WHICH MAKES. GETTING MEDICAL.
CARE EVEN MORE DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE. LOCAL FAST INCLUDE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS.
AND THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HEALTH
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE A
CONVERSATION OF PREGNANCY LOSS.
AND WHEN PEOPLE FEAR ARREST
INTERNALIZATION THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY. TO SEE CARE AND SUPPORT
WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST-
FURTHERMORE THE RISK OF CIVIL
AND CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR
PREGNANCY ARE HIGHER FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALREADY TARGETED. FOR
SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS ATION
INCLUDING BLACK INDIGENOUS OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS.
LGBTQ PEOPLE YOUNG PEOPLE PEOPLE
LIVING IN POVERTY AND PEOPLE
THAT THE INTERSECTIONS OF THESE
VARIOUS IDENTITIES. IS ALREADY
H. MEDIX BRANDS FOR WOMEN TO
HAVE A PREGNANCY LOSS. LET US
NOT LATER THE TRAUMA AND
PUNITIVE WAY OF CANNELLA
JUSTICES NON TOP OF THE TRAUMA.
THAT WOMEN AND FAMILIES ARE
ALREADY UP FACING FOR THOSE
REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY UP ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE TO MAKE A MOTION
TO WITH BOTH. THANK YOU WE DO
THAT HAVE A MOTION AS THEIR
SECOND. ANDERSON THANK. OTHER
COMMENTS MISS DAVIES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I JUST WANNA BRING
SOMETHING UP IN REGARDS TO THIS
OBVIOUSLY THE COUNTRY SO BILL.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT MY
OFFICE LIKE I'M SURE A LOT OF
YEARS HAVE HAD CALLS NON STOP.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS A
BODY HERE THAT I MEAN I GOT A
LOT OF CALLS FROM PEOPLE FROM MY
DISTRICT. I ALSO GOT A LOT OF
CALLS FROM OTHER PEOPLE'S
DISTRICTS AND SOME OF THE CALLS
WERE SAYING THAT IF I DON'T LIVE
IN THEIR DISTRICT THEY DON'T
TAKE YOU KNOW MY OPINION A BY
POSITION. AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND US BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE
DO HAVE A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
THAT THE PEOPLE BELIEVE IN RIGHT
NOW. AND A LACK IN TRUST SO
HAVING EACH VOICE HEARD IS SO
IMPORTANT NOT TO MENTION THAT.
WHEN I VOTE I VOTE FOR MY
DISTRICT BUT I'M ALSO VOTING FOR
EVERY ENTIRE CALIFORNIA AND THAT
THEIR VOICE IS IMPORTANT TO BE
HEARD WHETHER THEY'RE IN MY
DISTRICT ARE NOT. I JUST THINK
THAT WE CAN DO A LITTLE BIT
BETTER JOB BUT I THINK EVERYONE
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO YOU THAT YOU'RE- YOU'RE
HEARING THEIR VOICES SO. JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE TRANSPARENCY IS
OUT THERE SO THAT WE CAN BUILD
THE TRUST BACK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THIS WORKS YOU MAY CLOSE WELL I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE HERE
TO THANK THE CONSULTANTS AND THE
CHAIR- IN THE COMMENTS FROM
MISTER KALRA- AND AS WELL AS
EVERY WITH THE SENTIMENTS AROUND
TRANSPARENCY ENSURING THAT WE
HEAR EVERYONE OUT I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A VERY PASSIONATE
SUBJECT- ONE THAT I'M INVOLVED
IN AND OBVIOUSLY HAVE A CERTAIN
PARTY BUT I RESPECT OTHER
PEOPLE'S POINTS OF VIEW AS WELL
OF COURSE- I ALSO WANTED JUST
CLARIFIED I MADE THESE
CLARIFYING REMARKS TO MY OPENING
BUT JUST WANT TO REITERATE THEM.
THIS ISN'T THIS IS NOT A BILL
ABOUT INFANTICIDE- YOU KNOW I'LL
GIVE YOU A TANGIBLE EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT IS TRANSPIRED
YEAH- THERE WAS A WOMAN WHO WAS
EIGHT MONTHS PREGNANT SHE WAS IN
A VERY TERRIBLE- CAR CRASH THEY
HAD TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY C.
SECTION AND FORTUNATELY THE BABY
DIED AND SHE WAS CHARGED ISSUES
PROSECUTED FOR THAT DEATH- SHE
SHOULD NOT BE CHARGED OR
PROSECUTED FOR ANY KIND OF
HOMICIDE OR MANSLAUGHTER IN THAT
SITUATION- THAT WAS A PREGNANCY
RELATED OUTCOME. SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GUARD AGAINST
HERE- AND IN THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE TWO WOMEN RECENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE BEEN
PERSECUTED FOR ON THE LOSS OF A
PREGNANCY IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- IS NOT OKAY
AND I KNOW THIS IS A HOT BUTTON
TOPIC ACROSS THIS COUNTRY- BUT I
KNOW I WHERE I STAND ON THIS
pHAVE ACCESSTO. SAFE AND LEGAL
ABORTIONS THAT WOMEN SHOULD NOT
BE PROSECUTED FOR- YOU KNOW ANY
KIND OF PREGNANCY RELATED
OUTCOME LOSS OF PREGNANCY- IT'S
ULTRA AND SO WITH THAT- AGAIN I
WILL HEAR ANYONE WHO HAS
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION- BUT I KNOW
I FIRMLY STAND ON THIS ISSUE AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES DAVIES NO
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE MATHIS. MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SO WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
TWENTY TWENTY NINE THIS BONTA.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AND MOMENTS I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION T. YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HELP WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS. THAT IN THE PAST
YEAR MULTIPLE STATES HAVE RAMPED
UP THEIR ANTI ABORTION EFFORTS
AND PASSED LAWS TARGETING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION LAST YEAR ALONE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHT ABORTION
RESTRICTIONS WERE ENACTED IN
NINETEEN STATES. THIS INCLUDES
TEXAS WHERE THEIR MOST RECENT
ANTI ABORTION LAW ENCOURAGES
PRIVATE CITIZENS TO ACT AS
BOUNTY HUNTERS TO SEEK OUT AND
TO THOSE WHO HAVE PROVIDED ANY
FORM OF SUPPORT TO PEOPLE
SEEKING AN ABORTION. INCLUDING
THEIR DOCTOR THIRD NURSE A
FRIEND WHO TALK TO THEM ABOUT
WHETHER TO GET THE ABORTION EVEN
THE UBER DRIVER. WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
LIKELY TO WITH THE UNITED
SUPPORT STATE SUPREME COURT
LIKELY TO OVERTURN THE
PROTECTIONS GRANTED UNDER ROE V.
WADE. IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
IMPROVE ABORTION ACCESS AND
STRENGTHEN. PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE SEEKING SENSITIVE
SERVICES. PEOPLE ALREADY ARE
WELL AND WILL CONTINUE TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. HOWEVER WE WORRY.
THAT OUT OF STATE CITIZENS AND
ACTORS WILL DEMAND THE MEDICAL
RECORDS OF THOSE WHO SEE KERR
HERE TO PUNISH THEM FOR
EXERCISING. THEIR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. NO ONE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MINIMIZE NOT
MANIPULATE CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL
SYSTEM TO TARGET AND PUNISH
PEOPLE WHO SEEK CARE AND REFUGE
HERE. MY BILL AB TWENTY NINE
WILL ENSURE OUT OF STATE
SUBPOENAS WHICH SEEK INFORMATION
RELATED TO A PATIENT WHO
RECEIVED REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
GRANTED BY DOING THIS CALIFORNIA
WILL PROTECT THE MEDICAL
PRIVACY. OF THOSE PATIENTS WHO
MAY BE TARGETED BY HOSTILE LAWS
IN OTHER STATES. AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE ALSO ENSURES THAT
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE CAN
ENFORCE VIOLATIONS OF THE
RELEASE OF MEDICAL RECORDS.
RELATED TO SENSITIVE SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA MUST PROACTIVELY
PROTECT THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
MEDICAL RECORDS AS WE SEE STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY PAVING THE
WAY TO USE THOSE RECORDS TO
ENFORCE THEIR OWN STATES. ANTI
ABORTION LAWS. THANK YOU AND AS
A WITNESS TODAY I HAVE LEAD TO
MY TO BORA WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU WHEN IS PLEASE.
YOU TERM AND STONE AND MEMBERS I
AM LISA. FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
AFFILIATES IN THE STATE
OPERATING OVER A HUNDRED HEALTH
CENTERS. THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS UNDER ROE VERSUS
WADE ARE NO LONGER ENSURING
ACCESS TO ABORTION ACCESS.
ABORTION ACROSS THE NATION. EVEN
AS THE US SUPREME COURT
CONSIDERS A DIRECT CHALLENGE TO
ROE. THE COURT HAS ALREADY
UPHELD TEXAS SENATE BILL EIGHT
AND IT'S DELIBERATE LEGAL SCHEME
TO CIRCUMVENT JUDICIAL REVIEW OF
AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
ALLOWING TEXAS TO RELY ON
PRIVATE CITIZENS TO USE CIVIL
LAWSUITS TO DO TO TAKE AWAY
PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THE TEXAS ABORTION HAND HAS BEEN
IN EFFECT NOW FOR THE PAST SEVEN
MONTHS. AT THE SAME TIME ANTI
ABORTION LAWMAKERS HAVE
INTRODUCED FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE RESTRICTIONS IN
FORTY ONE STATES SO FAR THIS
YEAR. WITH THREE ABORTION BANS
BEING RECENTLY ENACTED IN
ARIZONA IDAHO AND WYOMING. IN
OTHER STATES LIKE MISSOURI
LAWMAKERS ARE TAKING AN EVEN
MORE AGGRESSIVE APPROACH
ATTEMPTING TO BAN RESIDENTS FROM
LEAVING THE STATE TO OBTAIN AN
ABORTION. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OVER
THIRTY SIX MILLION PEOPLE BOOKS
IN OVER HALF OF THE STATES WILL
LOSE ACCESS TO ABORTION IN OUR
HOME STATE. THESE BANDS DENY
PEOPLE TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
HARM PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
FACING SYSTEMIC BARRIERS IN THE
HEALTH SYSTEM. AND FORCE PEOPLE
TO FLEE THEIR HOMES TO GET THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED AND THEY
DESERVE. WE ARE PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT THIS STATE AND THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AND IS
DOING TO ENSURE ABORTION ACCESS
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT WE MUST DO
MORE. FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PROTECTING PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY IS AT THE CORE
OF THE SERVICES PROVIDED BY OUR
AFFILIATES. THE PATIENT'S
MEDICAL RECORDS SHOULD NEVER BE
USED TO PUNISH SOMEONE FOR
OBTAINING AN ABORTION A RIGHT
EXPLICITLY PROTECTED UNDER OUR
STATE LAWS. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
ONE IS THE ABOLITION SAFEGUARDS
IN THE LAW TO PROTECT THE
MEDICAL RECORDS OF ABORTION
PATIENTS TO ENSURE THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT USED AS
EVIDENCE. IN AN OUT OF STATE
CASE TO PENALIZE THE PATIENT WHO
SEEKS CARE IN OUR STATE. IN
WOULD SIMILARLY PROTECT THOSE
WHO PROVIDE ABORTIONS OR ASSIST
PATIENTS TO ACCESS ABORTION
KAREN CALIFORNIA. WE THANK THIS
COMMITTEE AND FOR THEIR THOROUGH
ANALYSIS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA FOR CARRYING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. SO CALIFORNIA
CAN BE A SAFE HAVEN FOR THOSE
WHO SEEK THE ABORTION CARE IN
OUR STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO ZERO
NINE ONE. ALL RIGHT SEE NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO
ZERO NINE ONE. AND WE'RE TAKING
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWO ZERO NINE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN WE'RE
ON SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO NINE
ONE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE IS
SEVEN NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT'S ABOUT ARE QUITE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIFE WITH THE STATE'S IF THE
PATIENT IS PART THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE EIGHT OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
EIGHT OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT SHARING TWENTY MEMBERS
WITHIN TAMI MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
JUST JOINED AS A CO SPONSOR OF.
EIGHTY TWO ZERO NINE ONE AND
AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE EIGHT
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RESIDENTS ARE BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
SISTERS NINE WE'RE SUPPORT THE
PREVIOUS MEASURE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ONE AS WELL AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT TO GO TO LINE EIGHT
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS FOR BEHALF OF
CHEECH TRAININGEARLY ABORTION
FOR COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO
NINE ONE. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE IS SIX TO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIX
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO
GO TO LINE ONE OF THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SUCH A FELLA POLICY ADVOCACY
COORDINATOR FOR CALIFORNIANS
ONLY ABORTION FIND ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO
NINE ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT SIGN IT'S THREE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M A
WOMAN WHO HAD A REGRETTABLE
ABORTION AS A CHILD I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT PREVIOUS CELL OF
MAKING IT LEGAL TO KILL LIKE
BABY. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHT
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS DANNY
CAMERA CUTS ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE EIGHT OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SOVIET CAT E.
L. DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT ESSENTIAL ASSETS HELD
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I
GUESS THAT'S BILL ME- MY NAME IS
TRANSISTOR OLD AND- EVEN THOUGH
I'M AGAINST ABORTION I'M
DEFINITELY FOR KEEPING OUR
MEDICAL RECORDS PRIVATE SO I
GUESS I'M FOR AB TWO ZERO NINE
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GILLIAN TORN
FROM HIM A CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSE
BOTH A. B. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE I'M SORRY WE'RE OUT ON
OPPOSITION WE ARE. COURTS FOR AB
TWO ZERO NINE ONE. THANK YOU
NOTES OVER TO LINE EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD- GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ON THE MARKET CAP ON
WITH BLACK PEOPLE HONEST ACTION
PROJECT AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO NINE ONE.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT FLIGHT
EIGHT SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- THIS DIFFERENT ONE. HELLO
OPEN. WE WILL MOVE ON THE LINE
SEVEN NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT'S ABOUT ARE QUITE ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IF THE COURT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS SHANNON OVER
VERY HOGAN ON BEHALF OF THEIR
OUTFIT CALIFORNIA I'M THE
DIRECTOR HERE AND- WE COULDN'T
GET IN ON TWO TWO TWO THREE
WE'RE PROUD COULD SPONSOR OF
THAT BILL THANK YOU. I'M SORRY
WE'RE NOT TAKING TESTIMONY ON
TWO TWO TWO THREE. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER- THE
PORTANTINO THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION ON A B. TWO
ZERO NINE ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
ZERO NINE ONE. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MILBORNE I'M THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT COORDINATOR FOR
ABORTION SURVIVORS NETWORK. THE
ONLY ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES
THE SURVIVORS OF ABORTIONS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. I BELIEVE THAT
MEDICAL RECORDS AND HISTORY ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY PERSONAL HOWEVER
KEEPING ABORTION AND ITS IMPACT
PRIVATE TO CREATE A SAFE HAVEN
FOR ABORTION. WILL NOT
ELIMINATES COST TO WOMEN AND THE
CHILDREN IN HARM'S. I SPEAK WITH
SPECIFIC AUTHORITY BECAUSE I AM
THE VICTIM OF A FAILED ABORTION.
FIRST I DO NOT WISH TO
CRIMINALIZE WOMEN WHO HAVE HAD
OR SEEK ABORTIONS. OR PUBLICIZE
THEIR HEALTH RECORDS. IN FACT IT
IS THE HEALTH RECORDS OF MANY OF
THE PORTION SURVIVORS THAT I
SERVE. THAT HOLD THE KEYS TO
THEIR HISTORY AND THEIR FUTURE.
SECOND I WISH TO CLARIFY
ABORTION IS NOT HEALTH CARE. THE
ONLY REASON I AM ALIVE TODAY IS
BECAUSE THE FAILED HEALTH CARE
MY BIOLOGICAL MOM RECEIVED. THE
ABORTION DOCTOR FAILED TO
COMPLETE THE ABORTION PROCEDURE.
MY LIFE WAS SAVED BECAUSE A
DOCTOR FAILED. USUALLY WHEN A
DOCTOR FAIL SOMEONE DIES. I WAS
NOT A DISEASE THAT NEEDED TO BE
TREATED I AM A HUMAN BEING. HOW
CAN SOMETHING BE CONSIDERED
HEALTH CARE WHEN THE DESIRED
OUTCOME IS A HEARTBEAT STOPPED.
AN ABORTION AS AN OPTION
EXERCISE WHEN WOMEN ARE LEFT
UNCARED FOR AND BELIEVE ABORTION
IS THE ONLY OPTION FOR THEM. OR
THEY ARE FORCED TO HAVE AN
ABORTION AGAINST THEIR WILL.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA A
DESTINATION FOR ABORTION. AS
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
RECOGNIZE THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
AND THE SACREDNESS OF LIFE AT
ALL STAGES. THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL COLLABORATE TO
EXPLOIT. VULNERABLE WOMEN AND
EXTINGUISH SUPPLIES OF PREBORN
INFANTS. YOU MUST SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
STATES ALL PEOPLE ARE BY NATURE
FREE AND INDEPENDENT HAVE
INALIENABLE RIGHTS. AMONG THESE
ARE ENJOYING AND- DEFENDING LIFE
AND LIBERTY. HOW CAN A RIGHT TO
AN ABORTION SUPERSEDE MY RIGHT
TO LIVE. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL. THANK YOU
FOR. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BRIDGET BLAIR I AM A FORMER
CEO MICHAEL CLOSE TO THE
MICROPHONE. THANK YOU I AM THE
FORMER CEO OF HOLLISTER
PREGNANCY CENTER AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE SILENT NO MORE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. I HAVE HAD
THREE FIRST TRIMESTER SUCTION
DNC ABORTIONS AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN AS A FRESHMAN IN HIGH
SCHOOL I BECAME PREGNANT. I WA
NAIVE AND IMMATURE A CHILD I
WENT TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD TO
HAVE AN ABORTION AND WITH NO
QUESTIONS ASKED. I WAS SIGNED UP
FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL AND HAD A
FREE ABORTION WITHOUT MY PARENTS
CONSENT OR KNOWLEDGE. DURING THE
SUCTION ABORTION I SAW THE
COLLECTION BOTTLE FILLED WITH
THE BLOOD AND PARTS OF MY BABY I
WAS TRAUMATIZED. AFTER THE
ABORTION I SPIRALED INTO DRUG
AND ALCOHOL ABUSE. I BECAME
PREGNANT AGAIN AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN WHEN I FOUND MYSELF
PREGNANT A THIRD TIME I WENT TO
THE CLINIC AN EMOTIONAL WRECK I
WAS EMOTIONALLY FRAGILE. AND
VULNERABLE I FELT HOPELESS. I
WAS OFFER I WAS NOT OFFERED ANY
TYPE OF PREGNANCY OUTCOME
OPTIONS OR ANY TYPE OF
COUNSELING REGARDING MY
EMOTIONAL HEALTH. I WAS NOT
ASKED WHY WANTED AN ABORTION ON
THE TABLE I CRIED I WAS
VULNERABLE THE NURSE STOOD OVER
ME AND SAID YOU DO NOT WANT TO
DO THIS DO YOU. I SAID NO THE
NURSE SAID IT WILL BE OVER SOON
I WAS INVISIBLE EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS YET THE CLINIC
PERFORMED THE ABORTION EVEN
THOUGH I SAID NO BEFORE THE
PROCEDURE STARTED. THEY DIDN'T
DENIED MY RIGHT TO CHOOSE THEY
DENIED MY RIGHT TO CHANGE MY
MIND. AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
WILL PROTECT WOMEN THE ONLY
PEOPLE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY ONE
WILL PROTECT ABORTIONIST RAPISTS
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKERS. WHO HAVE
VIOLATED OTHER STATES LAWS
PROTECTING WOMEN. AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE WILL REFUSE TO
RECOGNIZE VALID SUBPOENAS FROM
OTHER STATES SEEKING INFORMATION
ABOUT HARM TO WOMEN. INFORMATION
OTHER STATE COURTS HAVE DEEMED.
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT WOMEN. AS
THEIR STATE. SOFFIT IT NOREEN
THOSE SUBPOENAS WILL VICTIMIZE
WOMEN A SECOND TIME FOR THOSE
REASONS I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
. WHEN I MOVED TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE. OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION. MY
NAME IS SOON SUSAN ARNOLD I'M
WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE
I'M A CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINETY
ONE THANK YOU. MY NAME IS KATIE
GLENN I WAS BORN IN HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT AMERICANS
UNITED FOR LIFE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. MY NAME IS JONATHAN
KELLER PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE IN THE BILL
. A GREG BIRD WITH CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS TO
MICAH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL BUT HE'S WORKING ON IT
THANK YOUNG. HI EMILY SOFTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SETTLED FOR THE HEARING ROOM.
OKAY OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GIVE US THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT THEY ARE
OPPOSED TO AB TWO ZERO NINE ONE.
WE'LL TAKE AT MOST ABOUT TEN
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO ZERO
NINE ONE YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO ZERO NINE ONE. WE WILL GO
TO LINE. SIX SEVENTY SIX. YOU
HAVE TO PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN BORDERLINE SIX OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS RICARDO LARA KNOWS OPPOSITION
I'M OF TWO ZERO NINE ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MICHELLE NEW I REPRESENTS A
LINES TO PROTECT CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWENTY
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO SO
I NINE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE CIVILIAN TARGETS AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS ADOPTED AT BIRTH
I STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY TWENTY
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE NINE OH NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ROBERT AND I'M A CITIZEN AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINETEEN I
ENCOURAGE YOU ON THE BASIS OF
THE TESTIMONY YOU JUST TURN THE
TWO WITNESSES TO OPPOSE. EIGHTY
TWO ZERO NINE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE
NINE OH FIVE HE LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR TIME IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL OF. TWO NINE JOINT OR WHAT
. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE EIGHT TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS DANA
MARANDA AND OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER THE LINE EIGHT FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
EIGHT FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO HELLO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MY NAME IS JEFF CARTER
UP ONE DISTRICT FORTY ONE AND
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF.
TWENTY NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE A FOUR FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN FOUR FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
THIS. YES I. THE TICKET NUMBER-
MY NAME IS TAMMY HOAGLAND FROM
TRIGGERING A COUNTY BASED FOR
LIFE AND WE THE PEOPLE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL AB TWO ZERO NINE
ONE AND TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK
YOU YOU WE ARE NOT TAKING.
FURTHER TESTIMONY ON TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MEXICO
TO LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEXT TO GO TO LINE
SEVEN OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE SEVEN ZERO THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. BURKE HELLO GO AHEAD. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF
A LINE TO TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. RATE THIS ISSUE HOW
LOTS REPRESENTING JAMES BRADLEY
FOR U. S. SENATE MANTRA LIBERTY
AFTER CHAPTER. PASHA WILLIAMS IS
A FEATURE BURKE AT ALL RELY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT ASKS FOR NO
VOTE ON AB TWO ZERO NINE ONE AND
WE OPPOSED TO TWO TO THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOT SO GO TO LINE
ONE A FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TRESHMAN YEAR I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO NINE ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS VICTORIES
MENDOZA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
TWENTY NINE ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT TO LINE FIVE OH TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
SERRA CAME FROM A TRADITION OF
THE VALUES FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF CREATING ASIAN
AMERICANS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE FIVE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TJ STAND FOR
LIFE FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE AND THE PREVIOUS
OWNER JOBS NO NO. THANK YOU NEXT
TO VOTE TO LINE EIGHT OH TWOYOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI YES MY
NAME IS JANE EVERETT THE MOST
SAN DIEGO THE SAN AND I PROBABLY
OPPOSE. AB TWENTY NINETY ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE
EIGHT NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS KERRY PHOTO I'M
FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA AND
THIS BILL BREAKS MY HEART I AM
SO AGAINST IT PLEASE THAT BOOK
FOR THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE EIGHT FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS NATALIE
REYES AND I AT THE. EIGHTY TWO
ZERO NINE ONE. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN. ARMORY THIRTIETH ARE
REPRESENTING MYSELF AND MY
HUSBAND JOHN PHILLIPS MEMBERS OF
THE ETHNIC CHRISTIAN CHURCH WILL
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO ZERO
NINE ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK IN OCTOBER TO LINE EIGHT
OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
TERRY ENGLISH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. TWO ZERO NINE NINE.
THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE
AS SIX SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI SIX SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT'S OKAY PARDON
YEAH YOU SHOULD DO ABOUT. MEXICO
CAROLINA SEVEN TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM OF THE
BORROWED I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO ZERO NINE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE AND
NINE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI I'M A MECHANICAL AMERICA I AM
FROM THE CITY OF ORANGE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY TWO ZERO
NINE ONE AND I TRIED FOR ALMOST
AN HOUR TO TAKE A CLOSE TO TWO
TO THREE WELL. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HELLO GO AHEAD PLEASE. IT CAN
HEAR ME YES. OKAY THIS IS GOING
TO MARINO AND I AM I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE DEMONIC BILL AB.
TWENTY NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE AT SIX
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SIX SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ABOUT TEN NINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS LISA BASS GONE FROM DISTRICT
THIRTY NINE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE TWENTY NINETY ONE AS WELL
AS TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY I WAS
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH THANK.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO THREE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
. THANK YOU MY NAME IS DR
PRESIDENT I'M A MEMBER OF GRACE
BAPTIST CHURCH OF WILMINGTON
ALSO CIVIL LITIGATION PARALEGAL
AT A LAW FIRM AND I ALL ME AND
MY FAMILY MEMBERS AND MY CHURCH
MEMBERS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE. SEVEN NINETY. HELLO MY
NAME IS RYAN FROM LAKE ELSINORE
CALIFORNIA LONGTIME PRESIDENT
AND VOTER I STRONGLY OPPOSE
OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINETY ONE AND
EIGHTY TO TWO TO THREE. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE EIGHT
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DIDN'T TAKE DOWN HOUSE FINE.
VALLEY OPPOSE HUGE THERE NINE
ONE NINE MEMBER STEPHANIE CHURCH
AND TO PUT A MENTAL
COLLABORATIVE. THANK YOU TO GO
TO LINE THIS SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DON
TO MEXICO HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. HELLO OKAY MY NAME
IS DON TO MEXICO AND I'M CALLING
IN FROM SAMBAR DINO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO NINE
ONE AS WELL AS AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. THANK THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE SEVEN FIFTY ONE.
HI MY NAME IS MARK TWENTY NGUYEN
AND I LIVE IN FOUNTAIN VALLEY
ORANGE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE AND I WOULD
ASK YOU TO DO THINK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
ARE PAST OUR TIME FOR TESTIMONY
SO YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES WHEN
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
RIGHT SINGING UNRESPONSIVE YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE IS A NECESSARY BILL
NEEDD TO COMBAT THE WAVE OF
ABORTION RESTRICTIONS BEING
ENACTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY THIS
BILL PROTECTS EVERY PERSON'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO BE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
DECISIONS AND IT PROTECTS THE
RIGHT TO MAINTAIN PRIVACY AS
THEY ARE DOING SO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION IS THEIR SECOND. AND THE
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
CULTURAL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. DAVIES NO
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA
AYE MATHIS MATHIS NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES. REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS
THREE OF US THIS RIVERSIDE. THE
BILL NEEDS ONE MORE SO WE'LL
PLACE IT ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS I'VE BEEN NUMBER
ELEVEN A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
FIRST LET ME START BY SAYING
THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE WORK WITH
MY STAFF ARE WORKING WITH THIS
BILL APPRECIATE- THE SUPPORT OF
THE HELP. MEMBERS SAY IMPROPER
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE WHICH ENCOURAGES ATTORNEYS
TO TAKE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS CASES AND REMOVES
UNNECESSARY HURDLES FOR
SURVIVORS REQUESTING. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS ALSO
KNOWN AS DVR ROSE. CURRENTLY IT
IS UP TO THE COURTS TO DECIDE TO
AWARD ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS
OF A SURVIVOR WINS OUR DVR-
CASES. IN SOME INSTANCES QUARTER
ACTUALLY REQUIRING SURVIVORS TO
MEET MORE REQUIREMENTS. THAN
THEIR ABUSER WHEN AWARDING
ATTORNEYS FEES BECAUSE COURTS
HEARD CONSISTENTLY APPLYING
CURRENT LAW. SURVIVORS NOT ONLY
FACED PHYSICAL ABUSE BUT THEY'RE
ALSO OFTEN VICTIMS TO ECONOMIC
ABUSE ABUSERS TAKE AWAY THEIR
VICTIMS FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE
DENYING THEM FROM HAVING. HAVING
A JOB OR PUT A ARE SPENDING
THEIR VICTIMS MONEY WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT AND PUTTING THEM
DEEP INTO THAT. THE SLEEVES MANY
SURVIVORS WITH LITTLE TO NO
RESOURCES WHEN THEY TRY TO
LEAVE. PETITIONERS FOR DVR ROSE
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY UNDER.
UNREPRESENTATIVE I'M REPRESENTED
AND MOSTLY WOMEN AND THEIR
CHILDREN. WITHOUT REPRESENTATION
SURVIVORS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
LOSE THEIR DVR- CASES- THEY HAVE
TO JUGGLE. TRYING TO LEAVE THEIR
ABUSER WILL NAVIGATING THE
COURTS EVIDENCE REQUIREMENTS AND
PROCEDURE. THE SURVIVOR LOSES
THEIR CASE THEY WILL BE ON THE
HOOK FOR THOUSANDS OR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND COSTS AND
FUND THEIR- AND FUND THEIR VIEWS
ARE IN THE PROCESS THIS PROCESS
IS BURDENSOME DOES NOT PROTECT
SURVIVORS OR THEIR FAMILIES AND
DISCOURAGES VICTIMS FROM TRYING
TO GET A DVR- IN THE FIRST PLACE
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE FIX
IS THIS PROCESS BY REQUIRING THE
COURT. AFTER ISSUING A DVR- TO
ORDER ABUSERS PAPER SURVIVORS
ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS THIS
ONCE ADVISED MORE TOURNEY'S TAKE
UP IN REPRESENTS RIDERS IN THIS
CASE. I HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY COREY HERNANDEZ A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH FAMILY VIOLENCE
APPELLATE PROJECT. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE COREY HERNANDEZ LISTED
SO WITH US BY THE TELEPHONE HEY
COREY HERNANDEZ ARE YOU WITH US
. YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU MY
NAME'S COREY HERNANDEZ I'M AN
ATTORNEY AT THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
APPELLATE PROJECT OR NONPROFIT
BASED IN OAKLAND BUT WE ARE
STATEWIDE AND WE PROVIDE FREE
SERVICES TO SURVIVORS OF ABUSE
WHO ARE APPEALING CHALLENGING
TRIAL COURT ORDERS. THAT
APARTMENT LIST- AND IF THERE'S
BEEN AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE SEEN
AND SINCE OUR FOUNDING IN TWENTY
TWELVE- WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE THINK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND ESPECIALLY SOME OF THE
SALAS FIRST LEADERSHIP- AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE IS A
DIFFERENT DIMENSION IS BASICALLY
DECIDED TO TWO THINGS FIRST. WE
WANT TO EMPOWER MORE SURVIVORS
TO BRING FORTH MORE CASES WITH
REPRESENTATION WITHOUT THE WORRY
THAT THEY MAY BE LIABLE FOR
THEIR OWN ATTORNEYS' FEES- OR IF
THEY LOSE THEY MAY BE AT RISK
FOR PAYING THE OTHER. PERSON'S
ATTORNEY SEES FOR THE NEAR ACTED
MAKING THE REQUEST AND SECOND WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE MORE ATTORNEYS
TAKE MORE LOW INCOME SURVIVORS
CASES. HAVING REPRESENTATION CAN
MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN ANY
COURT CASE PARTICULARLY FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHERE THEY HAVE TO INTRODUCE
EVIDENCE FOLLOWING COMPLEX RULES
FACE THE PERSON WHO ABUSED THEM
IN COURT AND TESTIFY IN A PUBLIC
SETTING TO VERY PERSONAL DETAILS
OF THEIR LIFE. I'M AT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED THE
CURRENT LAWS BEING
INCONSISTENTLY APPLIED AND I
WANT TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
THAT WORKS AGAINST SURVIVORS SO
FOR EXAMPLE- WE'VE SEN
SURVIVORS WHO MAY BE OF MODERATE
INCOME AND MAYBE THEY CAN AFFORD
THEIR OWN ATTORNEY. NOT ALL THAT
COMMON BUT IT SOMETIMES HAPPENS-
OR MAYBE A SURVIVORS OF LOWER
VERY LITTLE IN COMMON BUT THEY
CAN MAYBE SCROUNGED UP ENOUGH BY
BORROWING FROM FRIENDS ARE
GETTING GET- SO THEY MAY BRING
FOR THE RESTRAINING ORDER ITH
AN ATTORNEY WHEN GET THE
RESTRAINING ORDER. AND THAT THE
CURRENT LAWS WRITTEN IN THE TVPA
THE COURT BUT STILL REFUSED. TO
GIVE THEM ATTORNEYS FEES SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE COURT THE STATUTE
THE LAW GIVEN THAT GIVEN THAT
DISCRETION- OR THE COURT COULD
SAY THAT WHILE THE SURVIVOR WAS
ABLE TO AFFORD THE ATTORNEY ON
THEIR OWN- SO THEY DON'T NEED
THE RESPONDED TO PAY FOR THAT.
AND IN THESE TYPE THE CASE OF
AN- SURVIVORS ARE ESSENTIALLY
HAVING TO. THEIR IDEAS. SO IF
PASSED THE EIGHTY TWENTY THREE
SIXTY NINE WHICH- HOW THE
OUTCOME WILL LOOK IN. IN THE
FUTURES IN THAT TIME SCENARIO-
UNDER THE BILL COURT WOULD
ACTUALLY REQUIRE- TO ORDER
RESPONDENT PAY FOR THE ATTORNEYS
THE SURVIVORS ARE. FEES IF THAT
RESPONSE HAS THE ABILITY TO PAY
THOSE- AND OUTSIDE WE THINK THE
BILL BRINGS THE TV. AND THAT.
SCHEMES OF DOMESTIC BROWN
RESTRAINING OR MORE LINE WITH.
REMEDIAL LIKE THE FAIR HOUSING
ACT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT. BY MAKING IT EASIER
FOR PETITIONERS TO GET THEIR
FEES AND HARDER FOR RESPONDENTS
WE ENCOURAGE MORE PEOPLE. TO GET
THE PROTECTION THEY NEED AND WE
THINK YOU ENERGY FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
pWHO WOULD LIKE TO GET SUPPORT
FOR A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE. WILL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. JEFF IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN THEIR
APPEARANCE THE PORTS OF AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE- THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MELISSA KNIGHT
SIGN THE LEGISLATIVE COALITION
SPIRIT CHILD ABUSE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
AT TEN THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING- GOOD
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MORGAN- I AM A LONG
TIME RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND EIGHTY THREE CENTS.
THE PERSON WHO HAS DECIDED TO
COME FORWARD ABOUT THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THAT I SUFFERED- I'M
SORRY I TAKING ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY WERE JUST TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE. OKAY
I'M NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE THAT IS THE PART OF IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
THE LINE EIGHT OH TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I YET YOU NEVER COME
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT
SO GO TO LINE SIX SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME
IS INGRID MORENO AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE SIX
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING KILL
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVES TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE. ALL
RIGHT SAYING NONE. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINE FOR.
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY NINE. GIVEN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN THERE
APPEAR IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE AT TEN FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU I'M
SORRY I WAS ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT
AND I WANT TO CALL ON YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU AND NEXT WEEK. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE. ONE MOMENT TEN
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES PLEASE DO
NOT PASS THE- LAW IT IS EVIL
THANK YOU I AM COMPLETELY AGAIN
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE AT TEN
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TEN FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES
OF RING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. CENA THIS
RESULTS YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT SURVIVORS
AND THEIR FAMILIES SHOULD HAVE
TO FEAR GOING TO COURT TO GET
RELIEF FROM THEIR ABUSING.
ABUSERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THANK
YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES DAVIES I
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA
AYE MATHIS MATHIS I MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS
THREE OF US THREE OF US I. THAT
BILLS UP THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT MISS DAVIES YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB. SIXTEEN
ELEVEN. QUESTION FOR. THANK YOU
CHAIR. MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE
BECAUSE AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN I WILL
FIRST WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY STAFF
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MEMBERS
GIVEN THE EXTREMELY LATE FOUR AM
OPPOSITION TO THIS NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILL I'LL BE BRIEF
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN THERE IS
A THREAT OF LEAKAGE OF OIL
COMING FROM A VESSEL THAT THAT'S
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY REPORT THAT
DISCHARGE TO CAL- YES.
SHOCKINGLY HOWEVER IF A VESSEL
WE'RE TO BE THE CAUSE OF AN OIL
LEAKAGE SUCH AS HITTING A
PIPELINE WITH ITS ANCHOR LIKE WE
WITNESSED AN ORANGE COUNTY LAST
OCTOBER THERE IS NO LAW
MANDATING THEY MUST NOTIFY
ANYBODY. AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO MERELY PUT
INTO PLACE PROTOCOLS FOR VESSEL
OPERATED TO NOTIFY TELLS- YES
ABOUT A STRIKE A POTENTIAL
STRIKE OF A SUBMERGED PIPELINE.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO INSTRUCT THE
OFFICE TO NOTIFY THE PIPELINE
OPERATORS SO THAT THEY MAY BEGIN
REPAIRS ON THE PIPELINE
IMMEDIATELY THE BILL ALSO STATE
THAT A VESSEL OPERATOR WHO
NORMALLY DOES NOT PROVIDE THIS
ALERT TO CAL- YEAH THAT'S IS
SUBJECT TO CIVIL FINES OF UP TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS INCOME.
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS OF THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIXTEEN ELEVEN. YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN THEIR
APPEARANCE ABOARD. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY NINETEEN NINETY MADE
. PLEASE GO AHEAD MY COMMENTS
WOULD ACTUALLY BE IN OPPOSITION
OKAY IT IS NOT TIME FOR A
POSITION JUST YET. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE AT TEN FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE CARD AB
SIXTEEN ELEVEN ON A STOP IN A
CAMPER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
NOT SURE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO
AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN. HERE FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
THEREOF IN OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE GREATLY APPRECIATED
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN BABY
THAT OUR STAFF. TO MOVE SOME
AMENDMENTS VOTING WILL STIPULATE
THAT THERE BEEN MANY AGREEABLE
AMENDMENTS. HOWEVER TODAY WHILE
WE ARE HERE TO VOICE OUR POST
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION- THAT'S
PREDICATED ON THAT I DON'T DRESS
PROVISION THAT CREATES AN
UNPLANNED UNSUBSTANTIATED CIVIL.
PENALTIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. I THINK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE ALLIANCE THEY'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AS THEIR SECOND. I WILL
SECOND THAT THANK YOU. YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY AS WHEN I
. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
TO SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE DAVIES AYE DAVIES AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES AS AYE
ROBERT RIVAS THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THAT BILL IS OUT. WE HAVE A
LACK OF AUTHORS I WILL PRESENT
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN TO. TAKEOVER COMMITTEE
FORM.
TO
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM FOURTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX WE TO BEGIN
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO
THANK YOU START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF
WORK THE WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME TRYING TO FIND A
WAY TO GIVE EOPLE VALLEY
CALIFORNIA ID'S UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THAT ALLOWS
FOLKS REGARDLESS OF
DOCUMENTATION STATUS TO GET TO
GET A DRIVER'S LICENSE. DOES NOT
COMPLETELY FILL THE BILL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING TO GET PEOPLE
IDENTIFICATIONS AS THEY COME OUT
OF PRISONS AND JAILS AND THOSE
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR DRIVER'S
LICENSE WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT PROGRAM SO JUST SEEMS
TO HAVE BEEN AN OVERSIGHT IN
THAT PREVIOUS LEGISLATION TO NOT
INCLUDE A CALIFORNIA ID
DISTINGUISH FROM A FEDERALLY
COMPLIANT ID THIS WOULD BE A
CALIFORNIA ISSUED. ID FOR ANYONE
REALLY WHO DOESN'T WANT TO GET A
REAL I OR CANNOT GET A REAL ID
FOR WHAT EVER. REASON THIS IS A
REALLY VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
THAT ADDS CALIFORNIA ID'S TO
THAT PROGRAM. WE ARE MAKING IT.
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
AND GIVING. THE DMV YOU PLENTY
OF TIME TO BE ABLE TO PUT IN
PLACE THEIR SYSTEMS. SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE MS
NORMA MARANDA ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I'M BRENDA
I'M WITH YOU ON THE LINE. LEVINE
SHOULD BE OPEN. IF SHE'S ON. THE
MARKET. I DO NOT HEAR HER ON AS
A CO HOST LINE. THIS IS A TEN
MINUTE. CAN YOU CHECK OPERATOR
FOR REDEEMER RITA MEDINA THE
TRANSLATOR. READ A MEDINA I HAVE
HERE ON THE LINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OKAY. HELLO HELLO I'M
SORRY. READER IS A FEW. IF NOT
READ US SORRY. OKAY. I HAVE NOT
FOUND RITA MEDINA THE AT. ABOUT
SHUMEN CHEER AS SHE AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YES HELLO
I'M ON THE LINE AND I ALSO HAVE
THE- TESTIMONY YOU'RE NOT
MEMORANDA- WHO WAS GOING TO
TESTIFY RITA MEDINA HAD SET UP
THE TESTIMONIES THAT CAN ALSO BE
THAT. BE GREAT PLEASE BEGIN.
RIGHT NOW START WITH NORMAN
AROUND OF TESTIMONY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MEMORANDA I
AM AN IMMIGRANT AND I HAVE LIVED
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS. I AM FROM PERU I'M
MARRIED TO NATURALIZED CITIZEN
BORN IN ABOUT THE DOLLAR.
DESPITE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO GET MY LEGAL DOCUMENTS. I
COULDN'T APPLY FOR CITIZENSHIP
BECAUSE OF A MATTER IN WHICH
THEY DEPARTED MANY YEARS AGO.
I'M THE ONLY PERSON IN MY FAMILY
WITHOUT LEGAL DOCUMENTS. OUR
INCOME IS LIMITED BECAUSE MY
HUSBAND HAD AN ACCIDENT AT WORK
AND IS ON DISABILITY. I TAKE
CARE OF THEM AND I WORK WHEN I
CAN TAKING CARE OF CHILDREN OR
CLEANING HOUSES. I DON'T DRIVE I
THINK THE BEST MY HUSBAND HAS A
CAR. BUT DRIVING PUT THEMSELVES
AT RISK AND YOU CAN'T GET ME TO
DRIVE FOR THAT REASON. BUT CAN I
HAVE A LICENSE AND I CANNOT GET
ANOTHER OFFICIAL ID BESIDE MY
PASSPORT. IF I HAD AN ID CARD I
WOULD FEEL MUCH SAFER I'M AFRAID
OF LOSING THE PASSPORT. AND IN%
ANY CASE I'M GOING TO SHOW IT IN
THE OFFICES. PEOPLE ASK ME IF I
HAVE SOMETHING ELSE. PEOPLE HERE
USED TO ID CARD DRIVER'S. WHEN I
SHOWED A PATH. IT'S STRANGE OF.
SO BY CARRIED A- IF THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO. IT ANYWAYS. I LIKE TO
HAVE LEGAL DOCUMENTS UNTIL WE
ACHIEVE THAT AND ID CARD WILL BE
VERY USEFUL TO ME. I COULD SIGN
UP FOR THE EIGHT PROGRAMS FROM
THE STATE AND THE CITY TO HELP
PEOPLE LIKE US. MY HUSBAND WOULD
HAVE TO THE CITIZENSHIP AND ME
WITH MY CARD. WHEN A PERSON HAS
NO SUCH SECURITY OR IT.
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING. MUCH
HARDER. THIS WILL HARD TO BEAT
BECAUSE- I CANNOT SIGN UP FOR
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM. INCLUDING
THOSE HELP UNDOCUMENTED. LIKE
ME. I GET FRUSTRATED BECAUSE
THEY'RE ONLY TRYING TO SURVIVE.
SOMETIME AGO. WE APPLY FOR
MEDICARE. THEY GAVE IT TO MY
HUSBAND AND NOT TO ME BECAUSE I
HAD NO SOCIAL. BUT IF THEY OPEN
THAT ACCOUNT FOR PEOPLE WITHOUT
STATUS WE'RE GOING TO NEED
SOMETHING THAT IDENTIFIES. US WE
HAVE WORKED FOR MANY YEARS AND
WE HAVE PAID OUR TAXES. I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE AN ID CARD TO
MAKE IT THE GOVERNMENT OFFICES.
HE ASKED MORE LIKE PEOPLE.
UNLESS LIKE PROBLEMS. REMEMBER
CHIRLA. THAT'S NOT OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE A THING ISSUE OF NOT. A
NIGHT. THEY CANNOT GET IN A
SIXTY LICENSE OR- THE TRAIN
TESTED THEY DON'T HAVE. TO HELP
THEM PREPARE. IT'S NOT SO EASY
SHOWING AN EXAM YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT. FOR ANYTHING OUT OF LINE.
WE JUST WANT TO BE AT PEACE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND MOVE. WITHIN
THE COMPETENCE. WE WANT IDEA
CORRECT IDENTIFIES THE PEOPLE
WHO BELONG IN OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. I I'M NOT BE NICE TO.
ARE GOING TO. MY NAME IS GINGER
NUMBER. ARE OF PROGRAM AND
CAMPAIGNS THE- AND AGAIN
POLICIES. AND WE ARE PRO. CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. EIGHTY
SEVEN CENTS SIXTY SIX. OP ED. TO
HELP BUILD ON EQUITY FOR AROUND
ONE POINT SIX MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS. COULD
BENEFIT FROM HAVING A STATE
GOVERNMENT ISSUED ID CARD. SO
MANY REASONS TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I WILL HIGHLIGHT THREE OF
THEM. FIRST ACCESS ID CARDS A
LOT. OF SHOWN ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. HAVING AN ID CARD
TO HELP IMMIGRANTS ACCESS STATE
COUNTY AND CITY PROGRAMS AND
BENEFITS. SUCH AS FOOD AND CASH
ASSISTANCE. AS WELL AS THE PAPER
RENTAL HOUSING. AND STREET
VENDING PERMITS. PEOPLE NEED A
VALID OF ID TO OPEN UP ACCOUNT.
CASH A CHECK GET A MARRIAGE
LICENSE. OR BUY A CAR. NOT
HAVING AN ID HAS AN IMPACT
BEYOND AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS MANY
U. S. BORN CHILDREN LIVE IN
MIXED STATUS HOUSEHOLDS. WERE
APPARENTLY UNDOCUMENTED. ONE
APPARENTLY UNABLE TO APPLY FOR%
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS FOR THE
FAMILY BECAUSE THEY LACK AN ID
THE US CITIZEN CHILDREN ARE ALSO
AFFECTED. SECOND AND IDEAS
GATEWAY TO MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION AND INCLUSION. AND
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. BOTH
DOCUMENTED AND UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS WERE UNABLE TO
OBTAIN IT IS SIXTY DRIVERS
LICENSE. SUCH AS WOMEN WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO A CAR. ELDERS
PEOPLE LEADING CORPORATION ARE
WE ENTERING THE COMMUNITIES. OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO STATE ISSUED ID
SO. EIGHTY SEVENTY SIXTY SIX.
FIND THIS BILL WOULD REVERSE LAW
STANDING AND EMIGRATE. OVER THE
LAST DECADE CALIFON HAS TAKEN
THE NEXT. STEP SIX ACCESS STATE
PROGRAM. I'VE BEEN A THAT
EXCLUDE AND NOT AND- INTEL
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR CALIFORNIA
ALLOWED ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT.
AND I CARDS OUT. HOWEVER AT THE
NINE SEVEN SIX OCCURRED
EVERYBODY APPLYING FOR A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ID CARD TO
PROVE THEIR CITIZENSHIP OR LEGAL
RESIDENCY STATUS. PROHIBITING
CONDUCT PEOPLE OBTAINING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ID CARD.
WHILE BEGINNING IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AB SIXTY PROVIDED A
ROUTE FROM DOCUMENT THE PEOPLE
GOT BY FOR DRIVER'S LICENSES
THIS GROUP OF STILL PRECLUDED
FROM ACCESSING CALIFORNIA ID.
YOU MUST REPORT OF THE STATE AND
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN
TECHNICALLY ACCESS ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES PROVIDED
BY THE DMV. FOR THE TRADE AND
SUPPORTING EIGHTY SOMETHING
SIXTY SIX AND A HALF REYES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OF WHAT. IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIXTY MY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT IS THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR A. B. SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JONATHAN GO WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TEN SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IN SCOPE
WITH THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA IS STRONG
THE COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOTES TO GO TO LINE TEN EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI ELECTED GOT-
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORIZED TO INDICATE SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. COMMUNITY ACTION
BOARD OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IN
COULD SAN DIEGO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CONSORTIUM BEND THE ARC JEWISH
ACTION SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
NATIONAL IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER
BLATANT FIFTEEN I'LL- CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
LONG BEACH EMIGRATE RIGHTS
COALITION. TO CATER TO THE-
WEALTHY PEOPLE POWER COMMUNITY
UNITED COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE USED TO THE- ECHO
CALIFORNIA. CENTRAL VALLEY
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
COLLABORATIVE INTERFAITH
MOVEMENT FOR HUMAN INTEGRITY
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND TO
LIVE WITH. THE PARTNERS
ENCOURAGED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TELEVEN THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- PERSPECTIVE POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH A LESSER TERM ALL
POVERTY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU GIVE ME. GO AHEAD.
REVENUE THAT GREW UP A LOT
THOUGH I AM ONE HAPPY CAN YOU
COME FROM THE GULF PROMOTED OF
NETLINK CALIFORNIA I DO SUPPORT
AB SEVENTEEN SIX SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE TEN
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY BACK ON A TOPIC
CAMPUS NEXT SATURDAY UNITED.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE- LEVIN ALL ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM VERY
FAINTLY WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
CALLING AND INVESTED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M NOT BLESSED WITH
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT ONE SAYS IT'S
THE INTERPRETER. THIS IS THE
RETURN MAKING OUT WITH COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHT TO
YOUR LAPTOP BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
. THANK YOU NEXT WILL GO TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NOBODY IN THE ROOM OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX AGAIN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU FOR NOT POSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR IN OPPOSITION. OF A B.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE THE SIX SEVENTY FOUR
. INGRID MORENO AND THEN
OPPOSITION OF AB. SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE SEVEN TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AM PLEASED WITH
NAVARRO NUMBER AGAIN AB DOWN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT A GOOD
SIGN ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS MARLENA TO FRAME AND I'M
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXT TO
BOTTOM LINE NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. BLIND NINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I MEAN UP OPPOSITION
AB. SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU KINDLY BECAUSE
THE PHONE LINES- NOW IS OUR TIME
FOR QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE- MISTER
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY
JOIN AUTHOR MISTER JONES SAWYER
I REQUEST AND I BOTH. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. STONE RIGHT STONE I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
. HOLDEN KALRA CALLER I MATHIS.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHEN AYE REYES
REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. SIX THAT'S HELPED. AS CAN WE JUST SAY THAT BILL
OUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
MISTER THE STAKES TO A. B. R. I.
NUMBER TWO AB. TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YOUR THING HAVE A
MILTON AND A SECOND. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM FOR JUST WORKING ON THIS
BILL ARE JUST VERY QUICKLY- THIS
BILL IS A RESPONSE TO ALL THE
UPTICK IN API. VIOLENCE THAT
REALLY STARTED DURING COVERT
BUILDER THE COUPLE VERY SIMPLE
THINGS IT JUST REQUIRES D. F. E.
H. BUT TO CREATE A TRAINING FOR
EMPLOYEES OF LARGE BUSINESSES
THAT TRAIN WORKERS ON HOW TO
RECOGNIZE REPORT IMPROPER
RESPOND TO. IT THAT THE
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
AGAINST CUSTOMERS WHO WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY CAN GO INTO
A BUSINESS WITHOUT FEAR OF
HARASSMENT- IT ALSO CREATES A
PILOT PROGRAM TO PUBLICLY
RECOGNIZED AS IT IS FOR CREATING
A SAFE AND WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT. IT ALSO REQUIRES
THE BUSINESS TO POST SIGNAGE SO
CUSTOMERS KNOW THEIR RIGHTS AND
THEN LASTLY WE WANT TO MAKE VERY
CLEAR DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
WORKER TO INTERVENE WHILE
INSTANCE OCCURRING. AND WOULD BE
PROTECTED FROM RETALIATION
LIABILITY- I HAVE- MY JEWISH-
CALL CARNEY FROM- THE API EQUITY
ALLIANCE AND CO FOUNDER OF STOP
API HIT HERE TESTIFIED SO. THANK
YOU FOR COMING UP. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD. MY NAME
IS MIND YOU SHEKEL GURNEY AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM MENTIONED
AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE API EQUITY ALLIANCE. A
COALITION OF OVER FORTY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SERVE AND REPRESENT THE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION API'S. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I AM ALSO ONE OF
THE CO FOUNDERS OF STOP ÁP I
HATE. A COAL AS COALITION TO
ADDRESS HATE AND RACISM AGAINST
API'S NATIONWIDE. I AM PLEASED
TO TESTIFIED TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FOUR FOUR EIGHT. A BILL
TO EXPAND CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS THAT LARGE
BUSINESSES WHERE HATE INCIDENTS
OCCUR. THIS BILL AS YOU KNOW IS
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG
AND SPONSORED BY STOP ÁP I HATE
. SINCE THE START OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC STOP BABY I
HATE HAS RECEIVED NEARLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND REPORTS OF HATE
INCIDENTS FROM ASIAN AMERICANS
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS A CALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. INCLUDING
MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND REPORTS
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE. A MAJORITY
OF THESE INCIDENTS ARE WERE
REPORTED BY AAPI WOMEN A VAST
MAJORITY INVOLVED CONDUCT THAT
IS NOT A CRIME LET AND LOAN I
HATE CRIME. AND THAT INCLUDES
VERBAL HARASSMENT. JUST UNDER
ONE THIRD OF THESE INCIDENTS
TOK PLACE AT BUSINESSES AT
RESTAURANTS GROCERY STORES
RETAIL STORES CAFES JAMS GAS
STATIONS IN THEIR PARKING LOTS.
THESE INCIDENTS SERIOUSLY IMPACT
OUR MENTAL HEALTH FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT OUR ABILITY TO CARE FOR
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR OVERALL
WELL BEING. TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA
OF WHAT ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING IN BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE I OFFER THREE
EXAMPLES IN THE WORDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO EXPERIENCE THEM
AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE THAT- THESE INCLUDE VERY
HARSH LANGUAGE- BUT I WILL GO
AHEAD. I WAS WAITING IN A LINE
AT A HOME IMPROVEMENT STORE A
MAN CUT IN FRONT OF ME SO I
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S A LINE
AND POINTED TO THE LINE OF
PEOPLE BEHIND ME HE BLEW UP AND
STARTED VERBALLY HARASSING ME BY
YELLING. STUPID F. ING CHANG GO
BACK TO YOUR COUNTRY BUT YOU
CAME FROM DO. DO YOU **** SPEAK
ENGLISH APOLOGIES OF THIS IS
FROM A CASE OF A IN LOS ANGELES.
EXPERIENCE BY A WOMAN WHO IS IN
HER THIRTIES. THE SECOND EXAMPLE
MY UNCLE WAS GOING TO A HOME
IMPROVEMENT STORE AND WAS
WAITING IN LINE MY UNCLE AND HIS
WIFE WERE SPEAKING IN BURMESE
AND THE PERSON THAT WAS ENOUGH
IN FRONT OF THEM KEPT LOOKING
BACK AND STARTED STEPPING AWAY.
HE BECAME FURIOUS FOR NO REASON
AND STARTED YELLING THINGS SUCH
AS YOU GUYS BROUGHT THE FLU HERE
NOW YOU HAVE TO SUFFER GO BACK
TO YOUR COUNTRY SPEAK ENGLISH
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES. THIS
WAS REPORTED BY A GENTLEMAN FROM
DALY CITY CALIFORNIA. AND THE
LAST EXAMPLE I WAS SHOPPING AT A
STORE WITH MY MASK ON A WHITE
OLDER MAN CAME UP AND STARTED
SCREAMIG AT ME SAYING YOU NEED
TO STAY TEN FEET AWAY FROM ME
YOU DISGUSTING BAT EATING BADGE.
YOU NEED TO GO BACK TO WHERE YOU
CAME FROM AND THIS WAS ONLY A
FEW MILES AWAY FROM HERE IN
DAVIS CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW THAT
API'S I NEED TO WRAP UP YES WE
KNOW THAT API'S ARE NOT ALONE IN
EXPERIENCING THE RACIALIZED
HARASSMENT AFRICAN AMERICANS. AS
WELL AS LATINOS HAVE REPORTED
HEIGHTENED RACIALIZED HARASSMENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT IS WHY
WE NEED THIS BILL THESE. OKAY
THANK YOU. SIR ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU LEAH
BARROWS ON BEHALF OF CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION CO FOUNDERS
OF THE STOCK AP I HATE COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. SEE NON OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT WILL BE TAKING
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. DEAR PARENTS PART OF
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. WE WILL GO TO
LINE AT TEN FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO HUNDRED NUMBER
NINETY NINE HE. FOUR THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO. TO ELEVEN FORTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THERE MY
NAME IS SWATI SHARMA I AM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HELPING ELSE ONE COOPERATIVE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
FOUR EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. THANK YOU KNOW NOW
MOVES TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT. SEEING NONE ARE
PRETTY WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
UP ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY. SUBACUTE SO
WE'LL GO TO LINE ELEVEN FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD YES YES MY
NAME IS DEBORAH PELLICER AND I
AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION A. B.
TWO TWO TWO THREE SORRY WE ARE
NOT TAKING ANY FURTHER
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE WE ARE ON AB TWENTY FOUR.
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE AND NINE OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE NINE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
RIGHT AND NEXT OVER TO ELEVEN
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AT THE SPEAKER MEMBERS MARGARET
GLAD STEEN ABAP CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE. I
WANT TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE FOR CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE
BILL BUT YOU WANT TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE DOCTOR AND
COULD MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
WORKABLE CAR RETAILERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS. C.
NOT VISITING YOU MAY CLOSE JUST-
RESPECT FRANCE BRAVO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES
DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. THAT BILL IS OUT
THERE RIGHT OUR FINAL BILL AB
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN NUMBER
THIRTEEN MR MAIENSCHEIN AND AS
HE'S MOVING TO THE TABLE TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA CULTURAL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES
DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MENTION AYE
REYES. RIVAS AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I THANK YOU THAT IS
THE CONSENT AGENDA IS OUT AND
THAT IS ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY NINE. RUBIO
I'D OF NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY NINE CORK ITEM
NUMBEREIGHTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FIVE PATTERSON ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO WEBER. AND ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
MIKE FONG SO I WOULD ALSO ASK IS
WE HAVE OUR LAST BILL OF OTHER
MEMBERS CAN SHOW UP PLEASE THEN
WE CAN FINISH WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT STILL NEED MOTIONS
AND SECONDS THERE'S QUITE A BIT
OF WORK TO DO. MR MAIENSCHEIN
THANK ALL OF THEM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE MR CHEN MEMBERS THE
SALE OF GAP WAIVERS IS OFTEN
TARGETED AT CONSUMERS WITH LOW
INCOME AND SUBPRIME CREDIT
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE CODE
PROVIDES A GAP WAIVERS ARE NOT
INSURANCE HOWEVER CALIFORNIA LAW
DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
THE RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES
OF SELLERS AND CONSUMERS. OF GAP
WAIVERS WITHOUT SPECIFIC
PROTECTIONS UNFAIR PRACTICES IN
THE SALE AND ADMINISTRATION OF
THESE WAIVERS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
VULNERABLE CONSUMERS AND HARM
COMPETITION. AB TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN ESTABLISHES CONSUMER
PROTECTION GUARDRAILS FOR THE
SALE OF GAP WAIVERS AND REQUIRES
THE AUTOMATIC REFUND OF THE
UNEARNED PREPAID WAIVER CHARGES
WHEN THE AUTO LOAN HAS BEEN
TERMINATED EARLY. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT CAR BUYERS ARE
COVERED THROUGH STRICTER
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS HELPING
THEM AVOID THIS COSTLY ADD ON
WHEN UNNECESSARY I APPRECIATE
THE PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM. WITH ME I HAVE
ANTHONY LIU AND BRENDAN READY ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND ROSE MERRY SHANAHAN
FROM CONSUMERS FOR AUTO
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK. THE SPONSOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA- OKAY
THANK YOU DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SO FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
ANTHONY LIU ARE YOU WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE. YES HELLO. AT THE
MORNING CARE DOWNING COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY LOSE ON THE
DEPUTY AG. ARE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA AND WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF
THE LEGISLATION. WE WANT TO
THANK A FAMILY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN LEADERS IN OFFERING
AB TWENTY THREE ELEVEN WHICH
WITHOUT WHICH CONSUMER
PROTECTION GUARD REAL. QUICK
FAILED THEM GUARANTEED ASSET
PROTECTION OR GAP- WAITERS- GAP
WAIVERS ARE ADD ON PRODUCTS THE
AUTO LOAN CONTRACT BY WHICH THE
CREDITOR AGREED TO WAIVE THE
REMAINING AMOUNT OWED ON THE
LOAN. THAT EXCEEDS THE VALUE OF
THE VEHICLE IN THE EVENT THAT
THE VEHICLE IS TOTALED OR STOLEN
AND RECOVERED. AND WON IT THANK
THAT COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
ITS EXCELLENT AND NOW AT THE BUT
THE BILL- AS NOTED ON. H. FIVE
OF THE AND NOW THE QUOTE IF THE
BILL WERE ENACTED CALIFORNIA
WOULD JOIN. AT LEAST FIFTEEN
OTHER STATE. THAT ARE PERFECT
PROTECT FOR BY OF AWAY. AT SPOT
A MOBILE DEALERS AND INSTITUTE-
HE COMES WITH LAN IN MANY STATES
. AND WE THINK THAT TOM NUMBER
OF STATE THAT GREG GAP WAIVER.
HE DEGREES OF CLOTHES TO THREE.
AND ALL OF THE STATE- YOU COULD
SAY COULD BE CONSIDERED TO BE
AHEAD OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE-
LACK THE CLEAR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
GAP WAIVERS. SO ACCORDINGLY THE
BILL STRENGTHENING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN SEVERAL KEY WHEN.
FOR EXAMPLE AT REQUIRED PREDATOR
AT THE PROBABLY REFUND THE
UNEARNED PREPAID THE GAP LABOR
CHARGES THAT THE LONER WAVERED.
AGREEMENT IF TERMINATE EARLY.
SECONDLY CAPS THE AMOUNT THAT
CAN BE CHARGED RIGHT GAP WAIVER
RELATIVE TO THE AMOUNT OF THE
LOAN AMOUNT. THIRD IT PROHIBITS
THE MAYOR THAT DO NOT COVER THE
ENTIRE AMOUNT TO FINANCE. AND
FINALLY THEY REQUIRED AUTO
DEALERS TO MAKE IMPORTANT
DISCLOSURES THE CONSUMER AT THE
GARDEN GAP WAIVERS. INCLUDING
THAT THE PRODUCT IS I'M SELLING
CANNOT BE A CONDITION TO THE
LOAN OR IF THEY'LL TURN-
EVERYTHING PROPOSAL FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT WE- HAVE WE
COULD WE'RE NOT ABLE TO BE
INVOLVED IF YOU FULL TIME A MAN
WE TAKE IN THE COMING TODAY BUT
WE'RE OUT. COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. I MEAN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. I AND AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN TODAY AND ON THE
LINE AS DEPUTY AG BRENDAN READY
WITH AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL. QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HEY WE ALSO. HAVE ROSE
MERRY ST. CHAIRMAN DOWN BY
TEACHER CUNNINGHAM AND MEMBERS
I'M ROSEMARY SHE CAN'T PRESENT
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT AUTISTIC TEEN CONSUMER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION BUT IT'S
SPEARHEADED NUMEROUS FLAWS IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY. TO
PROVE PROTECTIONS FOR OWNERS OF
NEW AND USED VEHICLES AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN AND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN CHAMPIONING THIS
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY MEASURE. AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA FOR SPONSORING
THIS BILL WE CONCUR WITH THE
TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY THE OFFICE
OF ATTORNEY GENERAL CONTACT.
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN WILL HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
THE WORST ABUSES INVOLVING GAP
WAIVERS BENEFITING CALIFORNIA
VEHICLE OWNERS IN MULTIPLE
IMPORTANT WAYS AND RATHER THAN
REPEAT THOSE- BUT TO SAVE IT WE
TOTALLY ARE IN SYNC WITH THE
AG'S OFFICE ON EACH OF THOSE
POINTS. AND I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT AMONG THE STATES THAT
OFFERS SUPERIOR STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS ARE INDIANA NEVADA
TEXAS UTAH. AND WYOMING. USUALLY
TOP IN THE READ THE IN
PROTECTING AUTO OWNERS AND
MINUTES WE'RE SORELY BEHIND- AND
- ONE THE BEST PARTS OF THE BILL
CLOSE TO THE GAS IN GAP COVERAGE
. BY DISALLOWING THE SALE OF
PARTS GAP WAIVER HOPING OVER THE
FINAL SH VICTIMS OF THEFT OR
CRASHES EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY
DISCOVERED THAT THE GAP WAIVER
THAT THEY BOUGHT AT THE
DEALERSHIP FAILS TO COVER THE
AMOUNTS THAT THEY STILL MUST PAY
FOR THEIR AUTO LOAN. AND FOR ALL
THE MEANS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I VOTE FOR AB
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU READ UP IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN IN THE HEARING
ABOUT IT. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN AGAIN WE'RE ONLY
TAKING NAME. AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S THE
ONE AND THEN THEIR APPEARANCE A
PART OF AB TWENTY THREE ELEVEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANNY CANNOT CUTS ARE ON BEHALF
OF BOTH THE NATIONAL CONSUMER
LAW CENTER AND THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GETTING OF THE CARE OF
ON THE TOP OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION I HAVE TIMOTHY ME
HAN ON THE TELEPHONE AS WELL AS
ANTHONY. SAMPSON I'M SORRY
TIMOTHY MEAN IN THE TWENTY
MINUTE ARE YOU WITH US ON THE
PHONE. YES I AM MISTER CHAIRMAN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS TIM MINAMI EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE GUARANTEED ASSET
PROTECTION ALLIANCE ALSO KNOWN
AS GAP WE ARE THE NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR LENDERS INSURERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS THAT TOGETHER
PROVIDE- THE MAJORITY OF GAP
WAIVERS OFFERED THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS WE'VE WORKED IN-
OVER FORTY STATES TO ENACT
LEGISLATION NO SURE THAT HAPPENS
PROVIDED WITH PROPER DISCLOSURE
STRONG FINANCIAL BACKING IN A
WAY THAT ASSURES CONSUMERS ARE
PROTECTED. IN FACT SOME OF THE
STATES THAT THE EARLIER SPEAKER
MENTIONED- CONTAIN THE MODEL
ACCIDENT KAPPA- DEVELOPED IT HAS
TAKEN ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
NOT ADOPTED OVER HALF THE STATE
SO FAR. I SINCE BEEN SAID NOT
INSURANCE UPON GAP WAIVER. AND I
GO A GOOD. OF HOW GAP WORKS IS A
CONSUMER MIGHT BORROW THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO PURCHASE
CAR. AND IF IT'S TOTALED IN AN
ACCIDENT OR IF IT'S STOLEN THE
COLLISION INSURANCE COMPANY
MIGHT SEND A CHECK FOR TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. LEAVING
THE CONSUMER WITH NO CAR AND
FIVE THOUSAND AND REMAINING THAT
ON THE CAR. YEAH APTOSE WAVE
EITHER ALL OR PART OF THAT
AMOUNT DEPEND UPON THE TERMS OF
THE GAP AGREEMENT AND I CAN TELL. YOU THAT AS CONSUMER PRODUCTS
GO. GAP WAIVERS PAY AN AWFUL OF
TWENTY AND CAL. ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. TODAY WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN IN ITS CURRENT FORM
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER ALONG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION OUTLINING- THE
AMENDMENTS NEEDED TO MAKE THIS
BILL BETTER. WE DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMAN MENTIONS
WILLINGNESS TO SIT DOWN WITH US
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
DISCUSS WAYS THAT LEGISLATION
COULD BE AMENDED TO ASSURE
CONSUMER PROTECTION BUT ONE AT
THE SAME TIME NOT IT SHOULD BUT
THE PROVISION OF THIS IMPORTANT
PRODUCT. FRST I WOULD SAY THAT
WE DO AGREE WITH SOME WOMEN'S
GOAL OF ASSURING THAT IF A
PERSON DECIDES TO TERMINATE. THE
CREDIT AGREEMENT EARLY FOR
EXAMPLE THEY WANT TO. TRADE THE
CAR IN OR THEY JUST THEY GOT A
TAX CHECK IN THE MAIL AND I WANT
TO PICK THE CAR UP EARLY. THERE
DOES NEED TO BE A PROCESS TO
AUTOMATICALLY REQUIRE THE
CONSUMER GETS A REFUND. I'LL BE
HONOR AND PORTION OF THE
CONTRACT WITHOUT THE CONSUMER
HAVING TO REQUEST THAT REFUND.
WE SOUGHT LEGISLATION DOING
EXACTLY THAT IN OTHER STATES IT
IS A COMPLICATED PROCESS HOWEVER
TO REFUND GAP. BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY PARTIES INVOLVED INCLUDING
THE CAR DEALER THE CATHOLIC
MINISTRY- THE LANDER AND
INSURANCE SO WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO GET THE
WORDING IN PLACE TO MAKE IT
WORKABLE. WE ALSO THINK THAT IT
IS EXTREMELY. TO HAVE- TO
PROVIDE THE GAP REFUND AMOUNT-
EVERY TIME. THE LENDER WOULD
COMMUNICATE WITH THE CUSTOMER.
THAT WOULD BE EVERY MONTH THEY
SEND ABOUT A STATEMENT. SHOWING
HOW MUCH IS LEFT ON THE LOAN OR
A CUSTOMER CALLED IN BECAUSE
THEY'RE MAKING A LATE PAYMENT.
THEY WOULD HAVE THEY WOULD HAVE
TO BE A NEW CALCULATION EVERY
SINGLE TIME THAT HAPPENS- WE-
DISAGREE WITH PLACING A CAP ON
THE AMOUNT THAT CAN BE CHARGED
FOR THESEWAIVERS. ONLY THREE
STATES TAKE THAT APPROACH. BUT
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY RELIANT
ON COMPETITION AND I CAN TELL
YOU. BOUGHT A CAR RECENTLY YOU
KNOW THAT- COMPETITIONS VERY
MUCH ALIVE AT CAR DEALERSHIPS
THEY WANT TO DEAL AND THEY WANT
THE LOWEST COST FOR THEIR
CONSUMERS SIR I NEED TO WRAP UP
WE WANT TO CLARIFY THAT. YES I
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
HERE BY ALL IN ALL WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
ASSEMBLY WHEN MAIENSCHEIN AND
AGAIN ASSEMBLY. OPPOSE THE BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. AND THEN
ANTHONY SAMPSON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY SAMPSON THE
SAMPSON ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION ONLINE MY COMMENTS-
WITH THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
KAPPA- I SEE IN CDA STAKE IN THE
PRESENCE AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WILLINGNESS
TO ENGAGE IN A DIALOGUE WITH US
REGARDING OUR CONCERNS- I'LL
JUST START OFF BY. STATING THAT
WE UNDERSTAND FROM OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT
ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES
THAT THE BILL SEEKING TO ADDRESS
IS TO ENSURE THAT ANY UNDER THE
MOUNTAINS THAT CAR BUYERS BUYERS
PAID FOR GAP WAIVERS ARE
PROMPTLY AND AUTOMATICALLY.
REFUNDED IF THEY PAY OFF THEIR
LOANS EARLIER CANCEL GAP
PROTECTION. TNC GAVE VERY MUCH
AGREES THAT IT IS CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE PROMPT PAYMENT OF ANY
GAP PROTECTION. REFUND DUE TO
THE CONSUMER INTO THIS AND- WE
SUPPORT THE UNDERLYING INTENT OF
THE MEASURE. WE HAVE SOME
COMPLEX CONCERNS WITHTHE WAY IN
WHICH THE BILL SEEKS TO
EFFECTUATE THOSE REFUNDS AND
WE'VE SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHORED AND SPONSORED HOPES WE
CAN. REACH AN AGREEMENT ON THAT
ISSUE. MORE GENERALLY I JUST
WANT TO KNOW FOR THE COMMITTEE
THAT FOR MANY CONSUMERS GAP
PROTECTION PROVIDE THE
RELATIVELY LOW COST METHOD TO
SECURE PEACE OF MIND TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE POSSIBILITY OF
HAVING TO MAKE PAYMENTS. ON A
VEHICLE THEY NO LONGER OWN FOR
MONTHS OR YEARS. ESPECIALLY WITH
BOTH NEW AND USED VEHICLE PRICES
REACHING RECORD HIGHS IN RECENT
YEARS DUE TO SUPPLY CHAIN
CONSTRAINTS AND THE REALITY THAT
MANY AMERICANS CANNOT AFFORD
FOOTBALL FOR THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS DOWN ON A VEHICLE
PURCHASE. GAP PROTECTION COULD
PROVIDE A VALUABLE IMPORTANT
SAFEGUARDS CONSUMERS THE RECENT
STUDY FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN SHOWED THAT MANY
CONSUMERS HAVE CHOSEN TO
PURCHASE GAP PROTECTIONS THE
MEANS OF PROTECTING AGAINST
LOSSES AND PURCHASERS.
OVERWHELMINGLY REPORTED. THEIR
SATISFACTION WITH THE PRODUCT.
WE UNDERSTAND THE CONSUMER OUT
OF WITH ANY PRODUCT OF THE
MESSES MAKE PRODUCT PERFECT. AND
SO WHILE SHE IN CDA WISHES TO
WORK WITH THE- IN THE ATTORNEY.
LAW TOREACH A SOLUTION THAT
MAKES FOR ALL. CMCT BELIEVES.
THAT THE BILL IN ITS FORM IT'S
PROBLEMATIC FOR SOME OF THE
REASONS OUTLINED BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
RESOLVING THOSE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN. TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION ALBEIT FOR
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT REASONS IN
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE I'D SAY NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN. THANK YOU
THEY'RE NOT POSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
PROPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN. OKAY ONE MOMENT. WELL WE
GET PROVIDER LIGHT NUMBERS AGAIN
WE'RE ON AB TWENTY THREE ELEVEN
IN OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO
LINE. HELLO. NINE ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR HAIRMAN
MEMBERS THAT ANY WRITER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURERS ASSOCIATION
ALIGNING OURSELVES WITH THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS FROM THE
GENTLEMAN FROM KAPPA WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THAT
WITH THE AUTHOR SPONSOR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINE
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE THIS MENTION YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MERCED- PLEASE DATA TO
PRESENT THIS IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION- BILL. AND THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ASSESSMENTS FORWARD
RESPECTED REQUESTS AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. DAVIES NO
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
HI MATHIS. MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN I. REYES REYES I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I. THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SINCE WE HAVE MOST
EVERYBODY HERE I WANNA ROLL
THROUGH THE AGENDA FAIRLY
QUICKLY WE HAVE BUILT OUR CALL
AND OTHERS THAT NEED MOTIONS BUT
WE WILL START FROM THE TOP.
LET'S START WITH CONSENT CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM
KALRA. COLORI OKAY ITEM NUMBER
ONE IS ON CALL THIS IS AB TWO
ZERO NINE ONE BONTA I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL. CUNNINGHAM
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IS OUT BUT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY ARAMBULA NEEDS A MOTION.
SECOND THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES DAVIES I
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAINTAIN AYE REYES
REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE THREE OF US
THREE OF US THANK YOU THE BILL
IS OUT. I AM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE ARAMBULA
NEEDS A MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE KALRA. KALRA I MATHIS MATHIS
NOTE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. THANK YOU THAT
BILLS OUT ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE BLOOM-
TAKE A MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES REYES AYE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I THANK
YOU THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
SIX A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE
CALDERON I'LL TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES.
DAVIES I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA
KALRA AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. THANK YOU I
REMEMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX FRIEDMAN IS ON CALL I'M
GONNA LIFT THE CALL. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I MATHIS MATHIS NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT OF
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE JONES SAWYER IS ON
CALL I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
KALRA KALRA I MATHIS MATHIS NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I REYES
REASSIGN THANK YOU THE BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
TWO OH THREE THREE OF US IS ON
CALL A MODEL IF THE CALL
CUNNINGHAM. MATHIS MATHIS NO
MAIENSCHEIN. REYES REYES HI
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU. ADAM NUMBER
TEN WAS ON CONSENT OF NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE SALAS IS OUT BUT WILL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I THANK YOU I DON'T
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT TANG IS OUT BECAUSE
WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
KALRA COLORI THANK YOU I DON'T
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN MAIN CHINA'S OUT CALL ANY
OF THE MEMBERS. JUST CUNNINGHAM
OKAY THE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A.
B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX STONE IS
OUT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
HOLDEN. OKAY I REMEMBER FIFTEEN
AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN DAVIESS OUT
CALL IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN LOW IS ON
CALL I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
KALRA KALRA AYE MATHIS. IF YOU
WE HAVE THE- SUPPORT. MATHIS I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I'VE
REYES REYES I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I ALL RIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT. IS THIS CUNNINGHAM
COMING BACK. OKAY. YEAH QUICKLY
MISTER CUNNINGHAM BECAUSE WE
NEED MAKE HERE SO WE HAVE THE
NEXT. COMMITTEE HEARING. BACK ON. IF YOU WERE OUT HE WALKED TO.
I GUESS ROTH ARE STUFF THERE'S
MUCH I CAN DO LOT ABOUT THAT IS
PROBABLY LOCAL. AS MISSED HOLDEN
THIS WHOLE. I HAVE A ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN A. B. SEVENTY C. SIX
STONE. HOLDEN HOLDEN I. THANK
YOU. OKAY WE JUST NEED MISTER
CUNNINGHAM.
THIRTY EIGHT TO DO THIS BUT THIS
THIS HEARING ROOM NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE ON TO ANOTHER ONE.
I AM SORRY BUT WE ARE NOW GOING
TO ADJOURN THIS COMMITTEE AND
ALLOW THIS ROOM TO BE TURNED
OVER SO WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.